hey everyone welcome back to another
video session by simply learn
in this session on c plus plus full
course for beginners we will be learning
different concepts and topics of c plus
this video tutorial will help in
learning and understanding the c plus
plus programming language in both
theoretical and practical way by doing
some hands-on examples
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and press the
bell icon to never miss an update
so we'll start with the introduction to
c plus programming language and how to
download and install c plus in windows
then we will start with the first
program in c plus along with the terms
like variables types then the concepts
like if else statements loops functions
in c plus plus call by value call by
reference and friend function
then we will cover topics like arrays
pointers in c plus plus this pointer
references and memory management
we will also learn about sorting in c
plus
after that we will move on to object
oriented programming topics like classes
in c plus plus oops concepts etc and
after that we will move on to topics
like vectors in c plus plus stl that is
standard template library and in the end
we'll also learn to make some projects
in c plus
so without further ado
let's get started
so let's start with the introduction to
c plus plus programming
c plus plus is a popular programming
language introduced by john strawstrop
in the year 1979 the aim was to make a
dynamic language that is efficient and
has some additional features to see
initially it was called c with glasses
as it was an extension to c language but
later renamed as c plus
it is general purpose case sensitive
language and it is called pre-compiled
language because it converts the source
code directly to the machine
understandable code
it is an intermediate level language
because it contains both features of
high level and low level language
c plus plus supports the features of
object oriented language like
encapsulation inheritance polymorphism
etc it also supports procedural
programming and functional programming
as well
welcome to this video where we'll be
telling you how you can install c plus
on vs code and dev c plus after we are
done with installation we'll also learn
how to run a program on both of these
code editors
so we'll start with visual studio code
to download vs code let's go to google
and search for visual studio code
or vs code
we'll click on this first link
this is the official web page for
downloading the visual studio code
and we'll now click on this download for
windows blue button
and now we'll click on download now
here it is getting download and
as you can see thanks for downloading
visual studio code for windows
once we are done with the download we
can click on this open folder
here it is
now we need to install this file so
we'll double click on this file
and this is a setup wizard
we'll click on this i accept the
agreement
and we'll click on next
as we have accepted the licensing
agreement now
we can select our destination folder or
we can leave it as it is but make sure
there must be 293.2 mb of free space on
that particular disk space
now
we'll click on next
here we can again click on x there is no
need to change over here
and now
you can click on this create a desktop
icon button
or anyone else as per your choice
now we'll click on next
and now we'll click finally on install
it is getting installed it will take
some time
now we can click on this finish button
launch visual studio we have marked it
it is already marked so when we click on
this finish button it will launch the
visual studio code
so as we can see this is the visual
studio code
so as we have installed vs code now we
have to configure it so that the c plus
programs can run in this code editor
so in order to do that we need to add
some extensions so we'll click on this
extensions button
now here we will write code runner
extension
right code runner
and this is extension
then click on this install
and it is getting installed
there are some instructions we can click
on control plus alt plus n
or press f1 and then select type run
code
but we'll deal with that later
now
[Music]
we'll add another extension that is
c
slash c plus plus
here it is
we'll click on this install
here you can see downloading visual
studio windows debugger
it is getting installed and i think it
is installed now
so as we have added both the extensions
so let's move on and do a program of cps
plus in this code editor
we can define strings as a collection or
group of characters
it is basically used to represent text
in the program
and we can perform many operations on
strings in order to manipulate it
the syntax of string contains a
collection of characters surrounded by
double quotes for example here string is
the type
str is the name of the string and coffee
is the value that is assigned to the
string
in c plus there are two ways to create a
string
first is c style strings
in c style strings collection of
characters are stored in the form of
arrays they are basically areas of type
character
the second way is using string objects
we can create string object to hold a
string
they are implemented in the standard
library which we must include in the
program using hash include
so here we will do an example of string
and we'll do some push back and pop back
operation on it
so first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include iostream
then using namespace standard
namespace standard
okay now
we'll start with int main
all right first of all we'll write
string
data type
then the name of the string
s
here s is the name of the string
all right now
first of all we will display a message
to enter a string
so
okay enter a string
now
get line
this is the syntax when you want to take
the input
of a string
so
get line c in is used to take the input
and s is the name of the string
so this is how we take the input
and
now we will print another message saying
that
you have entered
now here we will print the string s
next line
and then
okay
now we'll do some operations like s dot
push back
this will add an element at the end of
the string
so
let's say we want to add
y
so we'll write y inside the bracket
s dot push back and inside the bracket
with the single quotes we'll try it
y
now
we'll display a message saying
after
after using
pushback function
we'll print the string
that is after using the function push
back the string would look like this
and
now
we'll use another function as dot pop
back
it will delete the element from the end
so
we'll write c out
and we'll display the message
after using pop back function
let's write pop back only
and we'll print the
string
okay
now after that we'll write return zero
and i think it's done only the spelling
is wrong over here
okay
yeah now let's try to run this
as you can see the message enter a
string
so let's say i have entered
barcelona
so you have entered barcelona after
using pushback barcelona y
because we have used y over here we want
to add y at the end of the string
so after using pushback barcelona y
and
pop back function after that we have
used and we know that it will delete the
element from the end so
here we can see there is no y
power back function have deleted the
element
so this is our output
next is if-else statements
if else are two conditional statements
that are generally used when we want to
run the code based on some conditions
we run a block of code which is inside
if statement only if the condition is
true for example
if the number variable here is equal to
10
then only the block of code will execute
and will print the message you got it
otherwise it will run the else block and
display the message written inside that
block which is not this one so first of
all we'll create a new file
we'll go to file and click on this new
file
now in order to save this one we can
click on control s or we can go over
here and click on this save as
now we can select the location
like let's keep it over here only
let's name it as
visual dot cpp
dot cpp is the extension which is used
when we want to do a program in c plus
plus now we'll click on this save button
now let's do a simple program to check
whether the program is running on this
code editor or not
so we'll include the header files
i should include iostream
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll write int main
now inside int main will display a
message
welcome to this video
okay now return zero
make sure to
save this
after making changes or you can click on
control s
or you can go to file
and click on this save
so once you have saved the program now
you can run it
we can click on this play button it will
run the code
as we can see in the output
welcome to this video we can see
here it is
so
it means our program is working it is
running fine
now let's do another example in which we
will take the inputs from the user
so let's make a new file
we'll go to file and click on this new
file
now
we'll save as
and we'll write
visual
to dot cpp
all right in this program we'll take the
input from the user
so start with header files hash include
iostream
our spelling is wrong
hash include iostream after that
using namespace standard
now inside int main
will take the inputs from the user
will display the message
enter the
first
number
now using c in
we'll take the input
we forgot to mention this
declare this n1 variable
so
write int n1
and n2
and int
sum equals 0
all right here we have taken the input
of n1 the first number
now we'll take the input of another
number
by displaying the message
enter the second number
we'll write n2
now we'll
add both of these
and one plus
n2
and we'll display the result
we'll write end line
so that it looks good
all right now we need to save it
we'll go to file
and click on this save
now it is saved now we can run this
program
we will click on this run code
now in order to write the first number
over here that is in order to write in
the terminal we have to configure the
visual studio code
and to do that
we'll go to file
and we'll now go to preference
and in the settings we'll click on the
settings
and here we will type run in terminal
all right now we can scroll down
and here we can see code runner run in
terminal in my via studio it is already
marked but you have to mark this if you
want to
write in terminal or enter the inputs in
the terminal
all right once you have marked this you
can
close it and
then you can control s that is save
and then you can
close the vs studio and then open it
again
once you are done
now
let's try to run this
so now you will be able to write the
inputs
like let's say
4
the first number is 4
now the second number let's say
9
on addition it becomes 13 which is the
right answer
so these were some configurations that
you need to do if you want to run a
program of c plus in visual studio code
so as we have understood how to download
and configure visual studio code for c
plus plus programs so let's move on to
learn how we can download dev c plus
plus and run c plus programs in that
so let's go to google
and type dev c plus plus
this is the first link
we'll click on that now this is the
green button
saying download will click on that to
download dev c plus plus
as you can see it is getting downloaded
your download will start shortly
so now we'll click on download now
now it is getting downloaded
it will take a while the size of this
file is 48.1 mb
so as you can see the downloading is
almost done
so the downloading is complete now we'll
click on open folder
here it is dev c plus plus setup
now we'll click on this
setup
we'll click on yes
the setup is loading
so now here we will select the preferred
language it is english we'll click on ok
now
we'll click on this is the license
agreement we'll click on i agree
now
we'll click on next
we don't need to change this i think the
space required is
346.8 mb
and we'll click on next
now if you want to change the
destination folder you can
but i don't want to change it so i'll
click on install
now it is getting installed
it will take a while
it's done and now we'll click on finish
and it is marked
so when we click on finish it will
launch the dev c plus plus
so here we have to select the language
it is english so we'll click on next
here again we'll click on next and now
we'll click on ok
so this is our code editor that is dev c
plus plus
so let's write a code
first of all let's create a file
we'll go to file and go to new and we'll
click on source file
all right now we need to save this one
and in order to save this we'll click on
file then we'll go to save as
and now we'll select the destination
and name it as
dev dot cpp
all right now let's start
with the header file
hash include iostream
we'll do a simple program over here
using namespace
std
because we want to check
that whether the program is running in
this editor or not
namespace std
now we'll write int main
insight into main will
display a message
welcome
to
dev
c plus
all right after that we'll write return
zero
now let's try to run this
and in order to run this program we'll
go to execute
and now we'll click on compile and run
here this is the pop-up welcome to dev c
plus plus as we can see this is the
output
now press any key to continue it will
close this window
so our output is correct welcome to dev
c plus plus so this is how you can run a
program in dev c plus
and
our program was also working fine in the
visual studio code
so this is how you can download both of
these code editors to run the c plus
plus programs today we'll be discussing
about loops in c plus
so let's begin and see what's in it for
you
so we are going to be learning today
about why loops
what is a loop
then different types of loops like for
loop while loop do while loop then there
is nested loop
after that there are control flow
statements like break and continue
but before we begin if you are new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting tech videos
so let's start with the first topic that
is while loops
in order to perform a particular task or
operation many number of times we need
loops
these are used when we want to execute a
block of statement repeatedly rather
than just writing those statements again
and again
for example imagine you want to display
your name on the screen 50 times
now to do that there are two methods
method one is writing your name 50 times
by doing the hard code
and method 2 is writing your name once
with the loop condition and your name
will be automatically displayed 50 times
now it is pretty obvious that you would
prefer the second approach because you
don't have to put effort in writing your
name 50 times plus it is easy to write
code in few lines
so method two is the functionality of
loop
it reduces time in writing the code plus
it increases the simplicity
now let's understand what is a loop
loops in computer programming is a
series of tasks that are used to run
some particular code repeatedly until a
specific condition is met loops tells
the computer when to start the condition
and when to stop it
now this is a basic flow of a loop after
the initialization the condition is
checked if it's true then the block of
statement will get executed as long as
the condition is true and if the
condition is false the loop will
terminate
depending on the program different types
of loops are used in different times
so let's first see different types of
loops
first is for loop then while loop then
there is do while loop
after that there is nested loop
these are four types of loops in c plus
plus so let's discuss these loops
first is for loop it is a repetition
control structure that is used to
iterate a piece of code based on the
condition is true or false if the
condition is true the statement inside
the low body is executed and once if it
returns false the execution of statement
will get terminated
and after every execution of for loop
the increment on decrement parts will
update the loop counter
now let's move on to the while loop
in this loop the condition is evaluated
first if it's true then the set of
instructions inside the loop body will
execute and this will happen repeatedly
until the condition becomes false
and when it becomes false the loop will
end
now the main difference is we use for
loops when we know the number of times
the body of the loop needs to run
whereas we use while loops when we don't
know the accurate number of times the
body of loop needs to run
now moving to the next loop that is do
while loop
this loop is quite similar to the while
loop in this the loop will execute the
set of instructions once before checking
if the condition is true
after that it will repeat the loop as
long as the condition is true
that means
in do while loop body will execute at
least once irrespective of the test
condition
now coming to the nested loop
when one loop is defined inside the body
of another loop then it is known as
nested loop
in c plus plus there are at least 256
levels of nesting
and the flow of execution for nested
loop is first it includes initialization
of variable followed by condition one if
it gets satisfied then it will search
for the second condition if that also
gets satisfied then it will get
increment and when the condition gets
satisfied it will search for the new set
of statements
and follows the same flow of execution
in c plus break statements are used to
terminate the execution of the loop
and by terminating the execution of loop
we means finishing or stopping the
execution
like if we want to block or terminate a
loop at some point all we need to do is
to use the break statement with a
condition
on which we want the loop to stop and it
will terminate the loops flow or
iterations
so break statements are mainly used for
two cases
one is it can be used inside the loop
and second is
it is mostly used in switch statements
and this is the loop's flow diagram
in which first there is a loop body then
if the condition is true then there is a
break statement which will terminate the
loop and if the condition is not true
then the loop will continue to iterate
as you can see in this example the loop
is iterating from 0 to 10. inside the
loop there is a condition and then the
break statement which will make sure
that the loop will terminate when i
becomes equal to 4 after the break
statement the control will jump out of
the loop body and that's how the break
statement works its output would be
0 1 2 3
it will not exceed 4 because of the
break statement
now coming to continue statement the
continue statement is a bit similar to
the break statement as it is also used
for termination
but the difference is that it is used to
terminate the current iteration and not
the complete loop for example if a loop
is hydrating from 0 to 6 and inside the
loop there is a continue statement on 4
then all the elements will be printed
except for
because continue statement skips that
particular iteration and continues with
the next one
and in break statement the complete loop
flow terminates
so when the continue statement is used
then within the loop the control skips
or terminates that particular iteration
and continues with the next iteration
as you can see in this example
first loop body
then there is a condition
if that is true then the continue
statement will terminate and continues
it with the next iteration and if that
is false then control will go to the
remaining part of the as always
now in this example we are using
continue statement here the loop is
iterating from 0 to 10
inside the loop there is a condition and
then the continue statement
which will make sure that if the value
of i becomes 4 then terminate that
iteration and moves to the next
situation
after that elements are getting printed
with the help of c out function
now its output would be one two three
five
six seven eight nine
it will not display four because of
continue statements as we know that the
continue statement skip that particular
iteration so when we use i equals 2
equals to 4
then it skips that particular iteration
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
alright so as we have covered the
theoretical part so now let's do some
examples on breaking continuous
statements in our code editor that is vs
code
now we'll make a new file
and we'll name that file as
loops dot cpp
okay
oops one dot cpp
now here we will do a program in which
we have to print the digits from 0 to 10
using for loops
it will be a basic program just to
understand it
write the header file
hash include iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now here is the int
now we will write the for loop with a
for keyword
inside the for loop
we'll initialize i with 0
now we'll put a condition i less than
equal to 10
which means
the loop will keep on executing until i
is less than 10.
now
we'll put increment
i plus plus
now inside the loop brackets all we have
to do is to print i
so that all the digits
get printed
so now let me tell you here what we are
doing is
we are just making the loop to run from
0 to 10 as we can see that i have made i
0
to i less than equal to 10 that means
loop will move from i 0 to 10.
now let's try to run it
here we can see
all the digits zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
here is our answer and
let me tell you one thing more to put
return zero
after the loop it's a good practice
now i'll again run it
the output will be the same but it's a
good practice to write return 0 in the
end
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
so instead of writing the hard code we
can just use the for loop in this case
it's a basic example of for loop but you
can try some more examples in order to
understand it better
now let's do one example of while loop
to understand it better
we'll be doing a basic example of while
loop in which all we have to do is to
print happy new year 11 times
let's start
first of all let's name this file
loops2.cpp
now let's start with the header file
that is hash include iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now here's the name
now first of all we'll declare n equal
zero we'll take a variable n and
initialize it with zero
now we'll put the while condition with
the while keyword writing while
n
not equal to 11.
here what it means is
the loop will keep on executing until n
becomes
equal to 11
now here all we have to do is to print
happy new year so that it will get
printed along with the loop 11 times
handle
now we will write n plus
we have written n plus plus so that the
loop will keep on incrementing every
single time
after that now we'll write return 0
outside the loop
now we'll try to run this
so here's our output
happy new year 11 times so this is how
it's done
this is again a basic example of while
loop but to understand it better one
must practice some more examples on it
now let's do one example of do while
loop also
let's make a new file
first of all let's name that file
loops three dot cpp
i think the name is already taken
then we'll write loops four dot cpp
okay now so we'll write the header file
first of all
we'll write
hash include iostream
after that using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
we have to print the sum of all the
digits from 0 to 9.
so let's start
we'll write intern
so now let's first of all declare a
counting variable sum and initialize it
with zero
now we will initialize another variable
i
with zero
now the syntax of do while loop is
do keyword
and now we will add some code inside the
body
we'll write
sum equals sum plus i
here what we are doing is we are simply
adding some variable and i variable and
storing it to some variable itself
we are doing this because we want to
find the sum
that is why we have to store it in a
single variable
now we will need to increment i or else
loop is going to run forever
now we will write file
i less than 10 we have
written i less than 10 because we want
to find the sum from 0 to 9
and make sure to put a semicolon in the
end in case of do while loop
now we will print
some
in this while loop
will write sum is
sum variable
now this loop will keep on executing
till i is less than 10.
now in the do while loop sum is
calculated by repeated addition and
increment
in each repetition it is checked whether
the number i is smaller or equal to the
inputted number
if it is smaller than the loop continues
but exits the loop if it isn't
after the control exits from the loop
some is printed
now let's try to run this code
here it is
sum is 45
which is the right answer this is our
output
so this is how
it is done in two while loop
so now let's do one example of our last
loop that is nested loop
first of all we'll name the file
loops
pipe dot cpp
now we'll start with the header files
now using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print a star pattern of half pyramid
form
using nested loop
so let's try
we'll write in
now let's initialize two variables that
is i
and j
now let's say we want to make a half
ramid of 10 rows
then it means we need to run a loop
which runs for 10 times
so let's write
or
initialize it to 0.
i less than
10
i plus plus
now here we have written i less than 10
instead of this we will write i less
than equal to 10 because we want the
tenth row to be printed also
now we will print slash n
in order to insert a new line
now we will write another for
loop which will decide
number of stars in a particular row
so we'll write j equal to 1
because
this for loop is for the column section
then j less than equal to i
which is a row
then g plus plus
now we'll print
star
now one more thing instead of 0 we'll
write i equals to 1
because we want to print stars from 1 to
10.
so now let's discuss it's working
initially we have i equals to 1 that is
the outer loop value
now for this value a complete run of jth
loop is happening
that is j equal to 1 validated by j less
than equal to i
now this condition is used because the
pattern which we are going to build
is having increment of star as the
number of rows increments
so for i equals to 1
j equals to 1 is executed
then j plus plus is done
which increments the value of j to 2.
now j equals to 2 failed to execute as 2
is less than equal to 1 is false
therefore only 1 star is printed
[Music]
again we go to ith loop
now for i equal to 2 we will check every
value of j which can be executed that is
1 and 2.
since only 2 values can be true
therefore 2 star are printed
similarly we check for i equal to 3 4 5
and so on till 9 as we have the
condition i is less than 10
so now we will try to run this
and check
whether the pattern is printing or not
here it is
half pyramid form using stars
with the help of
nested loops
so this is our star pattern
we can make some more different types of
patterns using nested loops
but we have done only one example in
order to understand the concept
so now let's move to our control flow
statements
and let's do some examples of them
okay now
make a new file
and let's name this file as
control 1
dot cpp
now we'll write the header file and the
name space standard as we have done
previously
so let's do it
dash include
live stream
using namespace std
now here
we will write a program in which we have
to print the numbers from 100 to 200
like 110 120 130 with a gap of 10
but after 150 we will terminate the
ongoing loop
now how can it be done with the help of
break statement
so let's start
first of all we'll write intimate
now we'll take a variable num
and initialize it with hundred
now we'll write a while condition
and we'll write num is less than equal
to 200
because we want the loop to run from 100
to 200
num less than equal to 200
now we'll simply display those numbers
now we'll write an if condition that if
num equals 150
then we'll terminate the loop and for
that we have to write the break
statement inside the if statement
so let's write
if num equals equals 150
then we have to break
the loop
write the break statement
now after that we'll increment this
by 10
we're incrementing this by 10 because we
want
the numbers to be printed like 100 10
120 like this
that is why we are incrementing it with
10 and not with one
now we'll write out of the loop
just to be informed that we are finally
out of the loop
return 0
now we'll try to run this
here we can see yeah here we can see 110
120
up to 150 after that we are out of the
loop
this means
the code works fine
so this is the example of a break
statement
now after this we'll do another example
of
continue
so let's start
let's make a new file
and name it
control2.cpb
now we'll write the header files
[Music]
using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print the numbers from 100 to 90
only excluding 96 from them
now how do we do it with the help of
continue statement
so let's start
first of all we'll write into main
now we'll declare a variable
num
and initialize it with hundred
now we'll write a while condition
while loop in which we write the
condition
num greater than equal to
90 because we want the loop to run till
it is equal to 90
that is why we have wrote greater than
equal to 90 basically we want the loop
to run from 100 till it becomes equal to
90.
now inside the loop we'll write the if
condition
in order to skip 96
so we'll write
if
num equals 96 num
quilts equals 96.
now we'll use a decrement operator
because our starting point is 100 our
ending point is 90 that is why we have
to use the decrement operator
now continue statement
after that
write
value is
and will write the variable number
now we'll write num minus minus
here we are writing minus minus because
we want it to get decrement after
printing also
that is why we have written num minus
minus after printing num
now let's try to run this also hope it
works
okay i think there are some errors
so
[Music]
some brackets were missing
and we'll write return 0
now we'll try to run it
here it is
as you can see
199.98 97
but 96 is missing
so this is all we have to do in this
program
and this is the basic example of
continue statement
in order to understand these examples
better you must try more examples on
each of these loops and control flow
statements so that it will be easier for
you all today we'll be discussing about
c plus functions
so let's go ahead and look what's in it
for us
first we'll discuss what is a function
then we'll understand why we use
functions
then types of functions like built-in
function and user-defined function
then function declaration
after that function calling
then function call methods and at last
we have recursion
also don't forget to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an
moving on to the first topic that is
what is a function
functions are blocks of code that are
designed to perform a specific task
it basically divides the complex problem
into smaller portions and make the
program easy to understand and reusable
and by reusable it means we can define
the code once and we can use it many
times
we can also pass data into the functions
in the form of parameters
and this is the syntax
first is return type of the function
then we will write function name
then inside the bracket these are the
parameters
now let's discuss why we use functions
functions make the program less
complicated because once function is
defined in the program then it can be
used over and over again
which reduces the complexity of code
and it helps in avoiding the duplicity
of code and it reduces the amount of
code
due to this we can easily debug and
maintain the code
now coming to the types of functions
there are two types of functions in c
plus
that is built in functions and a defined
function
now let's discuss these functions
first is built-in function
these are also known as predefined
functions or library functions
we don't need to define these functions
because these are already present in c
plus plus libraries and the
implementation of these functions are
also available in library file
and to use these functions we don't have
to write them separately we simply call
them
now coming to the user defined functions
c plus plus allows us to define our own
functions
these functions are created by
programmers according to their
requirement
this allows a way to wrap a set of
statements to perform a specific task
and that group of statement is given a
name so that it can be invoked later
from any part of the program
following is the example of user defined
function
here club is a user defined function
with the return type wide and it is
being called from the main function
now
let's learn about function declaration
function declaration basically acts as
an identification for the function
it informs the compiler about the
existence of function
function's name
the number of parameters in the function
and its return type
these things acts as an identifier for a
function
and this is the syntax for a function
declaration
first we will write the return type then
we will write the name of the function
after that inside the bracket we will
write the number of parameters
for example in this chess function
int is the return type
chess is the name of the function
and inside the brackets these are the
number of parameters
although we can write the names of
parameters but names of parameters are
not important in the function
declaration only their type is required
now let's learn about function calling
in order to use a function we'll have to
invoke or call a function
when a program calls a function the
control of the program is transferred to
the called function and when the call
function completes its task then the
control is returned back to the main
program
so the functions are called by writing
the name of function and after that
writing the required parameters inside
the brackets
and this is the syntax
first we will write the function name
and after that we will write the
arguments which you want to pass
for example sum is the function name and
a and b are the arguments so first is
call by value
call by value is a method in which
copies of variables are passed to the
functions and as the copies of variables
or arguments are being passed so that is
why the changes that are done inside the
function does not affect the arguments
and this is the syntax inside int main
we can see that we are calling a
function and passing the values
here val1 and val2 are the actual
parameters
these are those which are passed to the
functions
and inside the brackets of call function
we can see
n1 and n2
these are formal parameters
foreign parameters are those which are
received by the function
so here we can say values of actual
parameters that is val 1 and val2 will
be copied to the formal parameters that
is n1 and n2
now let's have a look at an example
in which we are swapping two numbers
as we can see inside int main we have
assigned 120 to x and 152i
after that we have called a function
named swap it
and inside the brackets we are passing
the values of x and y
and these values are getting received by
called function
and inside that function there is a
logic to swap the code with the help of
temporary variable temp
and these values of x and y are then
displayed inside int main
but its output is same
x is still 120 and y is still 150 there
is no change after swapping it also
so this shows that actual value of the
variable is not getting modified
this shows that changes done to the
parameters inside the function
does not affect the arguments
now let's learn about call by reference
in this method instead of passing the
arguments the address of the argument is
passed to the formal arguments of the
function
and the address is used to access the
actual argument referring to the same
location so any changes that are made
gets reflected to the actual parameter
this is the syntax of call by reference
in which we have assigned 200 to the
variable num and then the address of
this variable is passed to the function
and 20 is assigned to it
now on displaying the output the value
would be 20 and not 200 because the
value is assigned to the memory location
that is why change is getting reflected
now let's have a look at an example of
swap
this is the same example as that of the
call by value but instead of passing the
copies of variable we are passing the
address of the variable
and inside the function values are
getting swapped
with the help of temp variable
and then it is getting displayed in the
main function
in this case we can see in the output
the values of variables are actually
swapped m is now 300 and n is now 250.
now let's do some examples of call by
value and call by reference in our code
editor that is vs code
now we will do an example of call by
value in which we will try to change the
salary with the help of a function
so let's start
first of all let's make a new file
and name it
call one dot cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include
iostream
now we will add namespace standard
now first of all we'll write intmin
and we will declare a variable cell
and assign a value 27 000 let's say
salary
to this cell variable
now we will call a function
let's name that function as
salary
underscore change
and now
inside the brackets we'll write
cell as we know that in call by value
we pass the copies of the variable
so
now we'll display
that variable
we'll write
value
inside main
and now we will write the variable name
cell
and
handle
now
return 0
now let's make
the function salary change
we'll write
void
salary underscore
change
it's void
now here we will write
hint the data type
and the variable
s that is the formal parameter
sal here is the actual parameter and s
is the formal parameter
now
we will assign as a new value
let's say thirty thousand
here we have assigned as thirty thousand
earlier the value of cell was twenty
seven thousand and then we passed the
copy of the variable cell
to the function shall we change and
there we assign 30 000 to it
so let's print over here
value
inside
function
[Music]
cell
and l
here we have to write s
because the variable name is
s okay now let's try to run this
here we can see
value inside function is 30 000
and value inside main is 27 000.
here we can see the value of the
variable that is passed gets changed but
the original value inside the main
function doesn't changes
so we can say changes are not reflected
to the original value which happens in
call by value method
so now let's do one example of call by
reference
let's make a new file
call to dot cpp
let's include the header files
hash include
iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now we'll start with int main
here we will declare a variable cell
and assign 27000 to it
as we have done previously
now we will call a function named
increment
and inside the bracket we will pass
the address of cell
as we know that in case of call by
reference we pass the address
so after that we'll just
write the
message saying
salary
inside
main
and
we'll write
the variable cell
then end l
after that we'll write return 0
now our job is to write the
function
we'll write void
increment
and here
will write ampersand sign
s
because here we are passing the address
not any copy of the value or the
variable here we are passing
the address of the variable
so that is why we have used ampersand
sign
now
we will simply write the logic to
increment
so we'll write s equals s plus
5000 let's say we want the sally to
increment by 5000
then
we will display
the variable s
so first of all we'll write the message
salary
inside
function
the name of the variable after that and
l
now let's try to end this
here we can see
that the salary inside the function is
32 000 and salary outside
the function that is inside the main
function is 32 000 as well
here we can see that the changes are
reflected to the original values as well
in the main function and we know that in
case of call by reference any change
inside the function is reflected outside
the function because we are passing the
address of the variable
so this is our output 32 000 and 32 000
so these were some basic examples of
call by value and call by reference
now here we will do a program in which
we have to do the sum of two integers
with the help of function
so let's first of all
make a new file
function dot cpp
okay so let's start first of all we'll
declare the header files
that is hash included stream
now the name space standard
now we will write int main
now inside end main we will declare a
variable named s
here we have declared this variable
because we want to store the sum of
those two integers in this variable
so
[Music]
we'll call the function let's say let's
name the function as sum
and let's
assume the variables to be 5 and
5.
here sum is the name of the function and
5 comma 5 are the arguments
now we'll make the function sum
here end
is the return type
sum is the name
and
end a
comma and b
are the parameters
so in this function we'll write the code
to do the sum of these two integers and
for that we have to store the sum in a
variable
for that we will now declare a variable
c
now we will write
c equals
a plus b
here we are storing the sum of a plus b
into the variable c
now as we know that the return type
isn't so we have to return the variable
instead of printing it
will write
return
c
now in the main function
we'll print that variable
we will print the variable s
because after the function completes its
task of addition the output will come
back to the calling function which is
getting stored in the variable s
so we'll write
the result is
now we will write the variable s
let's see
hope it runs
the result is ten
five plus five on addition will get ten
let's write 3
and again
try to run this
the result is 8
5 plus 3 equals to 8 so this is the
right answer
now we will do another example
of c plus function
in which we have to find the larger
number or greater number among two
elements
so let's do that
let's create a new file
function1.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include iostream
now using name space standard
now first of all we'll write the intent
now the variable n1
now we will declare another variable n2
these are the two variables among which
we have to find the greater number
so
we'll display a message saying that
enter
the first number
now we will take the input
and one
now we'll do the same for the other one
we'll write
enter the second number
we'll input the second number
now
we have to make a call to the function
named let's say
maxi
and we will pass these arguments
n1
n2
now let's make this function maxi
the return type is void
maxi
is the name
we'll write the variables n1
and 2.
now we'll write the if condition because
we have to find the greater number among
both these elements so we'll write the
if condition
if
n1 is greater than n2
then it must print the n1
will also display a message saying that
the larger number is
n1
if n1 is greater than n2 then we'll
display the n1
and
if n2 is greater
then we'll display the n2
we'll write the variable n2
so let's see if that runs or not
i think we have to write the first
number here we can see enter the first
number
enter the first number
so
we'll write let's say
56
and the second number would be
78
the larger number is 78
so
among both the numbers as we know that
70s is greater than 56 so this is how we
can show it with the help of functions
so these were some basic examples of c
plus first functions in today's session
we will learn about c plus plus
recursion
now let's have a look at what we'll be
covering today
first of all we'll discuss what is
recursion then we'll understand the
working of recursion that is how it
actually works after that we will learn
about types of recursion and at last we
will go through the advantages and
disadvantages of recursion so what is
recursion
recursion can be defined as a process in
which a function calls itself again and
again until a certain condition is met
recursion basically brings about several
number of iterative calls to the same
function
however it is important to have a base
case to end the recursion
for example imagine you are calling your
friend again and again for an urgent
piece of work until he picks up the call
now here calling your friend again and
again or one after the other is a
recursive function and when he picks up
a call is the termination condition and
this is the basic syntax where the
function name is recursion and it is
being called from the main function and
inside the recursion function it is
calling itself
now let's understand it's working
in a recursive function there are two
parts that is the recursive case and the
base case in the recursive case the
function is being called by itself again
and again and the base case is when the
function finally stop calling itself
so when the recursive function is called
from the main function then the call
function will execute and it keeps on
repeating as it is being called by
itself from within the function again
and again until it meets the base case
that will terminate its calling
for example factorial of five in this
problem we can see a pattern
n into factorial of n minus one
to be clear n is five
so n minus one is four
and it is going on till n becomes zero
here factorial is the recursive function
and n minus 1 is the argument that is
getting passed for every n into the
recursive function
in this case if n becomes 0 or 1
it is the base case and n
into factorial n minus 1 is the
recursive condition
now
let's understand the types of recursion
first is direct recursion as the name
suggests in this type of recursion
function calls itself directly for
example void recursion here recursion is
the name of the function and is being
called by itself from within the
function directly
although there is no base case in this
example but it shows the idea of direct
recursion
now coming to indirect recursion
when a function calls itself indirectly
that is if a function calls some other
function to make a recursive call then
it is known as indirect function
for example here recursion function is
calling some other function sub
and sub function is calling the
recursion function
here both the functions are calling
other functions to make a recursive call
this is called indirect recursion
now coming to advantages and
disadvantages of recursion the
advantages are in recursion we only need
to define the base case in the recursive
case
so therefore it provides a simple and
clean way to write a code
second is recursion is more preferred in
problems like tree traversals tower of
noise graphs because these are
inherently recursive problems
now
disadvantages disadvantages are the
recursive program generally acquires
more space than the iterative program
this is because after every call to the
function each function call will keep on
adding to the stack until the base case
is reached
second is it requires more amount of
time because of function calls
now let's do some examples of recursion
on our code editor that is vs code
now here we will do a program in which
we will find the sum of natural number
up to a number which we will enter and
we will do this example using recursion
so let's start
first of all we'll name this
recursion dot cpp
okay now we will start with writing
header file that is hash include
iostream
now
we'll add namespace standard
using namespace
std
now first of all we'll write int main
now we will declare a variable let's say
num
so basically we want to enter a number
so for that first of all we'll display a
message saying that enter a number
now we'll take the input
input as num
so now here we will make a call to the
function and in that function we will
pass the variable num which we have
taken the input off and we will print
this with a message
so let's say
we'll print it like c out
and the message would be
sum is
and this is the function name sum
and this is the variable which we are
passing
after that
let's write return zero
now let's make this function sum
we'll write
int
the return type
sum the name of the function
and
the variable number
now first of all we have to make a base
case
so we will write the base case as
we'll make if
num
is not equal to 0
then
here we will write the recursive case
return
num
plus
sum
num minus 1
so here we are adding the numbers with
its previous number and because of
recursive condition it will keep on
calling the same function sum function
again and again till the base case that
is num becomes equal to 0 is achieved
and once it is achieved the calling
would be stopped
num not equal to 0 here means that if
num is not equal to 0 then only this
statement num plus sum num minus 1
will execute
okay so
now
after this
we'll
try to run this
enter the number let's say
five
sum is 15 here we can see
sum is 15
okay let's recheck
5 plus 4 equals to 9 9 plus 3 equals to
12 12 plus 2 equals 2 14 14 plus 1
equals to 15 so our answer is correct
so this is how we can find the sum up to
any numbers which you want to find the
sum of
and
now let's do another example
so let's name this as
recursion
2 dot cbp
now here we will do a program of
factorial we will enter a number and we
have to find the factorial of that
number
so let's start
first of all we'll write hash include
iostream
that is the header file
now
using namespace standard
now we'll write int main
okay now we will declare a variable
number
and we want to take the input from the
user so we'll
display a message saying
enter the number
now we will take the input
we'll write number
now we will call a function
and we will send the pass the argument
number as we have done in the previous
question
so let's do it
first of all we'll display that
saying
the factorial
of the number
you have entered
is now we will make a call to the
function let's say the name of the
function is fact
and
will pass the argument number
as we have done previously
now we'll write
return
zero
now let's make this function
we'll write the end return type
int
now fact
after that now we will write the
argument
and number
now we will write if condition
and we'll write
number
less than
one
and we will return
1.
so here we have wrote this condition
because
as we know that the factorial of 0 is 1
and
if a number is less than 1 that it means
it is 0
and if it is 0 then our program should
return 1
and
we will write now else condition
else
if it is not 0 that means
we will write the recursive
condition
that is
number
into fact
number
-1
now this is the condition that is
responsible for finding the factorial of
a number
for example if we input 5 then here we
can see the condition would become 5
into fact
5 minus 1
that is 4
and this 4 will be passed as argument to
this fact function
and then the condition would become 4
into fact 4 minus 1 that is 3
and it is also passed to the function
and similarly it will go on until it
becomes less than 1.
now let's try to run this
enter the number
let's say 6
the factorial of number you have entered
is 720 and we know that the factorial of
6 is 720 so this is the right answer
and let me tell you this is this is the
base case and this is the recursive case
in this program
now after that let's do one last example
of recursion
okay so now let's make a new file
and name this file
now first of all we'll add the header
files
i have stream
now name space standard
using name
space
standard
so here we will do the program of
fibonacci series and we know that
fibonacci series is basically each num
in fibonacci series each number is
basically the sum of its two previous
numbers
so let's start
so first of all we'll
make int main
now
we'll declare a variable
num
now we want to take the input from the
user so
first of all we'll display a message
saying that
enter the number
now we will take the input
we'll write
num
now
we will make a for loop and iterate that
loop from i 0 to num
so we'll write for keyword
and
i equal to 0
i
less than
num
i plus plus
now inside the loop we will write c out
to display and we will call fibo
function
and we will pass i as an argument
because we want to print the series
so we will write
c out
fibo
and we'll pass i
as an argument and
just for the space
now i will write return
0
in fibo function we have passed i as an
argument because we want to print the
series
so first 0 will be passed
then 1 will be passed after then 2 will
be passed and so on
so now we will
make the function fibo
hint is the return type fibo is the name
now the argument num
now in this fibo function we will put if
condition
for checking if the num is equal to 0 or
1
if yes we will return the value of num
else we will recursively call fibo using
n minus 1 and n minus 2 because
fibonacci series is basically the sum of
previous two numbers
so first of all we will write
if
num
is less than equal to 1
then
return
num
num
else
return
fibo
num
minus 1
plus
fibo
brackets num minus 2
because we know
fibonacci series is basically the sum of
previous two numbers
now if the
num is 0 or 1
then it will go to the if statement and
if it is greater than 0 and 1
then it will
go to this recursive statement
so for example if n equals to 2 then we
will call recursively 2 minus 1 and 2
minus 2 that is 1 and 0 respectively
since 2 minus 1 will give 1 and 2 minus
2 will give 0 these will be evaluated in
if statement as they are less than equal
to 1 so it will give 0 plus 1 that is
equal to 1.
now let's try to run this code
enter the number
let's say 6
0 1 1 2 3 5 which is the right answer
the fibonacci sequence for 6 is 0 1 1 2
3 5
so this is how we can do fibonacci
series or fibonacci sequence with the
help of recursion
and i suggest you to do some more
examples on recursion to understand it
better
in this session we will learn about
friend functions in c plus so let's go
ahead and have a look at what we'll be
covering today in this session we will
cover topics like why do we need a
friend function what is a friend
function in c plus plus then the
declaration of friend function and after
that we will learn what is a friend
class then we will understand features
of friend function and its advantages
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update so
first is why do we need a friend
function friend functions are used when
we want to access the private or
protected members of the class but
without the help of the objects it helps
us in avoiding the case where the
functions must be a member of both the
classes in order to access them or in
other words a function doesn't have to
be a member of both the classes in order
to access the class data a friend
function is also used to perform
operator overloading like functions
operators can also be overloaded and
because of the friend function it is
possible now let's understand what is a
friend function a friend function is not
a member function of the class and it is
defined outside the class
and we know outside members cannot
access the class data but the friend
function can access those private public
and protected class data because the
friend function is friendly with the
class
now let's move to declaration of friend
function the declaration of friend
function must be done inside the class
the friend function is declared using
the friend keyword then the return type
then the name of the function that is
made a friend of the class its
definition is done outside the class and
we don't use the front keyword while
defining it but while declaring it
inside the class we use the front
keyword now coming to the next topic
that is what is a friend class exactly
like a friend function a class can also
be a friend of another class a friend
class is that class that can access the
data members and member functions of a
class to which it is a friend we need to
pass the objects of the class to a
member function of the friend class if
we want to access those private and
protected members also if the classes
are declared friends then all the member
functions of the class will be a friend
function to the friend class
now let's have a look at the syntax here
we have done the forward declaration of
class table this will allow the access
of the objects of the class table in the
class club inside the class club we have
declared friend class table that means
the class table is a friend of class
club and it can access members of that
class
after that we have defined the class
table without the friend keyword as we
can see
now coming to features of friend
function so here are some features of
friend functions so let's start with the
first one that is a friend function can
be easily invoked just like a normal
function it doesn't require any object
or so to invoke next is the scope of a
friend function is not limited it can be
a member of another class as well third
is a friend function can be declared in
any part that is private protected or
public parts of the class fourth is the
object of the class can be used as an
argument for the function and the last
is a friend function can access the
members by using the object name and dot
operator along with the member's name
now coming to advantages of friend
function the first advantage is with the
help of friend function we are able to
access the known public members of the
class that is the private members the
second advantage is friend function
helps in operator overloading and the
third advantage is because of the friend
function we are able to share the
private information by a known member
function as friend function is not a
member function
last advantage is
fan function allows us to generate more
efficient code so these were some
advantages of friend function so now
let's go ahead and do some examples on
friend functions to understand it in a
better way so let's open our visual
studio code and do some examples so
first of all let's make a new file let's
name it friend one
dot
cpb
all right so now here we'll do a simple
program of friend function so let's
start
with including the header file
include iostream
now we will write using namespace
standard
all right
and
inside the main function
first of all we will create an object of
a class let's say the name of the class
is salary and the name of the object is
s
all right after that we will
simply write return 0
and we will do the rest of this after
creating the class
so we need to first create the class now
we'll write
class
salary which is the name of the class
and inside this class first of all we'll
write private
access modifier and
here we will write
or declare
a variable named cell
after that now we will write or declare
the friend function so we know how to
declare a friend function we'll write
friend keyword
then the return type that is int
and then the name of the
function let's say increment
and then the objects
as we know we have to pass
the name of the class with the object
because we want to access the private
member of the class
so salary s which is the object
and after the class we'll write the
semicolon now we have to create or
define this increment friend function
we'll write
int
increment
here we haven't used the front keyword
because this is the definition
now inside the arguments will pass the
the object
all right
now inside the main function
we will call this friend function
so first of all we will display a
message saying that
increment
is
that the increment in the salary is
and then we will call this
function
and we will pass this object
all right now inside this increment
function which is a friend function we
will use object as
dot operator and then
the name of the variable which is
private
now all we need to do is to
increment this salary variable
we'll write
s dot cell plus
7000
which is the increment and then we will
return s dot cell
all right now as we can see this
increment function which is not a member
function of this class is accessing this
private variable of salary class and is
incrementing 7000 to the salary so now
let's save it first and let's try to run
this
there is some error
let's have a look at that
um all right
yeah there is some spelling mistake
increment
now let's save it
and run it
so as we can see
increment is 7000
so this is the correct output
so this was a simple example of friend
function let's do another example so
here we will do an example of friend
class and we know friend class is a
class that can access the data members
and member functions of a class to which
it is a friend
so let's start first of all we'll
include the header files
hash include iostream
and then the namespace standard
and we forgot to name this file so let's
do it
let's name it friend
two dot cpp all right now let's proceed
into main inside the main function first
of all we will create an object of a
class
let's say the class name is
num2
and its object is obj2 object2 now for
now let's say we'll write only return 0
we'll do this part later onwards now
let's create the class
all right so the class name would be
num2
num1 actually
but we know
in front class we have to do the forward
declaration so we will write
class
num
2
so this is a forward declaration of
class num2
now
inside class num1 first of all we will
declare a variable in private
so let's say the name of the variable is
n1
enters the data type and one is the name
of the variable
now we have to
do the declaration of friend class
so we'll write friend keyword
after that
class
num2
which is the name of the class
all right
after this let's create this
first of all we have to put the
semicolon all right now let's write this
class
num2
so this is our friend class num2 we
haven't used friend keyword over here as
we can see
all right in this class we'll use a
private
access specifier and
we'll create another variable n2
and then we will write the public access
specifier and we will create a
constructor of num2 as this is the
name of the class and this is object we
have created so now we will create the
constructor of this class
num2
and now in this constructor we will
initialize
n2 with 65 or whatsoever number we want
because in the end we have to find the
average of two variables
so this is the second variable n2
and
we have assigned the value 65 so now
let's make the function of average
because we want to find the average of
both the numbers
so enters the data type
avg is the name of the function let's
say and inside this function
we will
make an object of num1
class
and object name is obj1 now as we have
created the
object
by mistake we have wrote i
obj one so as we have created the object
of num1 class which its constructor
would be invoke which we will
create now but first of all
here we will write return
the average so
we'll write obj1 dot
n1
plus
n2
divided by
2.
so as we know that obj1 is the
object of num1 class so that is why we
have used obj1.operator n1 that is the
name of the variable plus n2 divided by
2
from here we can find the average and
before that we have to create the
constructor of this class
so
now all we need to do is
write public access modifier
now
num1
and inside this num1 we will assign the
value
to n1 variable which is let's say 11
all right so
now in the main function we have to call
this function avj that is the average
function
and
we forgot to put semicolon over here all
right now
we'll
display a message
average is
and now we will call the function
obj
2
dot
avg
which is a function
so here we are calling this function so
let's save this so we have saved this
now let's try to run this one
as you can see the average is 38
so
65 plus 11
6
and 76
divided by 2 which is 38 so this is the
correct output
so this is a fine example of friend
class
as we know class
num2 is a friend of class num1 so it can
access all the members of class num1
in class num2 we have created the
function avg
over here this is the function avg
here we are doing the average of both
the numbers
and as class num2 is a friend of num1 so
we can create objects of num1 in num2
class
and after doing this
this is our output that is average is
38.
so this is an example of friend class
now let's do another example so here we
will do an example of friend function in
which a friend function is a friend to
two classes
and this would be an example in which we
have to do the product of two numbers so
let's start
first of all let's include the header
files as we have done previously
iostream
namespace standard
now let's save it
friend3.cpp and
spelling is wrong
now
let's start with the main function
inside the int main first of all we will
create the object of class a that is a
and class b
object would be small b
and we will use these objects
to call the functions but we will do
that part later onwards first of all
we'll simply write return zero over here
and now we will create the classes
all right so here we will create a class
but before that we have to do the
forward declaration of another class so
this is the forward declaration of class
p and now we can create the class a
and
inside the a class
we will declare the variable x let's say
now
we will use this public scope
and we will create a function within
this class let's say void
assign
now inside this function we will pass
the
variable i because because we have to
assign the value of this variable i
to the variable x
so
we will assign the value of i to x
like this and before that we have to do
the calling from the main function
so we will do that later first of all we
will create the friend function and here
we are declaring this friend function
void is the return type product let's
say is the name of this friend function
and a
comma b
are the
arguments now
let's call this
assign function
first of all so all we need to do is
we will make a call from this main
function
a dot assign
which is the name of the function and
let's say we have
passed the value
45 now here
we will create the class b
inside the b class we'll similarly
create another variable y
and now
inside the public scope we will create
function
of the same name that is assign now in
this assign function we will pass
i as the argument as we have done in
class a similarly we will do it over
here we will assign the value of i to
this variable y
once we have done this
then
we will declare friend function as we
know that the front function is friend
of both of these classes so we have to
do it inside both of these classes we
have to declare the friend function and
now
we will declare the friend function in
this class as well
product all right after the class we
will use the semicolon
now
we will create the friend function
so here we are defining the friend
function we use void product which is
the name of the function
um data type object name
all right now all we need to do is
we'll do the sum a dot x into
b
dot
y
and now we'll use semicolon so here a
dot x will hold the value which have
been assigned that is 45 and now
b dot x
b dot y will
hold the value which we will call from
here
v dot
assign
here we are calling
and we are assigning the value let's say
20 we are passing the value 20 and this
20 value
will be assigned to this y and 45 into
20
would be the product
so everything is done now all we need to
do is to call the
product function and as we know that the
product function that is the friend
function is the friend of both of the
classes so it can access the private
variables so we'll do that
product
a
comma b here we are calling this
now let's save this one and let's try to
run this
there are some errors
let's check them
class a all right
so we forgot to make some space over
here now let's save it again
and let's try to run this
as we can see
the output is
900 so 45 into 20 is equal to 900 which
is the correct answer
and
it means the program is working fine so
this is a fine example in which a
function that is this product function
is a friend of both the classes that is
class b and this class a here we have
done the forward declaration and we have
made the friend of class a and here we
have declared the
friend function in class b
and as we can see that this product
function can use or access the private
variables of both the classes and so
this is by using the private variables
we we have done the product of both of
these numbers and its answer is 900 so
these were some few examples of friend
functions you can try some more examples
on it it will enhance your knowledge in
z plus plus as it is an interesting
topic welcome to this video on c plus
plus header files and in today's session
we will learn about why we need header
files then what is c plus plus header
file after that we will learn about
types of header files and how can we
create our own header file and at last
we will have a look at some examples of
header files
header files allows us to assemble all
the predefined functions in one place
and it is helpful because it is easier
to gather the declarations in one place
and then use them whenever we need them
and as all the declarations are gathered
in one place so it automatically reduces
the complexity and it also decreases the
number of lines of code there are many
functionalities of header files one of
them is it helps in taking the input
from the user and also helps in
displaying the output in a program
now let's learn what actually a c plus
header file is
header files are the set of libraries
that contains predefined functions at a
common place so it basically stores the
declarations at one common place and
they are being used while writing a
program
these header files usually have a dot h
extension and we use hash include before
writing the header file to inform the
preprocessor that we are including this
header file now let's discuss types of
header files
there are two types of files in c plus
plus first is predefined header file
these files are already present in c
plus plus compiler we simply need to
import these header files using hash
include which will inform the compiler
about the header file and then we can
write the name of the header file
between the angle brackets
next is user defined header file these
header files are defined or created by
users in c plus user can create their
own header file and include it in the c
plus library and it can be used whenever
it is required
now let's learn how to create this
header file in order to create your own
header file first of all we will write
the c plus code which we want to use
whenever we want
after that we will save the file with
dot h extension
as we can see in step 1 we have written
the code of two integers that are
getting multiplied
and now we will include this in the
program
to include this in the program we will
use hash include and after that we will
write the name of the header file inside
the angle brackets with the dot
extension
here hash include will inform the
compiler that a header file is added
and now as we can see in step 2
after the declaration of two integers we
are calling the function product and
passing the arguments x and y
after running this program
we will get the output as 45
because 9 into 5 equals 45 and we don't
need to worry about writing the logic of
it because we have already included this
header file now let's have a look at
some examples of header files
hash include iostream
iostream is the header file that is used
to read and write the standard input
output streams
because of this header file we can take
the input and display the output and in
case of iostream dot h is not used
because after standardization of c plus
iostream became standard header whose
function is now in std namespace
unlike earlier when functions were
defined in i o stream before
standardization
next is f stream
f stream are associated with files
it is basically used to read the
information from files and write the
information in it
and next is io manip
io manip is a library that is used in
the manipulation of input and output
statements
so these were some examples of header
files today we'll be discussing about c
plus array so without further ado let's
get started
so what's in it for you
we will start by understanding why do we
need arrays then what is an array
after that types of array like one
dimension array two dimensional array
multi-dimension array and then memory
representation and lastly we'll go
through array initialization
so first is need of arrays
we use arrays because it allows us to
store similar type of data within
contagious block of memory
and it allows us to iterate through
those variables conveniently using
indexing
usually an array is used to store
similar kind of data like marks code by
all the students of our class and record
of attendance of all the employees in an
organization
now moving to what is an array
an array can be defined as a collection
of similar kind of elements
these are always stored in contiguous
memory locations that is one after the
other the total number of elements in an
array is called the length of the array
now this is the way you can visualize
the n array
here each block is capable of storing
data values of some type in sequential
manner and each element can uniquely
identify by its index in the array
and this is the syntax of array
int is the data type
array is the array name and 5 is the
size of array
now there are few types of variant c
plus
plus
those are
one dimensional array two dimensional
array and multi-dimensional array so
let's first of all discuss one d array
this is the simplest form of an array in
this array data items are arranged
linearly in one dimension having single
index value to represent data elements
now this is the syntax of 1d array type
is the data type then there is array
name and after that size of array and
this is example of one dimensional array
now coming to its memory representation
here we can see 2 7 4 8 1 6 are the
elements inside the memory blocks and 0
1 2 3 4 5 are the indexes
so by using index we can easily access
the elements and once the array elements
are accessed a number of operations can
be performed
here error of 0 means 2 and array 1
means 7 and so on
as each element is of type int
that is 2 byte
that means the array occupies 12
contiguous bytes because each block
contain two byte and there are total six
blocks
now coming to the two dimensional array
in this array each element is referred
by two indexes that is rows and columns
and they are stored in the form of
matrices
the first index shows a row of the
matrix and the second index shows the
column of the matrix
now moving to its memory representation
as you can see this is a 2d array with 3
rows and 3 columns
and we can also say that these are
basically 3 1d array containing 3 blocks
each
combined to form a 2d array in the form
of a matrix with size of 3 cross 3.
the horizontal lines step its rows and
the vertical lines tap its columns
and we know that index starts from zero
so first elements get stored at array
zero zero that is zeroth row and zero
column
then second element is stored at array
zero one that is zeroth row and column
one and likewise all the elements are
stored in the array
now coming to the multi-dimensional
array
[Music]
these are defined as area of arrays that
means each element of multi-dimension
array is an array itself
they can have any number of dimensions
and it stores the data in tabular form
a two-dimensional array is also a
multi-dimensional array
and this is the syntax for a
multi-dimensional array
here type is the data type of array then
array name is the name of the array and
size 1 size 2 up to so on size n are the
dimension of sizes
after that this is the basic example of
a multi-dimensional array
now coming to the next topic that is air
initialization
so there are two ways to initialize an
array in c plus first is you can
initialize an array when you declare it
by including the initial values in
braces after the declaration
while declaring we could use curly
braces to set the values inside it
for example in this array of size 6 the
element 2 is at 0 index
5 is at 1 index 1 is at 2 index and so
on
if we don't mention the size of array
then the array will only be large enough
to hold the elements added within the
curly braces
other than this we can set the value
after the declaration by assigning the
element to the array using its index
like array of 0 equal to 5 here we are
assigning 5 to index 0 and arrow 1 equal
to 7 here we are assigning 7 to index 1
and same goes for the array of 2. now
let's do some examples on array to
understand them better we'll do these
examples on our code editor that is vs
code
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now we'll make a new file
and let's name that file as
array.cpp
array1 dot cpp
now we'll do a basic example in which we
have to print
the elements of array
so let's start first of all we'll write
the header file
[Music]
dash include iostream
now using namespace standard
[Music]
will write into main
now we'll start by writing the data type
int
now we'll write the array name that is
let's say coupon
and
now the size of array
let's say six
now
curly braces
now inside these curly braces we'll
write those elements
let's say 5
so these are those elements and this is
a
array declaration
now
here tint means the data type coupon is
the array name 6 is the size of array
and 5 8 7 3 9 1 are the elements of
array
now after that
we'll write the for loop with 4 keyword
now we'll initialize i
with 0
i less than 6 because it is the size of
array
now we'll increment i
now in this loop all we have to do is to
print this array
so how do we do that so let's do
c out
and inside the bracket we'll write i
so here we have printed the array inside
the loop and we have put i inside the
array bracket
now the loop will run from i 0 to 6 and
likewise all the elements from 5 to 1
will get printed so let's see
let's fly to learn this code
so this is our output
587391
so this is how we can print the elements
of an array
and if we want to print a particular
element from the array all we have to do
is to write the index number of that
element inside the bracket
let's say if we want to print 7
[Music]
all we have to do is to print its index
number that is 2.
now let's run this
see
777 it is because of the loop that from
i 0 to i 6 that is why it is getting
printed six times
now if we remove the loop and try to
print it then it will get print only one
time
let's see
here seven and this is what we want to
print
now let's do another example
let's name this file
array2.cbp
now in this example all we have to do is
to do the sum of all the elements of the
error
so let's start by writing our header
file
hash include ios3
[Music]
now using namespace std
now we'll write into main
now here first of all we'll declare a
variable sum and initialize it with zero
[Music]
now we'll declare another variable n
and n will depict the size of the array
so first of all in order to scan array
first of all we have to scan the size of
it
so we'll scan n
[Music]
now we'll declare the array
[Music]
and inside the bracket we will mention n
because it is the size
[Music]
now we'll write for loop
and we will initialize with i equals 0
i less than
n which is the size of array and we'll
increment i plus plus
we are writing for loop here because we
want to scan the array and as in this
array there are more than one element so
that is why we need
for loops
so now we will scan the error
we'll write c in
the name of array
and inside the bracket we'll write i
now here we have written i inside the
brackets because we want to take input
of elements from i equal to 0 to n which
is the size of array
now
we'll take another for loop
now here we will write another for loop
in which we are initializing i from 0 to
n
and inside that for loop we will do the
sum of the array
so we'll write
equals to 0
[Music]
i less than n which is the size
now we will implement i plus plus
now inside this for loop
we'll do the code we'll do the logic of
adding the elements of the array
we'll write sum
as we know that we have already
initialized sum with zero will write sum
equals to sum
plus
array of 5
now for this statement sum equals to sum
plus area of i
we are adding each value in the array
one by one into the sum which is
initially zero
when i equals to zero then the sum will
be equal to zero plus array of zero
and this sum will keep on getting stored
inside the variable sum
as our i increments our sum keeps on
storing the addition value
now
we'll print this sum
outside the loop
we'll write c
out and we'll write sum is
[Music]
now we'll write the sum variable
return
0.
let me tell you return 0 is optional in
c plus
basically return value is exit status of
the program and 0 is considered as ok
in c plus compiler includes it
automatically but it's a good practice
here we forget to write the data
type now we'll try to run it
[Music]
so first of all we'll write the size
like
let's say six
now the elements of the array
let's say one
two
three
four
five
and six
now we want to find the sum of these
elements
sum is 21 let's recheck
1 plus 2 equals to 3 3 plus 3 equals 6
6 plus 4 10
10 plus 5 15 15 and 6 is 21 so this is
our right answer
so this is another basic example of
array
so after this we'll do one example of
two dimensional array also so let's make
a new file
and we'll write the header file
let's name this file as
array3.cpp
now name space standard
now we'll write into main
now we will declare a 2d array of 3 rows
and 3 columns with elements inside it
three rows
and second bracket will write three
columns
now we'll write the curly braces
and
another curly braces
this is the way to declare
a 2d array
now 2
7
nine let's say
now again curly braces
one
three
eight because we are creating a
matrix of three cross three that is why
there are total 9 elements inside the
array
so now we will create a nested for loop
where the outer loop i which is for the
rows of matrix is initialized from 0 to
2.
we'll write
and i equal to zero
now i less than
three
i
plus plus increment
now we will write inner for loop j which
is for the column and we will initialize
it from 0 to 2 as well
we'll write 4
and j 0
j less than 3
j plus plus
now we will print the array
in the first bracket we will mention i
that is the number of rows and in the
second bracket we will mention j that is
number of columns
and in order to add space
we will add
space in the output
now
outside the bracket we will mention and
shift the elements to the next line
after that we'll write it in zero
so this is our output 541279138
in the matrix form that is why i have
used this space
to make the output look good and this
end l
so this is our output five four one two
seven nine one three eight
so this is how we can print the elements
of a multi-dimensional array or two
dimensional array
these were some basic examples of array
and in order to understand these
programs you must practice more examples
on it in this session we will learn
about sorting in c plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
we will learn what is sorting in c plus
then the categories of sorting which are
internal and external sorting
after that we will understand types of
sorting in c plus
that are bubble sort selection sort
insertion sort and quick sort
and at last we will understand sorting
using c
library
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and press the
bell icon to never miss an update
so first is
what is sorting in c
sorting in c plus is a concept in which
the elements of array are rearranged in
a logical order
now this order can be from the lowest to
the highest or highest to the lowest
rearranging them in a sorted order helps
in dealing with many problems like
searching the maximum element or the
minimum element from an array of
elements
in c plus sorting is categorized into
two types
that is internal sorting and external
sorting
so let's understand these
in internal sorting the data to be
sorted is present in the main memory
and the process of sorting will also
take place in the main memory itself
while in case of external sorting the
data is not always present in the main
memory because the data is large
so data is filled in the main memory in
small portions
so this is the difference between
internal sorting and external sorting
now coming to types of sorting in c plus
there are various types of sorting in c
plus that are bubble sort selection sort
insertion sort and quick sort
so let's start with bubble sort
bubble sort is one of the easiest
sorting techniques in c plus
in this technique the comparisons are
done starting from the first two
elements
the adjacent elements are compared if
the element on the left is greater than
the element in the right then the
swapping is done
and it will proceed till the end of the
array
so first the comparison will start from
the first two elements that are 22 and
13
and as we know that 22 on the left is
greater than 13.
so we will swap these elements and make
them 13 on the left and 22 on the right
now it became 13 22 5 7 11.
so now we will compare 22 which is at
index 1 with 5 that is at index 2
and as 22 is greater than 5 we will swap
these elements as well
then again we will compare it with the
next element
and if 22 is greater than that element
as well then we will swap them as well
so in this way round one of comparison
is complete as one of the element
reached its actual position
two more rounds of the comparisons will
occur till the array becomes sorted
it is because for n elements the number
of comparison are
n minus one
so number of comparisons here would be 3
as the elements are 4 in numbers
now
coming to selection sort
in this selection sort technique
the smallest element is fetched by
comparing itself with the rest of the
elements
and is sorted at the first position of
the array
once the first element is sorted
the search for second minimum element
begins from the rest of the array
and is positioned at the second place
similarly one by one all the elements
are positioned like this
so this is selection sort
now
moving to insertion sort technique
in this sorting technique the elements
are sorted by comparing the second
element with the first element
if the second element is smaller than
the first
then we will swap it
after that we will compare the third
element with all the elements that are
before it
similarly it goes for the fourth element
and so on once all the comparisons are
done the elements becomes sorted
as you can see in the figure
so this was insertion sort technique
next is quick sort technique or quick
sort algorithm
quick sort algorithm is one of the most
widely used algorithm and the most
efficient sorting algorithm
the quick sort algorithm follows a
divide and conquer approach
in this approach a paper element is
selected and the array is partitioned
into two halves on the basis of this
pivot element
the elements that are smaller than the
pivot element are shifted to the left
side of it
and elements greater than the pivot
element are shifted to the right side of
it
after this
both the left and the right sub arrays
are sorted and combined
for
example let's suppose we have 6 elements
5 15 1 8 22 and 6
and we want to sort them using quick
sort so first of all we will select any
pivot element let's say 6
now we will divide the array to two sub
arrays based on the pivot element
in such a way that the elements smaller
than the pivot element are on the left
and the elements greater than the pivot
element are on the right as you can see
in the figure elements smaller than 6
are on the left and elements
greater than 6 are on the right
now we will sort both of these sub
arrays separately
we will select a pivot element from each
of the sub-array
like we can see
from the first sub-array we have
selected 5 and the second sub-array we
have selected 15.
similarly if the element is less than
the pivot element then adjust it on the
left otherwise on the right
by doing this both the sub-arrays will
become sorted and now we can combine
them to become a complete sorted array
so this is how quick sort algorithm
works
so as we have understood about the
sorting technique
now let's understand how to sort using c
plus library
we can sort using the c
library as well
to use that library function we must
include the hash include algorithm
header file
this function compares each and every
element within the range
the syntax of function is sort
then
within the brackets there will be the
starting iterator and the ending
iterator
and we must include this algorithm
header file with hash include which is a
preprocessor
so as we have understood about these
sorting algorithms
so let's move to our code editor that is
vs code to do some examples on this
sorting algorithms
all right so this is our code editor and
here we will do some examples of sorting
techniques
so let's first of all create a new file
and let's name it
sort
1 dot cpp
so let's add first of all
the header file hash include iostream
then the namespace standard
so first of all we will do an example of
bubble sort algorithm
and
now we will create
the main function
inside the main function we will create
some variables
let's say
i int j
and a temporary variable
temp
after that we will declare an array arr
and let's say the size of the array is 8
and the elements of array are
12
let's say 3
and 35
so these are the elements of the array
now we will
display these elements
so we'll
display a message unsorted array as we
know that these area elements are
unsorted so
we will print the message unsorted
with
slashing all right
now
we will
write the for loop in i equal 0 that
runs from i 0 to i 8
because you want to print the array
i less than equal to 8 i less than 8
i plus plus
now here we will print the array
arr
i
so one by one all the elements will get
printed
and will add the
slash t
to add the horizontal space between each
element
all right
now
for space we will
write we can write n l
now we will write the logic for bubble
sort as we know in bubble sort the
swapping is done starting from the first
two elements and if the element on the
left is greater than the element on the
right then the swapping is done
so we will do that
we will write a for loop
which runs from i 0 to 8
and i equal 0
i
less than
8
i plus plus
and
the second for loop would be
in
j equals
i plus 1
j less than 8
j plus plus
now i'll explain both of these loops
but before that let us just write the if
condition for swapping
if
a r r
i
is less than
a r r
j
oh
i write the opposite of that which i
have to write
let's make it i
yeah if a r of j is less than a r of i
then we'll do the swap so now i'll
explain this part
here when i is at
0
then j is at 0 plus 1 that is at index
1.
so now comparison will take place
between element and index 1 and element
at index 0.
if the right element that is index 1
element is smaller than the left element
that is index 0 element then swapping
will take place and similarly one by one
each element is compared with the next
element and it will proceed till the end
of the array
so now here we will write the
swapping logic
we will store the first variable into
the temporary variable
and then we will store the second
variable into array of i
then we'll again store
into area of j
the value holded by the temporary
variable all right so this is how
swapping is done
now all we need to do is to just print
the array elements because it
because we have to show the sorted
elements of the array so we'll first
display a message
sorted
elements
all right
and then we'll use slash n as well
now here again we will use the for loop
and
which runs from i 0 to i 8
e less than 8
i plus plus
and now we will print the elements of
the array of sorted array
just to add the horizontal space we can
write slash d
and now
after that
return 0
let's save it and let's hope it will
work
so as you can see this is the unsorted
array 12 3 1 5 18 10 7 35 and this is
our sorted elements of the array 1 3 5 7
10 12 18 35 so as you can see these
elements are sorted
and using the slash t we have added the
space between each of these elements
all right now let's do another example
so now let's do an example of insertion
sort first of all let's save it
and let's name it as
sort
2
dot cpp
now let's add the header files
hash include iostream
then
write the namespace standard
then we'll start with the main function
in main
now we'll
write the variables like
and i int j and
num variable
then the temp variable temporary
variable
and we'll also initialize the array
let's
make it 30 size
now we'll take the input from the user
so
right enter the elements
enter the number of elements first of
all
all right
we'll take the input
as num
and then
we'll ask the user
to enter the
elements
all right
now
using for loop
sorry
using for loop
i
equals to 0
till i less than
num
i plus plus
we will take the input
of the elements of the array one by one
so
num is the size of the array so one by
one all the elements
will the user will enter all the
elements
all right after that
all right now we'll write the code for
insertion sort
please keep in mind in insertion sort
we start by comparing the second element
with the first element if the second
element is smaller than the first
element then we will swap it
after that we will compare the third
element with all the elements that are
before it similarly it goes for the
fourth element and so on
we can see this figure for reference and
now we'll start doing the code
we'll start by writing
the for loop which
starts from zero
till num minus one
less than m i plus plus all right after
that
we will store the array in the temporary
variable
once it's done
then we'll write j i minus 1
first of all we have copied the elements
of array to the time variable then we
have set j equals to i minus 1 because
we have to compare it with the previous
element
and
all right
now we'll write the while loop
okay so
temp
is less than a r r of
j plus 1
now
only j
and for termination j must be greater
than 0
all right let's
make them inside the brackets
all right now
first of all let's write the code then
i'll explain the part i have j plus 1
array of j
we will move this element forward
and
then we'll write
j minus 1 will decrement it
then
you have to insert the element in this
place
all right
i'll explain this part
in this part we have copied the elements
of array to the temp variable first of
all and then we have set j equals to i
minus 1 because we have to compare it
with one previous element
and
while in while loop we are checking if
the value of element prior to array of j
is more or less
if it is less than removes the element
in order to set it to the right position
using area of j plus 1 equals to temp we
are actually inserting the element in a
proper place
or the right position
we are validating that j remains greater
than equal to 0
so
this is how it's done and now we have to
print the elements
so now we have to print the sorted
element so we will
write the message will display the
message
sorted
elements
and then using the for loop
we will display all the elements one by
one
i plus plus
arr
inside it will write i
and
we'll add some space
once it's done then
all is left is to write return zero
return 0
now let's save it
once it is saved then now let's check
if it is running fine or not
as we can see enter the number of
elements in the array let's say there
are five elements
right
eight
one
four
nine
two
all right eight one four nine two so
our output is wrong let's check
i
where it is
i less than equal to
this is the problem
let's save it
and let's check it once more
five
now
eight
five
seven
two
six
eight two five six seven
all right now i get it actually we are
checking from the first element so
we have to start with the first index
now let's save it
and try one more time
five
nine
five
eight
two
and let's say twelve
2 5 8 9 12. so finally our output is
correct
because of some logical mistakes our
output was getting wrong but now we
finally can see that 2 5 8 9 12 the
elements of the area are finally sorted
and
this is how you can do insertion sort
now after this we'll do another example
all right now let's do an example of
selection sort
let's name it as sort 3
dot cbb
so let's understand the selection
sorting technique one more time in this
technique the smallest element is
fetched by comparing itself with the
rest of the element and is sorted at the
first position of the array
after the first element is positioned
the search for the second element begins
from the rest of the array and is
positioned and the second place
similarly all other elements are
positioned like this
as we can see in the figure
now let's do its practical
implementation
so let's start by adding the header
files
hash include iostream
then write the using namespace standard
now we'll start with the main function
all right so first of all we'll declare
some variables like in i and j
and
num variable
then
a variable p
and a temporary variable temp
and we also need a minimum variable
we'll name it main
and now we will declare the array
let's make it of size 10 and yeah
now
we will display a message saying that
enter the number of elements
all right enter
the number of
elements
all right
now we will take the input
see in num
now
we'll ask them to enter the elements
so we'll write slash n
enter the
elements
all right now again we will use slash n
once it's done now we can take the input
of the array
so we'll start with int i equal 0
i less than num
i plus plus
and now c in
array arr
index i
so
yeah
now we can take the input from the user
and now we have to do the actual part
that is the selection sort we have to
sort the array
using the selection sort technique
so let's start
we'll write a for loop and i equals 0
i less than num minus 1.
i plus plus
inside this loop we will store the value
of the first element of the array
min equals a r r of i we are storing the
first
element of array into this min variable
so here we are storing the value now we
have to store the index
so
the p variable which we have declared
and we are storing the
index i to this p variable
all right after that we have to use
another for loop
where the actual comparisons
begins
now we will write
j
equals to i plus 1
and
j less than num
j plus plus
now i'll explain you this for loop
in this for loop we are doing i plus 1
because here the comparison will take
place and the comparison will occur with
the preceding elements
so we have to do j equals to i plus 1
now we have to do inside this for loop
we will use a if condition
so we'll write
if
minimum is greater than array of
j
that if
that is
if any element is smaller than the
minimum element then that particular
element will be set as minimum element
so we'll do that we'll write
min
equals array of i arrived j sorry
and we also
have to change the index so we'll assign
the index of j to the p earlier we have
assigned the index i to p
but if that particular element is
smaller than the minimum element then we
also have to assign the index to p
now all we need to do is to swap
so now let's do the swapping part as
well
all right
so first of all the temporary variable
temp we will assign arr of i
we have to swap error of i and arr of b
because the index j is assigned to p
and we all know how to do the
swapping
i
now we will
put the value of error of p into error
phi
now the value at
temp
goes to error of p so the swiping is
done here
and now we have to just print the sorted
array
so now let's first of all display a
message
saying that the sorted elements are
right slash n
sorted
elements
are
slash and again
now using for loop we will print all
those elements
equal 0
i less than
n
num sorry i plus plus
all right now we will
just print the array
and now in order to give some space
we'll
use the double quotes
now it's done
now return 0 will write
now everything is done now let's check
if it is working or not
it's done by our end so let's save it
and
let's try to run
enter the number of elements
okay so
let's add five
now five elements are
eight
one
five
sorry one
five
three
seven
one three
five seven eight as you can see
these are the sorted elements and this
is correct
so this is how we can do the selection
sort
this is our logic behind the selection
sort
you can try this example as well
all right now we'll do an example of
quick sort
so first of all
let's create a new file
and
name it as
sort four dot cpp
now as we know in quick sort follows the
divide and conquer algorithm so let's
have a look at it
as we know in quick sort a pivot element
is selected like
here we have selected 6 as a pivot
element and then the elements which are
smaller than 6 are put on the left side
and elements which are greater than 6
are shifted to the right side and
similarly
same thing is done with the
partitions or the sub arrays
and in the end when we combine we get a
sorted array so now
practical implementation so first of all
we'll start by creating a main function
and before that
we'll add the header files hash include
iostream
and the namespace standard
all right now we'll start with the main
function
inside the main function we will declare
a variable num and another variable i
and
declare an array arr size let's say 10
now we'll display a message
saying that enter the number of elements
enter the number of elements
all right now
here it is
now we will take the input
from the user
number now we'll display another message
saying that enter the elements
and now we'll use for loop
to take the input from the user
i equals 0 i less than
num
i plus plus
so inside the slope c in an arri will
take the input from the user
user enters all the digits or the
elements
now we will call a function quick
and we'll pass the arguments array and
the starting index and the ending index
the starting index would be 0
and ending index would be num minus 1
that is size minus 1
so this is where we are calling the
quick function
and after that we can
display a message saying that
after sorting
the elements are
and now using for loop again
we can display
the sorted array afterwards
add some space
yes
and
we'll write return 0
so our main function is done
now all we need to do is to make the
quick function
all right so let's create this quick
function
quick
and its data type would be void
quite quick and will pass the
the arguments on the parameters are
array and the starting index and the
ending index
start
and end
so these are the parameters and inside
this quick function
we'll write the if condition
that is if start of the index is less
than end that is if the array element is
more than 1
then
here we will find the point of division
d
and then there would be recursive calls
for the divided sub arrays
or the partitions
so now
we will make the division point d
and
now we'll call
the function divide
and we'll pass
the parameters array
and the starting index and the ending
index to this function as well
so here
d is the division point and by calling
this function we will find this division
point
after that we will do the recursive call
for the left sub array and the right sub
array
so let's do that
quick
array
in starting index
and ending index
but here ending index would be as it is
a sub array as it is the left sub array
so the division point is the point of
division
so the ending index for the left sub
array would be d minus one
and similarly now again we'll call for
the right sub-array
here the starting index would be
d
plus one
and the ending index would be
end
let me explain this part again
the first recursive call would be from
start
to d minus one
and the second recursive call from is
from d plus one
to the end
so these are the two sub-arrays this is
the right sub-array and this one is the
left sub-array so d minus 1 is this
element and d plus 1 is this element
all right now we'll make this divide
function
and we have to make this divide function
above the quick function otherwise it
will show an error or
if you don't want to do that then you
can do the forward declaration but i'll
prefer doing this only
so it is the data type divide is the
name
and now
in arr
as we have passed the starting index
and the
sorry the starting index
and the ending index
all right
now inside this divide function first of
all we will
set a pivot
element
so we'll do that arr
we always we usually select the last
element as pivot element or you can
select the first element as well or any
random element
now
we'll create another variable in index
and
we'll assign it start index
now this variable will keep the track of
elements in the array
starting from all first element and all
these elements
so
now
we'll use a for loop
and now we will do the comparison with
the pivot element so inside the for loop
int i equals 0
sorry int i equals start because we'll
start from the first element so i equal
start
i less than
and we will not use
less than equal to we'll use i less than
n because we don't want to include the
pivot element so that is why we will use
i less than end and now i plus plus
all right now inside this for loop we
will create
if condition
now in this condition if the array of i
is less than the pivot element then we
will shift it towards the left then
we'll do the swapping
ar i
is less than
pivot
then
temporary variable temp and we all know
how to do the swapping
so we'll do that
arr i index
please note that index is storing the
start
and pivot is storing the end
so keep in mind that now
arr
index
this temporary variable
now we will increment this index plus
plus
because this index plus plus will do the
further comparison with pivot
element
so
if
that particular element is smaller than
the pivot element then it will move to
the left side otherwise on the right
side
all right now it's done
now the only thing left is the
positioning of the pivot element and to
do that because we have to find the
partitioning point so we have to
position the pivot element at at its
proper place so for that we'll use the
temporary variable again
and
arr
and index
then
we'll swap it
with index
so here we are done with the swapping
now we have found the partitioning point
so we will return the
index
now the pivot is at its proper position
now all the elements on the left side of
the pivot element are smaller than that
and all the elements on the right side
of it are greater than that
now let's try to save it and run it
i hope it works
there are some errors let's check
all right
all right let's do it
and this one is
this one is extra
all right now let's save it and run it
enter the number of elements let's say
we have entered five
not that place
five elements
three
one
nine 5
7
1 3 5 7 9
so this is our sorted elements of the
array
and we have done it using the quick sort
method or the algorithm
and this is our code
and this is our logic behind the
quicksort method
you can also practice this quicksort
algorithm it is one of the most
efficient sorting algorithm
and we have done the examples of bubble
sort selection sort insertion sort and
quick sort you can practice them all
today's topic is pointers in c plus and
in today's session we will learn about
what is a pointer
reference and dereference operator
then declaration and initialization of a
pointer
then there is pointer arithmetic
and after that we'll go through pointers
and functions pointers and arrays and at
last we have areas of one so let's go to
our first topic that is what is a
pointer
pointer can be defined as a variable
that contains the address of another
variable
it basically stores the memory address
which means it points to an address of a
particular value
and like a regular variable pointers
have a data type also
now coming to reference and dereference
operators
reference operator or address of
operator is defined as that operator
which is used to get the address of the
variable
it can be easily obtained by preceding
the name of the variable with an
ampersand sign
now dereference operator
dereference operator basically returns
the content stored in the variable
pointed by the specified pointer
for example if we write asterisk a
then it will return the value of
variable pointed by a
now let's see how to declare and
initialize a pointer to declare a
pointer first of all we will write the
data type
after that we will write the name of the
variable with an asterisk sign
for example
int asterisk sign a
float asterisk b care astrix c
suppose if we want to store the address
into a pointer
then we will write int that is the data
type
then ptr that is the name of the pointer
with an asterisk sign
equals to a variable a with ampersand
sign
which means
ptr will contain the address of the
variable a
now moving to a pointer arithmetic
c plus allows us to perform addition and
subtraction operations on pointers
a pointer is basically an address that
is it's a numeric value therefore
operations like addition subtraction can
easily be done on pointers
there are four types of arithmetic
operations that can be used in pointers
that is increment operator decrement
operator addition and subtraction
each time a pointer is incremented by
one it points to the memory location of
the next element
but if the pointer is an integer pointer
its value on ptr plus plus would
increment by 4 bytes because of the size
of in data type
for example assume an integer pointer
with current value of 10
now after the increment its value would
be 14 instead of 11 because int is of 4
bytes
now let's learn about pointers and
functions
like a normal variable has an address
similarly every function has an address
also and we can easily access the
function using its reference or address
only if we know the address of the
function
function pointers are similar to that of
normal pointers
when pointers are passed to the function
the address of actual arguments in the
calling function is copied into the
formal arguments of the called function
and this is the syntax for a declaration
of function pointer
here int is the return type and
parenthesis around function pointer
tells the compiler that it is a pointer
to function
and after this
they are argument lists now
let's discuss pointers and arrays
arrays and pointers are very closely
related to each other and both of them
are objects
when an array gets declared the compiler
assigns a continuous block of memory so
that all the elements of an array can be
stored in the memory and c plus treats
the name of the array as a pointer that
contains the address of first element
which is known as base address so
basically array name is the base address
of the array
and if we have to assign the address or
first element of array in a variable x
then instead of writing x equal to
ampersand array of 0
we can simply write the name of the
array only
now moving to the last topic that is
array of pointers
like in array we can store similar type
of elements it is same in case of vary
of pointers
but the only difference is instead of
storing the elements the address of
similar type of element is stored
in other words it stores the pointers
which point to the similar data type
and this is the syntax first is data
type
then name of array with an asterisk sign
then in the brackets it is the size of
array now
let's do some examples in our code
editor that is vs code if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
here we will do one example of pointer
to understand reference and dereference
operator
we will print the values of variable and
the address of that variable also and it
will give us an idea about reference and
error reference operator
let's start
first of all we'll make a new file
and name this file as
pointer1.cpp
so first of all we will import the
header file
cache include iostream
now we will include namespace standard
after that we will make int main
and now we will declare a variable
val
and assign it a value let's say 105
now we will declare a pointer variable
ptr
now we will store the address of the
variable val
into the pointer variable
so we will write ptr equals
ampersand well
now
[Music]
we'll display a message
before
printing val variable will display a
message saying
value is
value of
val is
now
let's see what is the value of ptr
for that we will have to print ptr also
and we'll write
value of
ptr
is now we will print the pointer
variable ptr also
although the value of val and ptr would
be same but in order to check we will
print that also
so we'll write
out
value of
specific ptr
is
now as we have printed variable val
ptr and
asterisk ptr
so now let's check
all these values
let's
write return 0
now let's check all these values
here we can see value of variable val is
105
and the value of ptr is this this is
actually the address
and
the value of
pointer variable ptr is 105
as we know that the value of vl and the
pointer variable is same
because we have assigned this value
the address of variable val to ptr
and then the dereference operator
as we know returns the actual content of
the variable so that is why the value of
variable well gets printed when we print
the pointer variable ptr
and the address over here
is the address of the val variable which
we are assigning to the ptr
so that is why this address is getting
printed
now we will do another example
let's name it
pointer two dot cpp
now we'll include the header files
dash include iostream
after that
using namespace standard
so here we have an example of arithmetic
operations in c plus plus
so
first of all we'll write intent
now here we will take four variables and
two pointers
so let's do it
and
num1
command num2
and
sum equals
zero
and in
sub
equals zero we'll initialize it with
zero
now i will declare the pointers
ptr1
ptr2
so let's take input of the required
variables num1 and num2 and after that
we'll do some mathematic operations on
them
so let's just write
first we'll display a message
enter two numbers
enter
two numbers
now we'll take the input
after this we will store the address of
num1 and num2 into ptr1 and pdr2
respectively let's do it
ptr1
ampersand
num1
ptr2
ampersand num2
now we will increment pointer ptr1 and
ptr2
we'll do in a bracket
and we'll use the reference operator
also
ptr1 plus plus
the reference operator dtr2
plus plus
here we are using the reference operator
because we want to increment the value
only
and as we can see
we have used increment operator so by
incrementing ptr1 and ptr2
the values of num1 and num2 will
increment and after that we will print
those values
so let's do it
before printing we'll just print a
message
after increment
now we will print
ptr1
and line
now ptr2
now we will do the sum of these
incremented values so we will write sum
equals
the reference operator ptr
1
plus
the reference operator ptr2
now we will simply print it
we'll write addition
and we'll print some variable
which we have already initialized as
zero earlier
and we'll write end line
so this will give us the sum of the
incremented values of
num1 and m2
now let's talk about decrementing the
value of pointers using decrement
operator
here by using this operator the value of
the ptr1 and pta2 gets decremented so
let's start
write
decrement ptr 1
minus minus
that is the decrement operator
now
ptr2
and s minus
now we will write
after decrement
the values of ptr1 and ptr2
so we'll display a message saying
after decrement
now we will print ptr1 and ptr2
this will display the values of ptr1 and
pta2 after decrement
and at last we will find the subtraction
of
so we'll write sub
decrement operator ptr1 minus decrement
operator ptr2
and
c out
will display first subtraction we'll
write subtraction
then we'll write the variable sub
let's see how it
before that i think we forgot to mention
the dereference operator
while printing
we have to mention this because we want
to print the values
the reference operator
and
let's put some space over here
now let's try
enter two numbers so let's say we'll
enter four
and five
as you can see we have entered 4 and 5
after increment it becomes 5 and 6
and on addition it becomes 11
after decrement it becomes 4 and 5 again
then
4 minus 5 that is equal to minus 1 so
this is the right answer
and this is how it's done
this was the basic example of arithmetic
operations and pointers
now let's do another example
name this file as pointer 3 dot cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include
iostream
using namespace standard
now we'll write end main
now we will do an example of pointer and
arrays in which all we have to do is to
print an array with the help of
pointers so let's start
first of all we will declare a pointer
now we will declare an array
named
a rrey
and let's add some elements inside it
5
17.
sorry twenty
seven
nine
four
six
i think these are seven elements
now we will assign array arr to pointer
ptr so we will write ptr
equals arr
after that we will run a loop from i
equal to 0 to i
less than 7 because we want to white
rate array elements
so
let's write for loop
and i equals 0 i less than
7
i plus plus
now we will display
using
the reference operator with pointer
because we want to display the values
that is why we have used the reference
operator
now we will do
ptr
plus plus
we have used ptr plus plus because we
want the pointer to move to the next
position after each iteration
and ndl will help to print the output in
the next line after each iteration
so after this we'll write
return 0
and let's try to run it
i think there is some error
yeah
namespace
now let's again try to run it
instead of array we have used arr
hope it works now
here it is
four
27946
five seventeen twenty seven nine four
six
so these are
our array elements which you want to
print
so this is how we can print the array
elements with the help of pointer so
these were some basic examples of
pointers in c plus in this session we
will learn about this pointer in c plus
plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so in this session we will cover topics
like what is this pointer
then we will have a look at the syntax
of this pointer
then we will understand the working of
this pointer and after that we will
learn
how to access the executing object using
this keyword
and we'll also learn about the features
of this pointer
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
so first topic is
what is this pointer
in c
this is a keyword that is used to
represent an object that invokes the
member functions
it automatically points to the object
for which the object is being called
or in other words
this keyword points to the current
instance or object of the class
for example let us suppose we have a
local variable of same name as that of
the data member and we want to assign
the value of a local variable to the
data member but having the same name
would create a problem
so in this type of case we use this
pointer
this keyword tells the compiler that we
are referring to objects data members
now
let's learn about the syntax of this
pointer the syntax for referring class
variable or instance variable would be
this keyword
then arrow operator with class variable
equal to local variable value
and the syntax for referring to current
object of class
would be this with asterisk sign
or d reference operator sign
now
let's understand
working of this pointer
this keyword represents the address of
current instance of the class
the this pointer acts as an implicit
parameter to all the member functions
now implicit parameters are similar to
normal parameters
the only difference is these parameters
are passed silently to the functions
that is
it is passed as a hidden argument and is
automatically passed to the member
function when it is called
now let's learn how to access the
executing object
as we can see in the example we have
created an object obj of class o
and with the help of this object we have
called this function display in which we
are printing the address of the object
and we are also printing this pointer
and this is the executing object
so by printing this
we will get the address of object in the
memory
along with this we can also access the
data members using this keyword
all right now
let's move to features of this pointer
the first feature
would be to distinguish the data members
from local variables which means it
helps in making the class members more
readable by differentiating the members
of the class and the parameters which
have the same name
this keyword helps in differentiating
between the class variable and the
parameters
as we can see in the example we are
assigning the var variable
which is a parameter
to the class member where
and this can only be done with the help
of this pointer
now
let's move to the next feature
that is
method chaining in c plus plus
method chaining in c plus plus is a very
useful feature of this pointer it helps
to chain methods together for ease and
cleaner code
in this each method returns an object
and allows the call to be changed
together into a single statement
it helps in invoking multiple methods
that are chained together as we can see
in the example set method replace method
and inc method are chained together in a
single statement and arguments are also
passed
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so now let's go ahead and do some
examples of this pointer in our code
editor that is vs code
all right so here we will do an example
of this pointer in which we will show
that how this pointer differentiates
between the class member and the
parameters having the same name
so let's go ahead and first of all let's
create a new file
and let's name it
this one dot cpp
all right now we can write the
header files
hash include iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
now we'll start with the main function
we'll write int main
inside in main first of all we will
write the class name and then the object
of that class let's say obj
now
let's write return zero first of all
and now we can make some calls with this
object but before that
let's create class
so all right now we have to create a
class
which has the name a
as we know the class name is a we have
already defined and the name of the
object is obj so let's create class
a
and inside that class
we will inside the private scope
we will declare some variables
let's say
and x
y
and z
so these three are the variables now
i'm sorry
spelling is wrong in
z
so these three are the variables
now inside the public scope
we will create a function
let's say the name of the function is
set
so data type is void name of the
function is set
and
from the main function we will call this
set function
so all we need to do is we'll write the
name of the object
obj dot operator
set which is the name of the function
and we will pass
the arguments let's say
20
54 and 65
these are random numbers
now
here we will write
int x
and y
intersect
as you can see the
parameters and the class members
have the same name
so variables
are of same name
so for that we know that we have to
write this
pointer
so
we will write
this
x
so here
this x is the parameter one and this x
is the class variable so this pointer
differentiates between both of them
as the name is same so this will help in
differentiating
we'll do the same for y
and we will do same for x this
arrow operator
z equals to
z
so here we are assigning the values to
these class members
now
after that we will display these values
so let's create another function let's
say the name of the function is void
print
all right so inside this function will
simply display these variables
so we'll write
x value is
the small one x
x value
is
the variable x and after that we will
write n l
right
y value is
y
handle
we'll do same for z we can copy it
and just paste it
it will save some time
all right as we have displayed or
printed all of these three variables
so
as the class ends so we need to add the
semicolon in the end
now
this print function we need to call this
one
so with
obj object
we will call this print function
all right
so
after calling this we have already added
return 0 so let's save this one and try
to run it
all right let's check
here it is x value is 20
y value is 54 and z value is 65
so arrow operator helped us in
differentiating between the class
members and the parameters
what if we don't use this
let's
have a look at that as well
if we do not use this
pointer
then
let's save it and let's try to run this
let's check the output
as you can see x value is zero y value
zero z value zero it is not correct so
this one is right and this is our output
correct output
now
let's do another example
so here we will do an example and see
that the
this pointer can be used for calling the
member function as well
so we will do an example regarding that
so first of all let's name this
this 2 dot cpp
let's save it
and we'll start with hash include
iostream
now the namespace standard
we'll start with int main
inside int main we will
name the class
and create the object obj
class name is king and the object name
is obj
so from here we will call a function
let's say obj
dot
let's say the name of the function is
text here we are calling
and let's say return 0 after this
now we have to create this class
so let's create this class
class king
and inside this class king
inside the public scope
we will declare the functions
first of all we'll declare function
call
and
now
we will define a function
that is text
so inside this text function
all we need to do
is to print a message
and call another function
so first of all we will print a text or
a message let's say
hello brother
so after that
we'll write endl
now we will call another
not c out we will call this function
call which we have declared and not
defined yet
so we will write this
arrow operator
cal
call
this is how you can call using this
pointer
and
here we are calling this call function
so
we'll close the class using semicolon
and now
inside the class scope let's say
void king scope resolution operator
this means that
this function is
of class king
so
now we will
print whatsoever we want let's say
a is
will display a text
let's say
a and that's it
then we'll do the same for
b and c
here we will print b
and now we will print c
all right now
all we need to do
and everything is done yeah because we
have created this function outside so
we don't have to use this semicolon now
we can save this
and we can try to run this
here we can see uh hello brother and abc
so this is what we want to print here we
can see we have used this
pointer to call this call function
and
after printing this hello brother
a b and c is getting printed so this
means this is the correct output
now let's do another example
let's make a new file and save this one
let's name it this three dot cpp
all right so here now we will do an
example of method chaining as we know we
use method chaining when we want to
return the reference of the object
and method chaining help us in writing a
clean code as it chains up the calling
together into a single statement so
let's start
first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include iostream
now
write the namespace standard
now we'll write the main function
by mistake we have
all right
now inside the main function first of
all we write the name of the class that
is test
and we'll create the object
the name of the object would be n1
now we will chain up the calls
let's say the name of the object n1
and the name of the function let's say
is assign
and we are passing 100
and now i will chain up display function
with it
so this is method chaining
now
we will write it on zero
and now we'll start with the
class
so
class name is test
and inside the class
we'll declare a variable let's say
num
and
now under public scope
we will
write the function
and
will not define the function in a usual
way we'll write the data type first of
all let's say
test
is the data type
address of operator
assign which is the name of the function
and
argument would be num the parameter
would be num
and inside this function
will use this
arrow operator
and now we will assign
the value of
parameter num
to the class variable
after that we can return reference to
the object we'll use the dereference
operator
and
this pointer
now
we'll make another function that is
display
and inside this display function
will print a message
and we'll print the
variable that is done
so first of all we'll print the message
saying that
the value
of num
is
all right after the class we'll put a
semicolon
and we'll try to run this one
after saving it
so as we can see
the value of num is 100
so let's do some modifications in that
let's say
we want to add 1000
so it will get added but we need to save
it first
now we'll try to run
as you can see the value of num is now
1100
so these are chain function calls and
when the reference is returned this
reference
is returned then this reference can be
used to change the function calls from a
single object that is
n1 in this case
so
this is the data type and this is the
address of operator when we are doing
the method chain we must do it like this
and then we will return the reference to
the object
so these were some examples of this
pointer in c plus plus you can try some
more examples if you want to learn this
topic in a much better way
in this video we will learn about
references in c
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so we will learn what are references in
c plus
then the creation of references
after that we will learn about reference
in the function and returning the
reference from the function
next we will have a look at the
applications of references and
understand the difference between
reference and pointer
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and press the
bell icon to never miss an update
so first is what are references in c
plus plus
a reference can be defined as an
alternative name of the variable
as the name suggests it is used to refer
to an existing variable
it is basically used to store the
reference of the variable and is stored
using an ampersand sign
although the reference and address are
the same thing but their context is
different
when we are talking about reference
variable then we will call it reference
rather than address
the variable can either be accessed with
the help of variable name or by the
reference name
so as we have understood about
references in c plus plus so now let's
learn how to create reference in c plus
let's suppose we have a variable named
data
and we know how to declare a variable
first its data type then the variable
name and then we will assign the value
to the variable
here int is the data type
data is the variable name and 10 is the
value that is assigned to the variable
if we want to declare a reference
variable for the variable data then it
would be like this
first is the data type
with ampersand sign
then the name of the reference variable
equals to the variable name of which we
are storing the reference of
as you can see int ampersand ref
which is the name of the reference
variable equals to data which is the
name of the variable
so we can say ref is the reference
variable for the data variable and it
can be used instead of the variable name
now
coming to reference in the function
we can pass the reference to the
function as a parameter
it is similar to passing the pointers to
the function but it is safer
while passing the reference to the
function the changes made inside the
function will also be reflected outside
because after passing the reference to
the function the past reference will
access the actual argument
so the changes that are done to the
parameter inside the function will
affect the arguments
in addition it is safer and provides a
cleaner code
to pass the value as reference all we
need to do is to change the function
parameter as reference type as you can
see in the calculation function int
ampersand a
now let's learn about returning the
reference in c plus
similar to pointers references can also
be returned
while returning the reference an
implicit pointer is also returned
in return by reference
no local variable is returned and no
constant is returned
only the global variable is returned in
return by reference function calling is
done on the left hand side of the
assignment operator
as you can see in the example
n is returned from the function but it
is not the value that we are returning
but the address of the variable
when this variable is returned then the
value 15 is assigned to it
which is then printed as we can see in
the example
now coming to applications of references
in c plus
so first is
references helps in modifying or
changing the values inside the function
without actually passing the actual
arguments
because we can easily pass the reference
instead of variable and if we pass the
reference to the function then also it
can modify or change the values
second is
references helps with operator
overloading because unlike pointers they
work with references and values
rather than pointer variables
third is
references helps with writing less error
prone code and by replacing values with
references while calling avoids the
unnecessary copy of data
so these were some applications of
references in c plus
now let's understand the difference
between reference and pointer
the reference can be defined as an alias
of the variable
here the word alias means additional
name or we can say
also known for the name
on the other hand a pointer is used to
store the memory address of the variable
reference cannot have a null value
whereas pointers can have a null value
references cannot be reassigned to other
values
whereas
pointers can be reassigned to other
values
it returns the reference of the variable
on the other hand pointer returns the
value located at the address of the
variable
reference can be initialized during its
creation only it cannot be
re-initialized
whereas
pointer can be initialized as many times
as required
so these were some differences between
reference and pointer
now let's go ahead and do some examples
of reference in c plus in our code
editor that is vs code
all right so here we will do an example
of return by reference in c plus we all
know how to return a value from a
function
so now we will understand how can we
return a reference from the function
all right so let's start
first of all create a new folder and
let's save it
and name it as
ref1
dot cpp
now we will save it
all right so first of all we'll include
the header files and then we'll start
with the main function
hash include iostream
and then the name space standard
now let's start with the main function
inside the main function
first of all like normally we'll do for
the functions we will call
let's name the function as club
so this is how we normally call a
function
and
after that we create a function like
this
like
int
club
and
then
this is how normal calling works but in
this case we want this function
to return the reference
and for that we have to use the
ampersand sign
so we have used this ampersand sign
and this is a syntax int which is the
data type then the ampersand sign then
the name of the function and if we want
to pass any arguments then we can do
that and keep in mind that inside this
function we cannot return any local
variable or any constant like we cannot
return we cannot create a variable
inside this function assign it some
value and then return it we can't do
that and we can only return the global
variable
let me show you that we cannot return
this return
8 as this is a constant and we can't do
like this like
int
p equals to 9
and then we will return it
return p we can't do like this as well
all we need to do is to create a global
variable and then we will return
all right
so let's create a global variable
let's say the global variable is
n
and so we'll return
n
now if we want to assign
some
value to this global variable we have to
call this club function
and we have to make this calling on the
left hand side of the assignment
operator
like this
and now we have to assign the value
like
let's say the value is 75
so here we're assigning the value and
calling this reference operator we are
assigning the value to this global
variable this n global variable and in
this part we are actually assigning this
75 value to this global variable n
now we can print this n variable which
is global and check if its value is 75
or not
all right so let's save it and let's try
to run this
as you can see 75
so this is an example of return by
reference in z plus plus
now let's move on to another example
all right now
all right we know a reference cannot be
reassigned that also means a single
reference cannot refer to two different
values
but two different references can have a
single value
or in other words a value can have two
different references
so in this example we'll show
how a value can have two different
references
so let's start doing this example first
of all we'll include the header files
hash include iostream
now the namespace standard
all right
now inside the main function
we will create a variable
and two different
references the variable is num and we
will assign it a value let's say 70
and
we will create two different references
in
num1 and one and
we will assign it to num
and
into
is also signing to the same variable so
there are two references n 1 and n 2
which are referring to the same variable
num
so now we will print this variable num
and both of these reference variable
that is n1 and n2 to check if they are
pointing to the same value
so let's do this
we will write
c out
value of
num is
all right now
again
value of
reference
n1
is
and one
handle
similarly
value
of
reference
and 2 is
and 2
and l
all right
so we have printed all of
these variables and references
and now return
0. and let's check if they're
running fine or not
as you can see value of num is 70 value
of reference n1 is 70 and n2 n2
reference is 70. so we can say all of
these
references and variables are pointing to
the same value and the value of num can
also be accessed by this reference
variable n1 and n2
all right now let's do another example
let's name it ref
two dot cpp
so here we will do an example of
references in c plus plus in which we
will pass the reference into the
function to swap the actual values
basically we don't pass the actual
arguments we only pass the references
and swap the values
so
let's start
so let's include the header files
now we will create the main function and
inside the main function we will declare
two variables and assign the values
and y
17 let's say
now we'll print first of all we'll print
before swapping right
you
all right
so
now we will
call
the function swap we will create a
functions web afterwards
and we'll pass not the values but the
references
and then we can similarly
copy this one
and just paste it again
and we'll do that
after
swiping here we have to do before
swiping right
so first of all we'll print the value of
x and y before swapping then
we will print the values of x and y
after swiping
so now we have to create the definition
or write the definition of swap function
so
let's write void
swap
and do remember that here we are passing
the references not the values so we have
to write like this and ampersand
n1
this is how when we are passing the
values we have to write like this
and
and ampersand
and 2.
here this n1 is referring to x
and this n2 is referring to y
and inside this swap function will
simply
swap as we
know how to swap into temp equals n1
then we'll do
n1 equals n2
we all know how to swap
to here we haven't passed the values
actually we have passed the reference
and using those references we are
swiping the values
so now let's try to run this
save it and
let's run this
as you can see before swiping x value is
12 and y value was 17 after swiping 17
and 12
so as we can see clearly that the value
is swept
so we can say using the references or by
passing the references to a function we
can actually swap the values so this
also proves that references can access
the values
so these were some examples of
references in c plus plus references in
c plus is a very simple topic and there
are very limited examples on this topic
and if you find some more examples
please do try them in today's session we
are going to learn about c plus plus
memory management
and do check out our other videos on the
c plus plus series so let's go ahead and
have a look at what's in it for us
first is what is memory management
then we will understand why we need
memory management in c plus
then we will learn memory allocation and
d allocation in c plus plus using new
operator and delete operator and at last
we will understand the advantages of new
operator in c plus
so without further ado let's get started
what is memory management
memory management can be defined as a
process in which management of a
computer memory occurs
for example assigning memory to programs
variables etc in such a way that it
doesn't affect the overall performance
sometimes the computer's data can range
up to terabytes
so efficient use of memory is necessary
so that we can minimize the memory
wastage and boost up the performance
now
let's understand why we need memory
management in c plus
memory management is required so that
there will be no wastage of memory
and to make sure that allocation takes
place efficiently
during the declaration of an array there
are times when the correct memory is not
determined until runtime
and to avoid such cases we usually
declare array of maximum size
and because of this maximum size some
memory remains unused
for example let us suppose we have
declared an array of size 30 and after
declaring the array it turns out that we
only need space of 10 size
so the rest of the space is of no use or
we can say it will get wasted
to avoid such cases we use memory
allocation
so let's understand memory allocation
and d allocation in z plus plus
other programming languages like java
python etc they don't need to allocate
memory dynamically
in c language we use the malloc or
catalog functions to allocate the memory
dynamically at runtime and these
functions are also supported by c plus
but in c plus allocation and d
allocation is done manually
in c plus there are two operators that
are used for the allocation and
deallocation of memory
that is new operator and delete operator
so let's understand this new operator in
c plus
the new operator in c plus is used for
the dynamic memory allocation
it is used to allocate the memory at
runtime
the general syntax of new operator is
pointer variable which is the name of
the pointer equal to new
which is a keyword and data type is the
type of the pointer
the syntax for arrays is almost the same
but after the data type we have to write
the size inside the brackets which
specifies the number of elements in an
array
and here in the example we first of all
are declaring a pointer ptr of in data
type
after that we are dynamically allocating
the memory using new keyword and at last
we are assigning the value 75 to the
allocated memory
coming to the delete operator
the delete operator in c plus is used
for the deallocation of memory
when we no longer need to use the
variable that means the memory is no
longer required
then we have to deallocate or release
the memory using the delete operator
syntax for delete operator is
delete keyword with the name of the
pointer variable
the syntax for arrays is delete keyword
following the empty brackets and then
name a pointer variable
as you can see in the example once the
printing of value is done
we have deallocated the memory using the
delete operator
moving on to the advantages of new
operator
the new operator and delete operator can
be overloaded unlike the malloc function
next is return type of the new operator
is of the same type for which the memory
was allocated we don't need to use the
typecasting
third is the new operator automatically
computes the size of data object we
don't need to use the size of operator
next is
new operator in c plus allows us to
initialize object while creating memory
space for them
so these were some advantages of the new
operator
so now let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code to do some examples on
the new operator and delete operator
here we will do an example using new and
delete operator in c plus plus that will
allocate the memory location for three
values and find their average
so first of all
let's
create a file and name this file as
mm1 dot cpp
mm means memory management so now first
of all we'll include the header files
hash include iostream
now using namespace standard
now we'll start with into main
okay
so first of all we'll create three
pointer variables
so we'll start
hint
star ptr1
and
star ptr2
we are creating three pointer variables
because we have to find the sum of three
variables so that is why we have to
create three pointers also
and
now we have to store the sum of three
variables into some another variable so
we now will create the variable average
okay
now we will allocate the memory
dynamically
using the new keyword so write ptr1
equals
new
hint which is the data type
same we will do for ptr 2
equals new keyword
hint
here we are allocating the memory
dynamically with the help of new keyword
new
and
sorry time is there
now we will print the value that is
stored in the memory
but before doing that
as we have allocated the memory so now
we will take the input from the users
of those three variables
of which we have to find the average off
so
we'll display
enter first number
after displaying this
we will take the input from the user
we'll write c in
and
using the d reference operator
we'll write ptr1
here we are taking the input from the
user for the first memory location
now we'll take the input of the second
number from the user
for that we have to
print the message again
enter the second number
yeah
now
we'll take the input
using the dereference operator
with the pointer
now same goes for the third one
enter the
third number
the reference operator ptr3
as we have taken all the three numbers
from the user now all we have to do
is to find the average of these three
numbers as we know that d reference
operator will point to the variable
so that is how we'll get the access for
the variable
now we'll write the variable avg that is
average
we know that the reference operator will
display the value
that is pointer pointing at
so
we are actually adding the values
ptr1
plus the reference operator ptr2
plus dereference operator ptr3
divided by 3
this is how we can find the average
after that
all we have to do is to print the
average
so
we'll write
average is
avg
that is the variable
as the result is getting stored in this
variable avg so we'll print that
variable
and once everything is done once the
printing is
then we have to de-allocate the memory
and
we will de-allocate the memory by
writing delete
ptr1
we have to do this for all of these
three pointers create ptr2
because we have allocated the memory for
all of these three pointers so that is
why we have to de-allocate for each one
of them
okay now
everything is done and let's try to run
this
here we can see enter the first number
so
[Music]
let's say
five
we have to find the average of three
numbers so we'll select the easy number
to
check whether it is right or wrong
then we'll write 5 again
now we'll write 2
as we know that 5 plus 5 equals 10
plus 2 equals 12
and
the average of 12 is 4 yeah 3 4 12 so
this is the correct output
so
first of all we have allocated the
memory over here dynamically then we
have deallocated the memory using delete
ptr1 ptr2 and ptr3
so this is how it's done
so let's do one another example
let's name this as
mm2.cpp
okay
we'll write mm4 dot cpp
i think two and three are already taken
so we'll start with hash include
iostream
hash
include
iostream
then we'll write
using namespace standard
so in this question we'll simply enter
the elements of the array and then we
will display those elements
but we will use new operator and delete
operator in this question
so let's start first of all we'll write
int main
now inside int main first of all we'll
write the variable
size we have declared the variable size
and this variable size is the size of
the array
which we will take as an input from the
user
so
first of all
will display
enter the size
enter the size
now
we'll take the input
size
after that we will declare a pointer
variable
ptr
all right
now here we will allocate the memory for
the complete array so we'll write
ptr
new keyword
int
which is the data type and here size
okay here we are allocating the memory
for the complete array of size that we
will enter
okay now
now we will display
the message saying that enter the
elements
as we have allocated the memory
all we have to do is to enter the
elements
we'll use a for loop
so we'll start with i equal 0
i less than size
i plus plus
now
we'll write
element
and after this we'll take the input from
the user
for the elements of the array so we'll
write c in
now just like carries we can do it for
the pointer as well we can write ptr
and just like that is
inside the bracket i
and we can do it
for the output as well
so here we are taking the input of the
elements from the users
now
we have to display those elements
so for that first of all we will display
a message
elements
that
you
have
entered
now we'll use for loop again
and i equals 0
i less than size
i plus plus
now
we'll
print those elements so first of all
we'll write
element
now
ptr
like just we
did earlier ptri
and
end line
so that the output looks good
now everything is done we have allocated
the memory then we have taken the input
from the user and displayed the output
now all we have to do is to delete the
operator
so i'll write
delete
then empty brackets
ptr
all right
now everything is done
we have allocated the memory and here we
are deleting the allocated memory
okay
now let's try to run this
here we can see enter the size let's say
4
now enter the elements
3
6
5
7
and here is the output elements that you
have entered
three six
five seven
that is right but
it is not looking good
let's use slash and over here
and now let's again try to run this
enter the size
4
now
2
4
seven
nine
uh here is the space between them now it
is looking good enter elements that you
have entered are
two four seven nine
so this is how it's done
we have allocated the memory
to an array of size
of size variable
then we have entered the elements
then we have displayed those elements
and at last we have de-allocated the
memory using delete operator
so these are few examples on memory
management c plus memory management you
can try some more examples on them in
this video we will learn about classes
in c plus first we will learn about why
do we need classes
then we will learn what is a class then
we will go through access modifiers and
object of a class
after that member functions and at last
we will learn about constructors and
destructors
so first is why do we need classes
to understand this we need to know that
c plus plus is an object-oriented
language and it also introduces the
concept of real-world entities
so in order to describe the real-world
entities we need two things
that is characteristics and functions
and a class is a mechanism of binding
these two methods together in a single
unit
also class has its own members like
functions variables constructors
destructors etc
which are commonly used in c plus plus
and class has an important role in the
concept of an inheritance as well
now let's understand what is a class
classes are one of the most important
features of c plus that leads to object
oriented programming
it represents the set of properties that
are common among all the objects of same
type
a class basically represents a group of
similar objects which holds its own data
members and member function together
and this is the basic syntax of a class
first is class keyword which is used to
create class then after that we will
write the name of the class
then inside the name of the class there
is access specifier that can be private
public or protected
after that there is data members that is
the variables and then the member
functions and also class body must be
surrounded with braces
now let's discuss access modifiers it
basically grant permission or set the
restriction for data members of the
class
access modifiers in a class are used to
provide accessibility to the class
member
for example in a school teachers are
allowed to see the question papers
before the exams but the students are
not allowed to do so
anyone other than teachers cannot access
those questions
now
we can relate these teachers to data
members of class
which have access and students are
outside functions that do not have the
access
so there are three types of access
modifiers
private public and protected
private members can only be accessed
from within the class that means
outside data members and member
functions cannot access it
public as the name suggests it can be
accessed from within the class and from
outside the class as well
protected members can be accessed from
within the class but cannot be accessed
from outside the class
but with the help of friend function it
can be accessed from outside the class
as well
now let's learn about object of a class
an object is an instance of a class it
is a real word entity that contains
state and behavior
when we create an object of a class then
the memory is allocated and no memory
allocation occurs when class is defined
and we can create as many objects of a
class as we need
in this example state is the class and
st is the object name or reference
variable
so this is how an object is created
now coming to member functions
member functions are also known as
methods
these are as much as part of the class
as the member variables
these member functions can be invoked by
sending messages through an instance of
a class
with the help of dot operator
for example if the name of the object is
obj and we want to access a function
named sum then it will be obj.sum
here obj is the name of the object and
sum is the name of the function
what is a constructor in c plus plus
in c plus plus constructors are special
functions that are different from normal
functions
they are used to initialize objects of a
class
whenever an object is created the
constructor is invoked or called
automatically even if we do not create a
constructor the compiler automatically
creates a default constructor
now let's move to the declaration of the
constructor
constructors are the member functions of
a class that has the same name as that
of the class and it doesn't have any
return type
a constructor can be defined inside the
class and outside the class as well
using the scope resolution operator
the syntax of a constructor is as
mentioned
inside the class cons we can see there
is a constructor which has the same name
as that of class
that is cons and we can initialize
variables inside it
this constructor will be invoked
automatically when the object is
created now let's understand how the
constructor is different from functions
there are some differences between
constructors and functions
so the first is constructor doesn't have
a return type unlike function which has
a return type
next is the name of the constructor must
be the same as that of the class and it
is not so in case of function
third is whenever an object is created
then a constructor is invoked
and the last one is
function can be a virtual function but
it is not so in case of constructors
so these are some differences between
constructor and a function
now coming to types of constructors
there are actually three types of
constructors in c plus that is default
constructor parameterized constructor
and a copy constructor
so let's start with the default
constructor
a default constructor is a constructor
that doesn't have any arguments inside
it it can either be declared explicitly
or can be generated automatically which
means even if we do not define the
constructor then also it is generated by
the compiler
for example here cons is the default
constructor
in this case the name of the class would
have been cons that is why the name of
the constructor is cons
now coming to the parameterized
constructor
a parameterized constructor is similar
to that of the default constructor the
only difference is we can pass the
arguments to the parameterized
constructor
the constructor can be overload and also
be used to initialize elements
here is an example of the parameterized
constructor
cons is the name of the constructor and
n1 and 2 are the parameters of the
constructor
now
coming to the copy constructor a copy
constructor is a type of constructor
which initializes an object using
another object of the class
in this constructor properties of one
object is copied to another object
this copy constructor is invoked when an
object is passed as a parameter
if a class has pointers or there is some
dynamic memory allocation then it is
necessary to have a copy constructor
its syntax is as follows
here cons is the name of the constructor
and ampersand obj
is the reference of the object as we
have understood all of these three
constructors so let's go ahead to our
next topic that is constructor
overloading
like functions constructor can also be
overloaded and it is pretty much the
same as function overloading
the constructor must have the same names
and the difference in the number or the
type of arguments will decide
which constructor should be called
here in the example we can see two
constructors with the same names as that
of the class are being overloaded
here the difference in the number of
parameters will determine which
constructor will be called
now coming to the last topic that is
destructors in c plus
just like the constructor the destructor
is also a special function
which deletes or destructs the object as
soon as the object goes out of scope
it basically delocates the memory that
has been assigned to the variables
the name of the destructor is same as
that of the class name with a tilt sign
the destructor doesn't have a return
type and it also doesn't take any
arguments
and here is the syntax of the destructor
now here we will make a new file
and let's name this file as
class dot cpp
now here we will do a program in which
we will make a class and inside that
class we will make some functions and
with the help of objects of that class
we will call those functions
so let's start
first of all we'll mention the header
files hash include
iostream
now
using namespace standard
now let's
make a class
and with a class keyword
and name this class as let's say
franchise
now here don't forget to mention the
semicolon
now
here we will write the access modifier
that is public
now we will mention those functions
let's say void
let's name this function as kfc
now inside this function
we will
print
something like let's say
we have the best chicken
after this we'll write nl
now we'll make another function named
burger king
as we know that these two are
famous franchise so that is why we have
put this under class for franchise
now let's
print here
we have the best burgers
now we'll try to
print these two functions with the help
of object that are made from the class
franchise so what we'll do is
we'll write end main
after the franchise class we'll write
int main and inside this class
we'll make an object of class franchise
franchise is the class name friend is
the object name
now
all we have to do is the calling
we'll call the function kfc and we'll
call the function burger king with the
help of fran object
so let's do this
friend
dot operator
kfc
that is the function name
after that we will write fran
dot
burger king
return 0
now let's try to run this one
here it is actually i have run it twice
so that is why it is getting printed
twice
we have the best chicken we have the
best burgers that is what we want to
print
first here friend dot kfc
called this void kfc inside this class
franchise after that
friend.burger king called this
function burger king
so that is why they have printed serial
wise we have the best chicken we have
the best burgers
after this we'll do another example
so let's do this
first of all we will name this file
class
class2.cpp
okay i think it already exists
we have to name it something else
three
okay now we will write
the header files
hash include iostream
now using
namespace standard
in this example we will try to access a
private variable
as we know that it can only be accessed
from within the class but it can be done
with the help of set regetter methods
so let's start
first of all we'll write
hint main
now we'll
make an object
for that we have to write the class name
which is
billboard
we'll make this class afterwards
first of all we'll write the
class name after that we'll write
object
let's name the object bill
billboard is class name bill is the
object name
now we will call
a particular method
or a function
which we call setter method we will
write
bill
dot
will name that setter method as set
title
basically this
function will access
or assign the value to the private
variable which we were talking about
so we'll write here
let's say top
five songs
of
2020
we want this title to be written on the
billboard
now we'll write the getter method
basically the setter method or set title
method will set or assign the value of
to the private variable and get method
or get title method will return that
value from there
so we'll write
bill dot
get
title
now because we want to print it so that
is why we'll write it
in c out
okay
now after that we'll write return zero
now we will make the class billboard
class keyword
billboard
after that bracket starts
now we will write
private
because you want
the variable to private
so
the data type string
and the variable is title
now this variable is private and we want
to assign the value to this variable
which is not possible because they are
not of the same class but we will do
that with the help of scetargetter
method so let's do that
now we will write public
because we want our functions to be
public
now
void that is the data type
set title
and inside the bracket we will
write the variable
now this method is taking this very this
parameter x so we will assign this
parameter x to the
private variable
let's do that
title that is the private variable
x
now
we will write another method
named get title
there are no parentheses in get title
method because
this method is only returning the value
so we'll write
return
title now get title function or method
is returning the value of private
variable title
so here what happening is here the
function set title which is public is
taking a parameter x and is assigning to
the title variable
so the message will get assigned to the
title variable
now get title function is returning the
value of private variable title
which is getting called in the main
function
one more thing we forgot to
put semicolon over here
and
we
get title cannot be void
because it is returning
it would be string
because it is returning some value
now
so basically
build dot set title in the main function
will set the value or assign the value
to the private variable and
build.gettitle will return the value of
that private variable which will get
printed
so now let's try to run this
[Music]
top 5 songs of 2020. here we can see
it is getting printed
so this is how we can do that we can
access the private variable using setter
and getter method
now let's do another example
let's name this as
class 4.cpp
now here we will do the same example but
we will do it with the help of
constructors
so let's continue first of all we'll
write
hash include iostream
after that
using namespace standard
now here first of all we'll write int
main
now
we'll name the class we'll write the
name of the class that is billboard
and we'll make the object of it
as we have done previously like bill
now
we'll make
a constructor of this object
and will pass the parameters
we will pass the string as
top three
songs
of 2020
as we are passing this string to the
constructor that means the constructor
is parameterized constructor
and now
we'll write
bill
dot
get
title
here we are writing this because
function this function is returning the
value of private variable title so that
is why we have to write it
and we'll print it actually
see out
return 0
now let's do the other thing
as we have done previously we'll write
class
billboard we are making this class
and inside this class we are making
the variable private
string title is private
now we'll write public access modifier
now here we will write the constructor
in which we were passing the string from
the main function
so we'll write the name of the
constructor
as you all know the name of the
constructor is same as that of the class
so it would be billboard
and
the parameter is
b
that parameters which we are passing
from the main function is getting stored
in b
now inside this constructor will call
the method set title
so we'll write set
title
we are passing the same string
to the set title method
now
we'll make this method
set title we'll write
void set title
string a
so actually what is happening
we have passed the string name top three
songs of 2020 to the constructor
the constructor is further calling to
the method or function named set title
and is passing that string to the same
function
now that function is set title and now
we will assign that string to the
private variable title
so let's write
title equals a
a is that string
now
as we have done previously we'll write
void
get
title
now get title function is used for
returning the value of private variable
as we know so we'll write
string actually
string
get title
return
title
semicolon
now let's try to run it
i think something is wrong
here capital s we have written
let's make it correct now let's try to
run again
here we can see top three songs of 2020
so this is how we can print with the
help of constructor
this was the same example as that of the
previous one but to understand
constructors we have done this with the
help of constructors and we get the
right output
so after this we'll do the example of
destructors
okay let's name this
as class 6
dot cpp
now let's write the header files
hash include
iostream
using namespace standard
now we'll start with int main
so first of all we will write the class
name
that is gambit
to access the class we need to have an
instance or object of class
here the name of the object is gam
after this we will call a function
display
so we will write
gam dot display
return 0
now let me tell you what is happening
so as we declared this object
constructor will be called that is
gambit and the message inside the
constructor will be printed
after the constructor gets completed we
will return back to the main
now we have game dot display which is
used to call display function inside the
gambit class
so after this we will write the class
let's make it
class keyword
gambit
now we'll write
public access modifier
now we'll write the constructor
and inside the constructor will display
the message
we'll write
hello
hello there
i'm constructor
i am in constructor
now here we will write the destructor
gambit
and inside the
destructor we will print the message
just to indicate that we are in the
destructor
hello there
i am in destructor
semicolon
but before that we have to
write the function display also so we'll
write
void
display
and we'll print the message
let's say hello
and
now let's try to understand this again
as the object is declared constructed
will be called that is gambit and the
message inside the constructor will be
printed
after the constructor gets completed we
will return back to the main
now we have gam.display
which is used to call display function
inside the gambit class
so hello will be printed
now as we can see the program has
finished the execution now the
destructor will be called and hello i am
destructor will be printed
as we know destructor destroys the
object and as the scope of the object
ends so after the scope of the object
ends hello i am in destructor gets
printed in the last
so now let's try to run this
here we can see
hello there i'm in constructor
then hello is printed then hello there i
mean destructor is printed as we have
thought
destructor is getting printed in the
last because as we know that when the
scope ends the destructor is called
so these are some basic examples of
classes in c plus
in order to understand them better you
must practice some more examples on them
in today's session we will learn
why we need oops
then what is object oriented programming
then we will discuss the difference
between oops and procedural programming
then we'll go through basic concepts of
oops and at last we will learn about the
benefits of hoops
there were some limitations in earlier
approaches to programming and oops help
to fill those gaps
in object oriented programming it is
easy to maintain the code with the help
of classes and objects and with the help
of inheritance there is code reusability
that is we don't have to write the same
code again and again which increases the
simplicity of the program
now let's understand what is object
oriented programming
object oriented programming is a
programming pattern where the programs
are structured around objects rather
than logic and functions
in other words we basically focus on
objects that are required to be
manipulated instead of logic
for example let us suppose we have made
blueprint of a mole then that blueprint
will be a plan that explains what
properties the mall should have and how
it should look like etc
but it is just a blueprint of the mall
we cannot go inside it physically as of
now
now the constructors will go through the
blueprint and they will construct them
all and they can make as many malls as
they want with the help of that
blueprint and each mall can have its own
different shops and showrooms
in this case blueprint is the class the
mall is the object and the show ups and
showrooms inside the malls are data
stored in the object's properties
and these are some basic concepts of
hoops
first is classes then objects then data
abstraction and encapsulation then there
is inheritance polymorphism dynamic
binding and message passing we will
learn about these concepts later first
we will discuss the difference between
oops versus procedural programming
procedural programming follows top down
approach here top down approach means
fragmenting a bigger complication into
smaller chunks
oops follows bottom-up approach and
bottom-up approach means
piecing together smaller tasks to give
rise to complex tasks
in procedural programming overloading is
not possible
in oops overloading can be done
in procedural oriented programming there
are no access specifiers in oop
they have access specifiers like private
protected public
procedural oriented programming is less
secure
oops is more secure because of the
concepts like abstraction and
encapsulation which are used for data
hiding
now let's learn the basic concepts of
oops
first is class
class can be defined as collection of
objects it is a logical entity
then there is object
it is defined as an entity that has
state and behavior or in other words
anything that exists physically in the
world is called an object
inheritance can be defined as when one
object acquires properties and behavior
from its parent class
it provides code usability
polymorphism polymorphism is a
combination of two words poly which
means many and morphs which means forms
it is basically an ability to exist in
more than one form
next is abstraction
hiding the internal details and showing
the functionality to the user is called
abstraction
then encapsulation encapsulation is the
binding of code and data together into a
single unit
in dynamic binding
dynamic binding is the method called at
runtime that means which code will
execute is unknown until the program
runs
then there is message passing
it is basically a communication that
exists between the objects
as we have gone through some concepts of
oops
now let's discuss some benefits of oops
in oops code can easily be reused with
the help of inheritance and object
we don't need to write the same code
over and over
second is with the help of abstraction
and encapsulation certain parts of
program can be hidden and it helps to
make a secure system
third is maintaining and modification of
code is easy in object oriented
programming
now to do some examples on concepts of
oops let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code
now here we will do a program of
inheritance in which we will make a
parent class and a child class and we
will call the attributes using object of
child class
so let's get started first of all
let's name the file
oop
dot cpp
okay so first of all we'll add the
header files hash include
iostream
now adding namespace standard
now we will write int main
so we want to create the object of side
class so first of all we'll write the
name of class child that is child
let's put c capital
child and now the name of the object ch
so now we will call the attributes using
this object
so we'll write first of all
display it so we'll write c
out ch
dot
name
1
which is the attribute
we will declare it later
so basically we want to write both the
names of both the classes together so
that is why
we are doing like this we'll write name
two
name one will be the attribute of the
parent class and name two will be the
attribute of child class
so after that we'll write
return zero
now
we'll make the parent class and the
child class so first of all let's write
class
parent we'll name it as parent
then
we'll write public access specifier
string
is the data type
name
one
let's write
harley
okay
now it is mandatory to write the
semicolon at the end of the class
now
we'll write the derived class that is
child
will write the column symbol
then we will write public
name of the parent class that is parent
so here we are writing
the child class is derived from the
parent class
now
within the bracket will
write public
then string the data type
name
to
will write
davidson
it's a popular bike brand harley
davidson
so
now we'll write the semicolon over here
now we'll try to run this
[Music]
as you can see harley davidson
here harla is from the parent class and
davidson is from the child class so as
we can see that we are calling from the
object of child class and still we are
able to access the attribute of parent
class
so this shows that the child class
inherits attributes or properties from
the parent class
now as we have done one example of
inheritance
so now let's do one example of
polymorphism also
let's name it oop
one dot cpp
first of all we'll include the header
files
let's include iostream
stream
now we'll write using namespace standard
after that we'll write int main
now here we will do an example of
polymorphism in which we will make a
base class and its derived classes and
inside these classes we will override a
function which is common in all of these
classes
so let's start
first of all we'll write the name of the
parent class or base class
animal
and will make an object a
after that we'll write the name of the
child class jeeta
and its object name is c let's say
now
another derived class dolphin
and we'll name the object as d
now while making these classes we'll
write a function named speed
in all of these classes inside all of
these classes and now in order to
override that function we'll call them
so
first of all we'll call it by the object
of animal that is a
a dot speed
now c dot
speed
this is the object of cheetah class
now
d dot speed
after that we'll write return zero
now let's make these classes
first of all we will make the animal
class that is the base class
animal
now we'll write the access specifier
public
now we'll write the function
void that is the data type speed
now we will
display a message inside this function
let's say
it displays who is more faster
who
is
more
faster
okay
now
we'll put a semicolon in the end
now we will make a derived class that is
dolphin
we write class
dolphin
child of
animal
class
okay so now inside this class
we'll write public
and we'll make the same function speed
and we'll display a message
saying
as this class is of dolphin so
we'll write
i'm faster
in
water
we'll put semicolon
now we'll make
another child
class class
cheetah
okay c is capital cheetah
public
animal
now here we will write
public access specifier
and we'll write the same function wide
speed
and over here will display a message
saying that
i am
faster on the ground
semicolon
so now as we can see that a dot speed is
calling this speed function
in animal class
c dot speed is calling this cheetah
function
in cheetah class
and d dot speed
d dot speed is calling the dolphin
speed function in dolphin class
okay so now let's try to run this
[Music]
okay the output is here but it is not
in very good form so
let's put slash n in the end
okay
slash and
slash n
okay
here it is so first who is faster is
displayed then
i am faster on the ground
then i am faster in water
is displayed
so as we know that first of all we have
called
the animal class so that is why who is
more faster is displayed after that we
have called the cheetah class and
cheetah says that i'm faster on the
ground then dolphin class then dolphin
says i am faster in water
so here we can see that each of the
class have its different implementation
for the same function that is speed
and this is how polymorphism allows us
to do a single action in variety of ways
okay now let's do one example of
abstraction
let's name it as
oop
three dot cpp
first of all we'll include the header
files we'll write hash
include iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
using namespace
std
now as we know abstraction helps in data
hiding so in this program we will make a
variable named coupon as private and
with the help of set coupon function we
will try to assign some value to the
coupon variable
and after that we will display it
so let's start
first of all we'll write int main
now we'll write the name of the class
that is trade fair
trade
fair
and now the name of the object
t
now with the help of this object we will
call a function named set
coupon
i would say coupons
and we'll pass 50 as an argument to this
function
now
we'll display
a message
coupon
and after that
we will call getcoupon method in order
to display the number of coupons so
we'll write t dot
get
coupons
and
brackets
done
after that we'll write return 0
now let's make the class and the
functions
so let's start first of all
we'll write
class
trade fair
now we'll write an access specifier
private
and
i private
now
we will
declare a variable coupon
and as i have already told you we will
make this variable as private so that is
why we have used this access specifier
as private
now
after that we will
write public
access
specifier to write a function
that is set coupons
set
coupons
and the parameter is c
as we know that we have passed 50 to
this
parameter
so
[Music]
now
we will write
the private variable coupon
equals c
so here we are basically assigning
the value of c to the coupon that is we
are assigning 50 to coupon
variable now
after that we will make another function
and
we'll put its data type as int because
it is returning something
so
we'll write and get coupon
and we will return
variable coupon
now as the class ends we'll write
semicolon
now let's try to run this code
there is some error
okay we haven't write s over here
now let's again try to run it
open
50
as i have told you
so here we have assigned 50 to
this function
and
the variable c is assigning
50 to the variable coupon
now after that we have used getcoupon
function to return the value of coupon
and that is why it is getting displayed
over here so
we got our answer that is coupon 50.
and as you can see that in this example
we are not
allowed to access the variable coupon
but still somehow we have managed to do
that with the help of some functions
so this is an example of abstraction
and
it helps to increase the security of the
program
so
this these were some basic examples of
oops in c plus plus
in order to understand it better we must
practice some more examples on it
today we will learn about c plus
inheritance so without further ado let's
get started so in this session we will
learn about what is c plus plus
inheritance why do we use inheritance in
c plus plus then we will understand
different modes of inheritance and after
that we will learn about types of
inheritance that is single inheritance
multiple inheritance multi-level
inheritance and hybrid inheritance in c
plus but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update so
what is inheritance in c plus plus just
like a child inherits the behavior and
characteristics from his or her parents
similarly inheritance in c plus is a
process in which the derived class
acquires all the properties and
characteristics
from the parent class that is the base
class
derived class is also known as child
class and base class is also known as
parent class
inheritance is one of the most important
feature of c plus plus oops that is
object oriented programming in
inheritance there are two types of
classes the class which inherits the
properties and behavior from the base
class is known as derived class and the
class whose properties or
characteristics are inherited is called
a base class
now let's understand why we use
inheritance in c plus plus inheritance
is used in c plus plus because it
increases the reusability of the code
and it helps in removing the redundancy
to understand it let's suppose there are
two classes two wheeler and four wheeler
both of the classes contain similar
functions like color brand and mileage
now if we create these classes we have
to create all the three functions in
both of the classes or in other words we
have to write the same code two times in
both of the classes so instead of
writing that code again and again we can
use inheritance and create a parent
class named class cycle and both of the
two wheeler and the four variable
classes will be inherited from this
parent or base class now with
inheritance we have inherited both the
classes from one base class that is
class cycle now we no longer have to
write the code again and again and we
can simply write the functions once in
the base class as both of these classes
are inherited from the base class
vehicle so as we have understood about
inheritance in c plus plus and why we
use inheritance in c plus plus so now
let's go ahead and learn about modes of
inheritance there are three modes of
inheritance in c plus that is public
mode protected mode and private mode of
inheritance so let's start with the
public mode in this mode of inheritance
the public members of base class remains
public in derived class and same goes
for the protected members that means
inside the base class the class members
that are public will remain public in
the derived class and similarly
protected class members will remain
protected in derived class
now protected mode in the protected mode
the public and protected members of the
base class will become protected in the
derived class that means the class
members which are public or protected in
the base class will all become protected
in the derived class in the private mode
of inheritance protected and public
members of class will become private in
the derived class so now let's go ahead
to the types of inheritance so there are
various types of inheritance in c plus
plus that is single inheritance multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical inheritance and hybrid
inheritance so let's start with the
single inheritance in this type of
inheritance a single derived class is
inherited from the single base class it
allows the derived class to inherit
properties and behavior from the parent
class the derived class objects can
access the members of the base class but
the base class objects cannot access the
members of the derived class so now
let's have a look at the syntax as we
know this is single inheritance so there
will be only a single derived class and
a single base class and this is how we
derive a child class from a parent class
class keyword then the name of the
derived class then the colon operator
after that there is an access modifier
with the base class now as we have
understood about single inheritance and
its syntax now let's move on to multiple
inheritance multiple inheritance when a
class inherits from more than one base
class or multiple base classes then it
is known as multiple inheritance it
allows us to inherit properties and
characteristics from more than one base
class syntax for multiple inheritance is
class keyword with the name of derived
class then the colon operator and access
modifier with the name of the base class
separated with comma and the name of
another base class here we have shown
only two base classes but we can make
more than two base classes depending
upon our requirement now coming to
multi-level inheritance in this type of
inheritance the derived class is
inherited from another derived class
that means when a class extends a class
that further extends another class is
known as multi-level inheritance for
example if there are three classes a b c
and class c is inherited from class b
and class b is inherited from class a
then it can be called as a multi-level
inheritance syntax of multi-level
inheritance is as follows
base class 2 is derived from base class
1 and the derived class is derived from
base class 2. these base class 1 base
class 2 and derived class are just the
names not a syntax you can write
whichever name you want with the class
now let's learn about hierarchical
inheritance in this type of inheritance
more than one class is inherited from a
single base class that is there would be
a single base class and multiple derived
classes
which have the properties and features
same as that of the base class as we can
see in the figure and in the syntax the
derived class 1 is derived from base
class and similarly derived class 2 and
derived class 3 are also derived from
the base class so this was hierarchical
inheritance and our next type of
inheritance would be hybrid inheritance
the hybrid inheritance is the
combination of more than one type of
inheritance and it can be said that it
is a combination of multi-level and
hierarchical inheritance in the figure
we can see the base class 1 is the
parent class of derived class 1 and
derived class 1 is the parent class of
derived class 3 which makes it
multi-level inheritance but if you look
at it in this way that the base class 1
is the parent class of derived class 1
derived class 2 and derived class 3 then
it is hierarchical inheritance as
multiple classes are inherited from a
common base class so we can say it is a
combination of more than one type of
inheritance or a hybrid inheritance so
as we have understood about inheritance
in c plus plus so now let's go to its
practical aspect and do some examples on
our code editor that is vs code so this
is our visual studio code and now we
will do an example of inheritance we'll
start by doing the single inheritance
example in which we will make a parent
class and a child class and let's start
first of all we will create a file and
let's name this file as
let's name it inherit dot cpp
so here we'll do an example in which you
will create two classes a base class and
a derived class
and we'll create functions in those
classes like we'll create one function
in base class and one function in
derived class and using the object of
derived class we will access the member
of
parent class or base class
so let's start first of all we'll
include the header files
hash include iostream
now the namespace standard using
namespace
std
now we'll create a base class first then
afterwards we'll create the main
function
all right so
let's create the base class
let's say the name of the base class or
the parent class would be
beverage
and inside this class let's make the
scope public and
now let's create a function
as we have said
drinks
so this is a function and we will print
something inside this function so let's
say we are printing
uh all rings are available
all drinks
are available
now we'll write endl now
we will use semicolon in the end of the
class so this is our base class and we
have created a function drinks and we
have printed a message all drinks are
available
all right now we will create another
class which is derived class or child
class
we will write
class
coffee is the
name of the derived class you use the
column operator public access specifier
and the name of
the base class that is beverage
all right now
we'll write public access specifier
inside this class and we will create a
function
in this class also like let's say the
name of the function would be mocha
it is a kind of a coffee so
and
we will print
that
mockart is good it is the best i would
say
okay
now
let's use the column operator in the end
of the class
so we here we have created the parent
class or base class and this derived
class of child class
so now we will create the main function
we will do the calling
so now we will create the object of
child class
so our child class is coffee
and
now we will create the object that is c
the name of the class and the object
okay now we will use the object with dot
operator and call this function that is
drinks
and now using the same object we will
call the
mocha the spelling is wrong yeah now it
is right
so using the object of child class here
we are calling the drinks function which
is of the parent class
so
let's see if it works or not
let's save it and now run it
as you can see all drinks are available
and mocha taste the best
both of these are getting printed that
means the
object of child class is able to access
the member of the parent class
so this is inheritance when the child
class acquires or inherits the behavior
or characteristics from a parent class
or access the members of the parent
class
this is an example of single inheritance
so now let's do another example of
multiple inheritance
so let's create a new file
and name it as inherit two dot cpp all
right now here we'll do an example of
multiple inheritance in which we will
create two base classes and a derived
class as we know that in multiple
inheritance there are more than one base
classes to a single derived class
so let's start first of all we'll
include the header file
now we'll use the namespace standard
and now we will create a class that is
the base class
and we'll name it as party
so class party inside this base class we
will first of all declare the public
scope and now we will declare a variable
let's say meals
so now we will create a function and in
this function we will take the input
from the user about the number of meals
to enter the number of mails
so
let's start void
food this is the function name and
first of all we'll display the message
saying that
enter
number of meals
all right now we will take the input
and meals
is the variable
now we will use the semicolon at the end
of this class
so in this
function we are taking the input of the
number of meals now in this in the other
class that is another base class we will
take the input of number of drinks from
the users
and then in the derived class we figure
out the total bill of the party
all right now
we'll create another base class that is
drinks
not drinks
drinks
all right
now
we'll write the public scope
and similarly we'll create
or declare another variable drink
and
then now we will create a function let's
say the name of the function is
liquor
right now inside this function we will
take the input from the user regarding
the number of drinks
so
we'll display the message
enter
the number of drinks
so
the user will enter the total number of
drinks used in the party or consumed in
the party similarly goes for the meals
now we will take the
input
and we'll write
drink
drink all right
now we have created this liquor function
now we will use the semicolon at the end
of the class here we have created both
the base classes that is class party and
class strings
now we have to create the derived class
so this is example of multiple
inheritance so
we will create
the derived class
and use the
column operator now we will write the
public specifier and the name of the
base class first base class would be
party
separated with comma the second base
class would be
drinks
all right so this is how we can do that
now inside this class we will first of
all create three variables
let's say
hint
total
meals
in
total
drinks
and int
total bill because in the end we have to
find out the total bill
all right
now
inside the public scope
we will create a function
name as total now inside this total
function we will write the logic to
calculate the total bill
so what we'll do is first of all write
the total meal
total meals
equals
meals
into the price of a single meal let's
say the price of a single meal is 90.
so the total product would be stored in
total meals
all right now
we will do
same for total drinks
total drinks not frank's equals
drink
into
let's say the price of a single drink is
60.
yes all right
now after that we have to compute or
calculate the total bill
total bill would be
the addition of both of these total
meals plus total rates so we'll simply
do the addition over here
total drinks
so once it's calculated we'll simply
display a message saying that the total
bill for the party
total
bill for the party is
and we'll write the variable that is
total bill
where the total
bill is actually getting stored all
right after this we will use the
semicolon so this is the derived class
here we have calculated the total money
spent in the party
so now we have to write the main
function where it all started
inside the main function
first of all we will create the
object of child class so we know that
our child class or the derived class is
bill
so bill is the derived class and b would
be the object so using this b we will
first of all call a function
that is
food function
so by calling this we will take the
input of number of meals now we will
call another function named liquor
all right using this function calling
this function will take the number of
drinks from the user
now we will call
this total function so this will
calculate the total money spent in the
party
and after that let's say return zero
we are calling all of these functions
using the object of derived class and
this is where multiple inheritance is
going on so let's see whether it works
or not we will save it and we'll try to
run this
enter number of meals as you can see
enter number of meals let's say the
number of meals would be 20 it was a
short party then enter number of drinks
17 would be so our total bill for the
party is 3270 which is the correct
answer so this is how we can do multiple
inheritance and this is a fine example
of multiple inheritance
now let's do another example so let's
name this one as
inherit
three dot cpp
all right so here we will do an example
of multi-level inheritance and we know
that in multi-level inheritance a single
derived class is inherited from another
derived class
or in other words we can say a class
extends a class which further extends
another class then it is called a
multi-level inheritance as the name
suggests
so
we will do example of that in this
example we will calculate the marks of a
student scored by him in three subjects
we will calculate the total marks scored
by him
using multi-level inheritance so let's
do this
so first of all we will
include the header file hash include i
string then we will write the name space
standard
now we will create the class
base class
chemistry
all right in this class
first of all we will
make the public scope
and
marks one so here we will take the input
of marks code by
that particular child in this chemistry
subject so we'll create the chemistry
function white chemistry this is of same
name as that of class so let's take
mystery marks
all right now
we will display the marks code in
chemistry
enter the marks
scored in chemistry
spelling is wrong okay now we'll take
the input marks one so the student will
enter the marks after that
let's put semicolon in the end now we'll
create another class
named physics
which is inherited from chemistry class
that is chemistry class is its base
class
chemistry
all right so
in this class
we will do the same public
int
marks2 print marks two
now we'll write void
physics marks
we'll do the same as we have done in the
previous class
so now we will
display a message saying that
enter the marks
scored in
physics
all right
now we will take the input c in
marks two all right so now we will put
semicolon in the end of this class as
well
so now we know that this physics class
is is inherited from this chemistry
class that is the mystery class is the
base class of physics class
now
we'll do
same for maths like class
maths
which is in
inherited
from the
physics class
we will write physics
inside this class as well we'll do the
same and as you can see this physics
class is the base class of maths and the
base class of physics class is chemistry
so this is a multi-level inheritance
so in this class we'll do the same
public scope and now after public scope
hint marks 3 is the variable we have
declared
and we will declare another variable in
this one like total because we have to
find out the total marks
now
function
maths
marks
inside this one we will display the
message
that enter
the marks yeah enter
the
marks scored in
maths all right now we'll take the input
marks three and we'll write the
semicolon in the end
so here we have created all of these
three classes which is of multi-level
inheritance as you can see
we have taken the input from the
user of his maths physics and chemistry
marks now
we'll do the total so
we have to do the total inside this
class only so the name would be
result function so
the total
func variable that we have declared
is equal to marks one
marks two plus
marks three so physics commission match
marks we will add all of them
and then we will display the total
all right
now this is done now we have to go to
the main function
now first of all we will create the
object of child class maths
once this object is created now we can
call the functions
as it can access
the base classes
so
chemistry marks first of all
then
m dot physics
marks
m dot maths marks
and then the total that is result result
function m dot result
then we'll write return 0
so
return 0. so here first of all mdot
chemistry marks will call this function
in the chemistry class so the user will
enter the marks code by him in chemistry
then this will call physics marks so the
user will enter the marks code by him in
physics subject then similarly we will
match marks they will enter the marks of
max then we will call the result
function we will do the total of all the
marks scored by the student we will do
the total and then we will display that
total so pretty much it's done now we
can save it and now let's try to run
this one there are some errors all right
that's a silly one
by mistake we have done this
all right now let's save it and run it
again hope it works now
yeah another error
marks
now let's try again now it's working
fine enter the marks code in chemistry
let's say 80
physics
80
on max's week let's say
75
235 which is the right answer 80 plus 80
plus 75 is equal to 235 and using the
object of child class we have called the
functions of all of these base classes
like we have called this chemistry marks
function and this physics marks function
which is of base class and this was a
fine example of multi-level inheritance
and this is how we can
do multi-level inheritance so these were
some examples of c plus plus inheritance
you can try some more examples on it and
these were some decent examples to
understand
it better you can start with some basic
level examples then go to the
intermediate level
hey everyone welcome back to another
video session by simply learn
in this session we will learn about c
plus polymorphism
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so we'll start with what is polymorphism
in c plus plus then types of
polymorphism in c plus that is compile
time and time
we'll also study function overloading
and operator overloading under compile
time polymorphism
and under runtime polymorphism we will
learn about
function overriding and virtual function
in c plus
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and press the
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn
so what is polymorphism in c plus
polymorphism is an important topic of c
plus plus oops concept
the word polymorphism is derived from
two words that is poly which means many
and morphs which means forms so
basically it means many forms
polymorphism in c plus can be defined as
when the member function or the object
behaves differently in different
situations or circumstances
then it can be called as polymorphism
for example
a mother has different relationships
with different family members inside the
house for example she is a parent to her
child
she is a wife to her husband she is a
sister to her brother and she is also a
daughter to her parents
so we can say a mother as a single
entity has different behavior among
different members
and same goes for polymorphism where
functions behave differently in
different situations
now
let's understand the types of
polymorphism
there are two types of polymorphism in c
plus plus that is compile time
polymorphism and runtime polymorphism
so let's start with compile time
polymorphism
as the name suggests
this type of polymorphism occurs during
the compile time and it is achieved by
overloading the function or overloading
the operator
that is by function overloading or
operator overloading
so what is this function overloading
function overloading is a feature in c
plus
where the functions having the same name
but different in terms of parameters or
type of parameters can be overloaded
for example
as we can see two functions with same
name func differ in the type of
arguments one data type is double
another data type is integer
so when we make a call to the function
with arguments of type double it will
invoke the suitable function and the
same goes for the other one
in example 2 there is a difference in
number of parameters
among functions
so while calling the function if we pass
two arguments it will invoke the first
function and if we will pass three
arguments then it will invoke the second
function
then
next is operator overloading
like functions operators can also be
overloaded
in operator overloading we can redefine
the functionality of the operator
it helps us in redefining the already
existing operator
for example
instead of writing sum equals
s1 dot add
s2 we can easily write
sum equals s1 plus s2
that is we can redefine the plus
operator and use it to add the numbers
in the operator function
and we will discuss the syntax of
operator overloading in the examples
now coming to runtime polymorphism
in this type of polymorphism the
functions are invoked during the
execution of program
that is during runtime
this runtime polymorphism can be
achieved through function overriding
so let's understand this function
overriding
in function overriding the function of
the base class gets a new definition in
the derived class
in this more than one function has the
same name and same type of parameters
the only difference is in the definition
of both the functions
that is functions have different
definitions in the parent class and the
child class
as you can see in the example
void message function has a different
definition in the parent class and in
the child class
both have the same name
but in parent class it is printing hello
there and in child class it is printing
nice to meet you
by using the object of the base class or
derived class we can invoke the suitable
function
so let's move on to our next topic that
is virtual function
virtual function is also used to achieve
runtime polymorphism
it is a function that is defined in the
base class and then is redefined in the
derived class
the function is defined using the word
virtual in the base class and the name
of the function is same as that of the
derived class having different
definitions as shown
it tells the compiler to perform the
late binding on the function in derived
class
the function call is resolved at runtime
and in late binding and the compiler
determines the object type at runtime
with the help of virtual function we can
invoke the derived version of the
function in the derived class
so as we have covered the theoretical
aspect of c plus plus polymorphism so
let's go ahead and cover the practical
aspect of this topic in our code editor
that is vs code if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so here we will make a new file
and let's name it as
poly1 dot cpp all right
poly1 dot cpp
let's save it so here we will do an
example of function overloading which is
used to achieve compile time
polymorphism and we know function
overloading is a feature in c plus plus
in which two functions have saved name
but differ in terms of parameters or
number of parameters or the type of
parameters can be overloaded so let's
start
first of all we'll write
the header file
hash include iostream
now using namespace standard
all right
so now we will create a class king and
inside that class we'll do the
overloading
so
the class name is king
and inside the class first of all
let's make public scope
now we'll create a function
return type is void
and the name of the function would be
pro
inside this function let's say we are
passing two arguments
into a and b
all right now we will print both of
these arguments
four variables inside this function
all right and we'll use ndl in the end
okay
after that we'll create another function
and the name of the function is same
that is pro
and but in this case we'll make the
arguments like int a
and b
and
into d
and int e
so there are five arguments in this
function second function pro
as we know that the name of the function
is same
and now inside this function we'll
simply add all of these
so a plus b plus c plus d
plus
e
all right once we are done with this we
will use semicolon in the end of the
class
all right now we will start with the
main function inside the main function
all right inside the main function
we will create the object of king class
king and the object would be k
with the help of this object k we will
call these
functions as we know the name of the
functions are same the only difference
is in the number of arguments
so
so i'll call the pro function
which accepts only two arguments
so the first pro
function
will be invoked
so i'll pass 10
and 20.
so these two arguments will be passed
over here
all right
similarly
now we'll call the pro function again
but
now we'll pass five arguments so that
the second pro function would be invoked
so let's say i'm passing
12
23
20
and 62
6.
these are some random numbers
all right now return 0
in the end
now let's try to run this i think we are
done with this first of all let's save
it and now let's right run this
so this is our output 10 20 let's make
it
let's multiply both of them
it will look good let's save it and run
it again
as you can see 200 and 123 so this is
our output 10 into 20 would become 200
and if we add all of these we'll get 123
so this is our correct output so this
was the example of functional
overloading and let's start with another
example
so now let's create a new file
and name this file as
only two dot cpp
all right we have saved it
now here we will do an example of
operator overloading as we know that in
operator overloading we give definition
to already existing operators
or we can say we can redefine the
functionality of already existing
operators
so let's start
first of all we'll include the header
files as we have done previously
hash include iostream
then the name space standard
so first of all we'll start with the
main function
and inside the main function
we will
write the name of the class that we will
create
and
the object let's say the name of the
object is o1
and
we'll pass
the arguments to the constructor
let's say the argument is 6 and 8
all right
then i think we can write return 0
and we'll do the rest
afterwards first of all we will
create the class
so as we know that the name of the class
is overload so let's create it
class
overload
and inside this class
inside the private scope
we'll start with
the variables let's say the first
variable is n1
and
let's declare another variable n2
then we will create the public scope
inside this we will create
the parameterized constructor
so
it is of same name as that of the class
that is overload
and now as the constructor is
parameterized
so into num1 and num2 are the parameters
so when we'll create this object oven
and we'll pass these arguments so it
will go here
and
all right inside this in the definition
of this constructor
we will create uh we will declare the
variable res
and we will assign
num to n1
will assign
num2 to n2
and let's say we'll do the subtraction
all right
n1 minus n2
all right now we will
display
the result that is res
so
res
and then the variable res
after that we'll use zendell
all right
so
once you're done with this parameterized
constructor then we will create a
operator function
so void is the return type
then we will write
operator keyword
this is the syntax of operator function
then after writing the keyword we'll
write the symbol let's say minus is the
symbol
then the arguments if there are any
arguments then we can put those
then inside the function that is in the
definition we can perform whatever the
functionality we want to perform
so let's say in this case we'll just
make the numbers negative
so we'll do that
all right
now we'll do the calling part of this
we will simply use the symbol and the
operator
and this is how we call the operator
function
this is very simple and after that we
have to display the
digits as well as we have made them
negative in this part
so
we'll
create a function display
and inside this function we will display
those
digits or numbers
so we'll write
n1
all right after this we'll write
we'll do same for n2
so we'll write n2
and 2 then
there is handle in the end
all right so here we are displaying this
so once we are done with this the class
is finished so we can use the semicolon
in the end
and we have to call this void function
as well so
we will write one dot display
one dot
display
all right we are done
let's see whether it works or not
let's save it
and check it
so as you can see the result is minus 2
that is 6 minus 8 equals minus 2
that is correct and n 1 is minus 6 and n
2 is minus 8 because we have made them
negative inside this operator function
we forgot to add some space in n 2 and n
1 so that is why it is looking like this
but the answer is correct
and this is how we can do the operator
overloading in this part we have use the
return type then the operator keyword
then the symbol and if there are any
arguments then we can pass those
arguments
and if there are not we can put it like
this
so this is our example of operator
overloading let's do another example so
now we'll do an example of function
overriding
so let's name this
poly3 dot cpp
so in function of writing the function
of base class gets a new definition in
the child class and when we call the
function of the child class using the
object of child class
then the function of base class gets
overridden
so now let's do the example of this
function overriding
i think we have named it wrong
poly3 dot cpp
all right
let's name it four
only four dot cpp all right now let's
save it
now
include the header files
using namespace standard
now
we'll start with the class parent
so this is
the base class
and we have named it parent
inside the parent class we will create a
function
for that will create the public scope
inside
inside the public school we will create
the function print
and
we will display the message
this is the function of parent class or
base class whatsoever
all right
so this is class parent and semicolon in
the end of the class
now we'll clear the child class
child
derived from
parent class
name of the class is parent
similarly we'll do the public scope and
create the function
void print
so it is same function as that of the
above class
and
inside this function we will display
this is
the function of
child class
derived class let's say
all right once we are done with this
semicolon in the end and semicolon in
the end of the class as well
then we can create a main function
and inside the main function
we will create the
object of child class
child obj
so as we have created the object of
child class or derived class so with the
help of this we will override the
function of the base class
so we'll write obj
dot
print which is the name of the function
so as we have created the object of
child class so it will call the
derived class or child class function
and in the end let's say return 0
now save it
and try to run this
this is the function of derived class
so as we have expected so it is calling
the child class function
so this function of the parent class
gets overwritten as we have used the
object of child class and call this
function print which is of same name
so
this function which is in the child
class gets to print
derived class
so this is our output
so now let's do an example of virtual
function in c plus
virtual functions are defined in the
base class to ensure that
the functions gets overwritten
and
when we use the base class pointer to
hold the derived class object or the
child class object the base class
pointer will always call the base
version of the function and not the
derived version
so to solve this problem we use the
virtual keyword in z plus plus so now
let's start with it
first of all we'll write hash include
iostream
now the namespace standard
now we will create the base class class
base
and then we'll use the public scope
inside the public scope we will create
the virtual
function
use the
virtual
the return type
then the name of the function that is
print
and we have created this virtual
function inside the base class now we'll
print
this is the function inside the base
class as we have done previously in the
previous question
this function
this is the functional base class here
it could be right
all right once we're done with this
we'll close the class by using semicolon
now we'll create the derived class and
we'll name it derived
from the base class whose name is base
itself
now
here we will use the public scope
and we will create the function
of the right class
print
function and will print
this is the function of derived class
all right
now we'll use the semicolon
to end the class
now inside the int function int main
function
first of all we will create the pointer
of base class
base
d reference operator b
so we have created the pointer of base
class now we will create the object of
derived class
derived d
so now we will store the address of
derived class object to the pointer of
base class
so let's do that
b which is a pointer of base class
address of operator
the object of derived class
so now we will call the print function
using the pointer of base class and it
will print the derived class function
because
the pointer of base class which we are
using to call the functions points to
the derived class object
so now let's do the calling part
all we need to do is
the pointer and the arrow operator
and the name of the function
that is print
after that we can write return 0
now everything is done let's save this
and
run it
as we can see this is the function of
derived class here we can see
so the derived class function is getting
called which we wanted
so this is an example of virtual
function in c plus
we have used this virtual keyword over
here and using the
base class pointer we have code this
function
and
and these were some examples of
different topics in polymorphism in c
plus plus you can try some more examples
on these topics it will help you in
understanding this topic in a better way
in today's session we will learn about c
plus operator overloading so without
further ado let's get started
so we will be covering today what is
operator overloading then we will
discuss non-overloadable operators after
that we will learn types of operator
overloading in c plus plus that is unary
operator overloading and binary operator
overloading
so first is what is operator overloading
operator overloading is a special case
of polymorphism in which the operator is
overloaded to provide special meaning to
the user defined data type
basically it adds some features or
redefines the functionality of already
existing operators
for example let us suppose we have three
objects of same class namely a b c
and c equals a minus b
now here we can redefine how minus
operator works and we can write c equals
a minus b instead of writing c equals to
a dot subtract b
and this is the general syntax of
operator overloading
first is the return type of the function
after that operator is the keyword then
symbol is the operator we want to
overload
then the arguments are those which are
passed to the function
now let's move on to the non
overloadable operators
there are some operators in c plus that
cannot be overloaded because it is not
syntactically possible to overload them
first is the dot operator the next is
scope resolution operator and third is
pointer to member operator and at last
we have ternary operator
coming to the next topic that is types
of operator overloading in c plus
so there are two types of operator
overloading that is unary operator
overloading and binary operator
overloading
first is unary operator overloading
it is defined as an operator which
contains only one operand or works on
only one operand
increment operator and decrement
operator are examples of it
there are two ways to do operator
overloading that is from the class
function and the friend function
its syntax using class function is the
return type operator keyword then the
symbol and the brackets but if we are
doing postfix in the function then we
have to write the data type inside the
brackets
syntax using friend function is
friend keyword return type then operator
keyword after that symbol
and in case of friend function we have
to pass an argument
next is binary operator overloading
an operator which contains two operands
or works with two operands is called
binary operator overloading addition
subtraction multiplication are examples
of binary operator overloading
syntax using class function is return
type then operator keyword then the
symbol and then we have to pass an
argument inside the brackets
and syntax using friend function is
friend keyword then the return type
after that operator keyword and then the
symbol and in case of friend function we
can pass two arguments
now we will do one example of unity
operator overloading in which we will
increment the value of the variable with
the help of operator overloading
so now let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code
so here first of all we'll make a new
file
and name that file as
operator
dot cpp
now first of all we write the header
files hash include
iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
now we'll start with int main
and inside intmin first of all we'll
write the name of the class that is
increase
and its object inc
now we will call the void operator
increment function
so we will write
plus
plus
i and c
here when we write plus plus i and c
then function void operator plus plus
will be called
which we will make later
so as of now first of all we
write i and c dot display in order to
display the output
we are calling the display function over
here
now after that we'll write return 0.
now we'll make the class
so we'll write
class
increase which is the name of the class
now we'll use the access specifier
private
and we'll write the variable
int
value
now we'll write another access specifier
public
and now we will make the constructor
because we have created the object inc
so that is why a constructor is called
and we are making it
increase
and inside the constructor we have given
the value
10 to the variable
now
plus plus inc is calling the void
operator plus plus function so we'll
write that function
void
operator
increment
which is the symbol
now
value equals
value plus five because we are
incrementing the variable with five so
we'll write value equals value plus five
now after that we have to display the
value variable so we will write
void
display
because we have already called over here
inc dot display
so now we will write inside
c out
we'll write the message value
is
now the variable value
and end
after the class we have to use the
semicolon now let's try to run this
here
is our output value is 15.
previously the value was 10 then on
increment its value gets 15 which is the
right output
so
here first of all we have created an
object and constructor is called and
inside the constructor we have
initialized value with 10.
then with the help of object inc that is
when we are using plus plus inc then we
are calling the void operator function
which is increasing the value of the
variable by 5 and then we are displaying
it with the help of display function
and one more thing guys in case of
postfix that is in case of inc plus we
have to write the data type inside the
void operator function
that is over here
now let's do another example for binary
operator overloading
so let's name this
operator
2 dot cpp
now here we will do one example of
binary operator overloading in which we
will add two complex
numbers so let's start
first of all
let's make the header files
hash include iostream
now using namespace standard
now we'll write int main
okay now first of all we will write the
name of the class that is complex
so we'll write
complex
and then
the objects like com1
com2
res
we have created three object
now we will write a message
because we have to take the input from
the user so first of all we'll write a
message
enter first complex number
because we have to add two complex
numbers
so first of all we'll
take the input of the first one
that is
slashing
okay now
we have to
write com1 dot input input is the name
of the function
which we will be creating afterwards
then
c out
enter second complex number
that is
now we'll write slash n
okay
now after this we have to write the
semicolon and we'll write
com2
dot input
these input function will take the input
of complex numbers from the user we will
declare them later we will make them
later
okay now
we will now here we will do an operation
with the help of plus operator function
so we will write
res equals
com1
plus com2
this function call from com1 will go to
the complex of operator plus function
and com2 will be passed to the argument
obj
and the result will be stored in
variable res
okay now we will
call another function output
in order to display the output
res dot output after that we'll write
return 0
now we will make the class complex
we'll write
class
complex
we'll write the access specifier private
and the variables int real
and int
imag that is imaginary because we know
in complex number there is a real part
and imaginary part
okay now we'll write public access
specifier
and now we will write the
function input
in order to take the input from the user
void input
now first of all we have to display a
message
we will write enter real in imaginary
parts respectively
okay
okay
now we will write
c in because we have to take the input
and the variable name real
and imaginary
now we will write the overloading
function we will write the return type
that is the complex
then operator keyword
then symbol
then
argument
complex
obj
okay now
we will write
complex
temp
so here we have created the data type
temp of complex class
we'll make it a capital c
okay now we will write
temp dot real equals to
real plus obj dot real so we'll write
temp
dot
real
equals to
real plus
obj
dot real
the plus operator over here will add the
real part of the number to the real part
of another number
and similarly we will do it for the
imaginary part
write temp
dot
imaginary
equals
imaginary plus
dot
imaginary
and
and then the value of the variable temp
is returned so we'll write
return
temp
the value was stored in temp so that is
why we have returned temp
now we will make the output function
we'll write
wide
output
right output is
variable real
then
we'll write plus
then imaginary
and then
i because this is the syntax for
complex number
okay
now we have to put the semicolon over
here
as the value of temp is returned
now the result is stored in variable
dress
and then we will print the output using
the output function this is the output
function
and
the value is stored in dress and then we
are printing the output using the output
function
com1 over here is getting passed to the
complex of operator plus function and
com2 is getting passed to the argument
obj
and the result is getting stored in res
now let's try to run this code
the first complex number let's say
2
plus 2 iota so we will write 2 and 2
and then enter second complex number
that is enter real and imaginary parts
respectively now we have to write the
real and imaginary parts of the second
complex number so we'll write
4
plus
6 iota
so the output is
6 plus 8 iota 2 plus 4 equals 6 and 2
plus 6 equals to 8 so this is our
correct output we are basically adding
two complex numbers with the help of
binary operator overloading
so this is how it is done
so these were some important examples of
operator overloading you can try some
more examples on it in order to practice
them well hey everyone welcome back to
another video by simply learn in this
session we will learn about
encapsulation in c plus plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so we'll start by understanding what is
encapsulation in c plus plus why do we
need encapsulation in c plus plus then
we will learn about access modifiers
after that we will understand the
benefits of encapsulation and also the
difference between encapsulation and
abstraction so let's start with
encapsulation in c plus
encapsulation is a very important
concept of object oriented programming
it can be defined as wrapping up of data
and functions together into a single
unit
just like a capsule the data members and
functions are wrapped together
wrapping them into a single unit helps
in keeping them secure from the outside
access
for example inside a class the variables
and functions are declared and then bind
together with the help of class
which also implements encapsulation
next is
why do we need encapsulation
hiding the details or attributes is also
an important thing that one should focus
on
encapsulation helps with that part
it keeps the details of the object
hidden or saved from the users by
securing them from the outside access
there are many implementation details
that the users are not supposed to see
so these details like the details of the
object are kept secure from the direct
access from outside the class with the
help of encapsulation
the data hiding is done with the help of
access modifiers
so let's understand these access
modifiers
the access modifiers helps in data
hiding part
the access modifiers provides or grant
the access to the members of the class
or it prevents them from the direct
access to the class members from outside
the class
so there are generally three types of
access modifiers that is public private
and protected
so let's understand them
in public access modifier other classes
and function can access the data members
and member functions of the public class
for example park is a public property
anybody can go to the park or access the
park because it's a public
nobody has to take the alliance of
anybody to go to the park
now coming to the private
in private access modifiers only the
member functions inside the class have
the access to the class members
functions outside the class cannot
access them
for example a house is a private
property
any member outside the family
cannot access the house without
permission
only members inside the family can
access it because it's a private
property
now let's understand protected
in protected access modifier
similar to private scope it cannot be
accessed from the outside class
but it can be accessed from the derived
class
the derived class is also called the
child class
also the protected member of a class can
be accessed from the friend function
so as we have understood about these
access modifiers
now let's understand the benefits of
encapsulation
encapsulation helps in reducing the
complexity of code by hiding the
irrelevant data or information and by
doing so it reduces the complexity
second is encapsulation helps in hiding
and protecting the data by wrapping the
data and function together which are
generally complex and by doing so
provides a simpler view to the user
with the help of encapsulation the
variables of the class can be hidden
from other classes
third is encapsulated classes can easily
be altered using the access modifiers
that is we don't need to change the
entire program all we need to do is to
change the access scope of the variables
that can be private protected or public
so these were some benefits of
encapsulation now let's go ahead and
understand the difference between
encapsulation and abstraction
both of these concepts are similar in
some ways but now we will discuss their
differences
so let's start with encapsulation
encapsulation helps in combining the
data and functions together in a single
unit whereas in abstraction the unwanted
information is kept hidden
encapsulation helps in hiding the data
and helps in providing an easier view
abstraction helps in hiding the
implementation details
encapsulation can be implemented using
an access modifiers
whereas abstraction can be implemented
using abstract class and interfaces
in encapsulation
problems are solved at implementation
level
and in abstraction
problems are solved at design level
so these were some differences between
encapsulation and abstraction
let's go ahead and do some practical
examples on this topic
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so this is our code editor that is
visual studio code
and now let's create a new file
and let's name it
encapsulation
dot cpp
so first of all we know in encapsulation
we can make variables inaccessible by
making their scope as private
so in this example we will do that
will make the salary of an employee as
private and then using the saturn gather
methods we will set the value of salary
and return it as well
the setter getter methods are generally
used in these kind of situations where
the variable we want to access is
private
so now let's start
first of all we will create the main
function but before that let's add the
header files
now using namespace standard
now we'll start with the main function
and inside the main function first of
all we'll create an object by declaring
the
class name let's say the class name is
company
the object name is obj
now
using this object we will call the set
function or we can say the setter
function
we will name it as set
salary let's say
and we will pass
two values
thirty thousand and six thousand
one would be
the full time salary and one would be
the overtime
all right now after that we can display
those
and we can write total salary
and
and
after that we can call the get function
to return the salary
as the getter function is used to return
the output and set function is used to
set the values so we'll write
obj.get
salary
so the salary we will display over here
and after that we can write the return
0.
now the main function is done now let's
start
with company class company
class company
and inside this class first of all
inside the private scope
this is the private scope and this is
the
variable salary
now this variable salary is private so
no member outside the class can access
it
but using the setter and getter methods
we will access this variable and we will
set the
salary and then we will return it
all right
now
public scope inside the public scope
we will
write the setter methods void
set
salary
and
end full time
and
over time
so these are two variables
this 30 000 that we are passing is a
full-time salary and this 6000 is an
overtime salary
so we need to add both of these salaries
in this part
so we'll write salary equals
full time
plus
over time
so this would be the total salary
and
let's just do this
all right
so this set
salary function is done this is the
setup function
now we have to return
using the getter function so we'll write
the data type end
get
salary
now inside this function
we will simply return the variable
salary
as we can see
and
once the class
will use this semicolon
all right pretty much everything is done
and now we can save it
and let's try
as you can see total salary is 36 000 as
30 000 plus 6000
so it is working fine so this is how we
can access these private variables using
these saturn getter methods
now let's do another example
this example of encapsulation will also
be pretty much the same we'll do the
setter getter methods in this one as
well but in this example we'll find the
area of circle
all right let's start then first of all
we'll include the header files that is
hash include iostream
and the name space standard
we also forgot to save this
let's name this one as
first of all the location is work
now let's name it as
encapsulation
2.cpp
all right
now the header files that i did now
we'll start with the main function first
of all
now inside this main function we'll
create an object first of all we'll
write the name of the class
that is ball
now the name of the object is obj
now using this obj object we will call
the setter function
that is the set area function and we
will pass the radius
all right
obj
dot set
area this is the setup function
now we will pass the
radius
now now we can display the area by
calling that getter function but before
that we will display a message
i'll write
area of
ball is
all right
now
we will call that getter function
get area
all right the main function is done now
we need to create the class
class bowl inside this class
private scope inside the private scope
we'll
create that variable
area and let's make its data type as
float because we know that there are
chances that the answer could be
in decimal form because we have to use
pi in that because the area of circle is
pi r square so 3.14 is the value so that
is why we are using
float as the data type
all right now
in the public scope
we'll
set
the radius inside this function
set area and
in radius this is the radius that is
6 that we are passing this is the r this
is the parameter
and
inside this function area equals we know
that pi r square is the formula so we
will write 3.14 that is the value of pi
into
radius
again into radius
r square
all right so this is the
area of
circle or ball we can say
after that
float is the data type now we have to
return the area using the getter
function
float getter
its
name is get area
get area
and will simply return the
area
variable
all right after that we can use
semicolon in the end
and pretty much everything is done
so let's save it
and let's check it
if it is running fine or not
as you can see area of ball is 113.04
so if we multiply 3.14 that is the value
of pi
with
36 that is 6 into 6 it will give you
113.04
so this is the right answer and this is
how we can find the
area of ball or something like that
and as you can see here the area is
private and using this set area and get
area methods that is the saturn getter
methods we are accessing this private
variable that is area
so these were two examples of
encapsulation you can try these examples
as well
hello everyone welcome back to another
video by simply learn
in this session we will discuss an
interesting topic that is exception
handling in c plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we will be covering today
so we will start with what are
exceptions
then why do we need exception handling
in c plus
and what
exception handling is
then we will understand exception
handling keywords that is try catch and
throw
and we will understand each keyword in
detail
so first we will start with what are
exceptions
exceptions are the unexpected events or
the situations that arise during the
smooth execution of the program
so there are times during the run time
when some errors or situations arises
which create issues in the program
these issues are called exceptions
for example let us suppose we want to
divide two numbers one is seven and
other one is zero
now if we divide seven with zero it will
show an error because we cannot divide
any number by zero because it is
undefined
so exception handling provides a way to
take care of problems like these
so now let's learn about exception
handling but before that we must
understand why we need exception
handling
so why do we need exception handling in
c plus
one of its reason includes handling the
exceptions that arise during the
execution of the program
along with that exception handling
provides a mechanism through which we
can handle the error generating part
separately from the rest of the code
exception handling provides information
to the user about the problem so that he
or she can detect the mistake and
correct it
now let's go ahead and understand what
exception handling is
as we have discussed exception handling
helps in dealing or handling the
exceptions that disrupts the flow of
execution of a program
so how does it deal with the exception
so when an exception is encountered it
transfers the control from one part of
the program to the other known as
handlers and makes the code more
readable and maintainable
and takes care of the exception by
providing certain code
these exceptions are handled with the
help of exception handling keywords
now let's understand these exceptional
handling keywords
so there are three exception handling
keywords named try catch and throw
as we can see in the example first there
is try block then followed by three
catch blocks
and each catch block contains the name
of the exception
the try block can have more than one
catch block
inside the try block those statements
are enclosed which may cause exception
or we can say in this block that
particular code is kept which will throw
the exception
each try block is followed by one or
more than one catch block
the try block throws an exception which
is caught by the catch block
taking care or handling the exception is
the actual job of catch block
this block catches the exception thrown
from the try block
inside the catch block a message or some
code is written to handle the exception
it can be a message for the user or a
default code for a particular condition
both the try block and catch block work
together and every try block has at
least one catch block for it
now next is throw keyword
whenever an exception is encountered it
helps in throwing the exception
it is used to throw an exception and its
value to the consecutive exception
handler
so as we have discussed this topic
theoretically now let's go ahead and do
its practical implementation in our code
editor that is vs code
so this is our code editor here we will
do an example in which
we will make sure a person who is less
than 24 years of age
is not allowed to drink in the club
so we will create an exception that part
and with the help of try catch and throw
blocks we will handle those exceptions
all right so first of all we'll create a
new file
and let's name it
as
exception
one dot cpp
all right now we'll start with the
header files that is hash include
iostream
now the name space standard
now we'll start with the main function
and inside the main function first of
all we will declare
a variable named age
so
right int age
equals to let's assign it as 20
so this person is 20 years of age and
now we will create the try block
so inside this try block
we'll write an if condition that is if
the age of the person
is greater than equal to 24
then only he is allowed to drink
so inside this we will
print a message saying that
you have
the excess to drink the alcohol
all right
so after this
inside the else block
all we need to do is to throw
and the exception that is if the age of
the person is not greater than 24 that
is age is less than 24
so in that condition
or in that situation we will throw the
exception
that is will throw age
to the catch block
and for that we have to create the catch
block
so the catch block
will
catch the exception that is age as you
can see
now inside this catch block
first of all we will write a message
we'll write
we will write you don't have the access
to drink alcohol
you don't have
because your age
is less than 24
all right
so after this after this message
we will print the age of the person
so we'll write
your is
so and so
and then
the variable h
now after that we'll write return zero
so in this example as you can see the
person age is 20 as we have assigned and
inside the try block we have set a
condition that if the age of person is
greater than 24
greater than equal to 24
then he or she have the access to drink
the alcohol
and if not
if his or her age is not
greater than 24
then we'll throw the exception
and the cash block with cashed exception
and will print this message that you
don't have the access to drink alcohol
because your rage is less than 24
and then
his age will be printed
so now let's try to run this i hope it
works
as you can see you don't have the access
to drink alcohol because your age is
less than 24 and your age is 20
and now let's try to if we assign
let's say 25
the program is working fine but we want
to check the other condition as well
okay so it is happening because we
forgot to save this 25
as we have now saved it now let's try to
run this
as you can see you have the access to
drink alcohol because now our age is 25
so this is how
exception handling works this try block
inside this drive lock we kept those
code or statements which will throw the
exception
and then
it is thrown with the help of this throw
keyword and then the catch block solves
or prints a message
in with respect to that exception
so now let's do another example
so
let's create a new file
and name it let's say
exception
2 dot
cpp
all right so here we will do an example
in which we will try to divide a number
by zero
and as we know that we cannot divide a
number by zero so it will throw an
exception
so let's do this example
so first of all
our hash include iostream the header
file
then the namespace standard
now inside the main function
we will create three variables
mean
so inside the main function we will
create three variables
one is for the numerator
then denominator and then in which we
will store the output that is the output
variable so let's name numerator as num
and denominator as d num
because it is sounding familiar then
we will store the output in the output
variable
all right
so we have created three variables num
denum and output
now
first of all here we will display a
message to enter the numerator and
denominators
so we'll write
please enter
the numbers
to do the division
all right
after that end l
now we'll take the input
c in num and
c in
d num
so the numerator and denominator we have
taken the input from the user
now after that we'll make the try block
so inside this try block
we will create an if condition
and we'll write if dnum that is the
denominator
is equal to 0 if it is equal to 0
then
we will throw the exception
and
the exception would be denum
because denominator cannot be zero
and
if the dname is not zero then in else
condition we will simply
divide
output equals to
num
divided by d num
all right
so now after this we have to create the
catch block also
because we have thrown the exception now
we want the catch to catch the exception
so
we can write
d for dinum here
now
we'll print a message saying that you
cannot enter 0 in the denominator
so we'll write
you cannot
enter
0 in denominator
while
doing
the division
operation
all right now after that we'll use endl
so this is our catch block
after this catch block we will again
write a message
that the output of the division is that
is
if
the denominator is not 0 then we have to
print that result so for that we will
do
this
the output
after
the division is
and here we
will write the variable output
so this
will print the result of
this one where the denominator is not
zero
so
after that we can write return 0
so there is one extra bracket as you can
see
of try block
all right now it's done we can save this
one and let's try to run this
but before running this one let's go
through this code that first of all we
have declared these three variables then
we ask the user to enter the numerator
and denominator
so then we have used this try block and
inside the try block we have set the
condition that if denominator is 0 then
we will throw the exception
and if it is not then we'll simply
divide both of the numerator and
denominator
so the
denominator which is thrown is called by
this catch block
this and it will display a message that
you cannot enter 0 in the denominator
while doing the division operation
because it is undefined
and if the denominator is not 0 then it
will simply print the message
and the output
so now let's try to run this
so as you can see please enter the
numbers to do the division
so let's say the first number is 8
and second number is
0 that is denominator is zero
then you cannot enter zero in the
denominator while doing the division
operation the output after division is
zero
so it will show this output only and
our output is correct now let's try to
run this and do the simple division
operation in which the denominator is
not zero
so let's say now again we'll write eight
and the denominator would be two
then as we can see the output after the
division is 4
so
our
code is correct and our output is also
correct so this is how
we can do the exception handling and
handle the exceptions using this try
catch and throw blocks
welcome to this tutorial on c plus plus
vectors so let's jump in and see what's
in it for us
so we will be covering today why we use
vectors in c plus plus what is a vector
in c plus plus and its syntax then we
will go through the member functions of
vectors like modifiers iterators
capacity and we will understand each of
their functions also so first is why we
use vectors in c plus
vectors are used when we are not sure
about the size of data
like in case of arrays we have to guess
the size of the data first because it is
not possible to resize it later
but in case of vectors we don't have to
set the size of vector and it is
resizable that is why it is more
preferable for dynamic elements
and it also has some inbuilt functions
like pushback size empty etc which helps
in dealing with data values
now let's understand what is a vector
vectors are array-like containers that
is used to store data and the data is
stored in contiguous storage locations
but unlike arrays its size can be
changed automatically depending on the
number of elements and it is not
necessary to mention the size of vector
while declaring it
now
let's have a look at the syntax here
inside the angle brackets this is the
data type of the vector
it can be string end float etc and v2 v1
v3 are the names of the vectors
respectively
now let's understand the member
functions of vectors
a vector container has three types of
member functions that is modifiers
iterators and capacity
so let's understand these functions in
detail
first is modifiers
these are those functions that are used
to modify data elements
for example first is push back function
this function is used to add a new
element to the end of the vector
next is pop back
this function
deletes the last element of the vector
then there is insert function it is used
to insert a new element at a specified
position
in this function there are two
parameters first parameter specifies the
position and second specifies the value
after that erase function raise function
is used to remove the elements at a
certain position or to remove a range of
elements
either you can write the position of the
element you want to remove inside the
bracket or you can write starting
position and ending position of the
range of elements inside it next is swap
function
this function is used to swap the
contents or elements between two vectors
and if there are two vectors named v1
and v2
that we want to swap then its syntax
would be v1 dot swap v2
then there is a sine function this
function is used to assign values to the
vector
in this function there are two
parameters first one specifies number of
values to be assigned and second
represents the value that is to be
assigned
last is clear function this function is
used to remove all the elements from the
vector
now moving on to iterator functions
these are those functions that helps in
nitrating across the elements
first is begin function it basically
returns the iterator pointing to the
beginning of the vector
the next is and function
this function returns the iterator
pointing to the end of the vector
now coming to capacity functions
these functions that lie under capacity
are associated with size so first is
size function
this function returns the number of
elements in the vector
next is max size function this function
returns the maximum size that a vector
can hold
then there is the size function this
function changes the size of the
container
and inside the brackets a number n is
mentioned
if n is less than the size of container
then content is reduced by removing
extra elements
but if n is greater than the size of the
container then extra elements are added
at the end
so that it reaches the size of n
after that capacity function this
function returns the size that is
currently allocated to the vector
container
at last there is empty function
which checks whether the vector is empty
or not
if it returns true then it is empty and
if false then it is not empty
now to understand these vector functions
in a better way
let's do some examples of these vector
functions in our code editor that is vs
code
so first of all let's make a new file
and name this file
vector.cpp
now first of all we will write the
header file
that is
hash include
iostream
now we will write the header file
hash
include
vector
this is the header file for vector
because we are doing some examples on
vectors so that is why we have to use it
now
we'll write the namespace standard
using
namespace std
now we'll start with int main
now first of all we'll define the vector
so we'll write
vector
and inside the angle bracket we will
write int which is the data type
now the name of the vector
will write n
now first of all we will see the
functionality of assign function
as we know that assign basically puts
the value at positions
so we will write
and
dot
assign first of all
we will write the number of
values
like 9 is the number of values
after that in the second parameter we'll
write the value
here it means that we are putting 1 to 9
positions in the vector
that is we are assigning 1 to 9
positions
now in order to print this
first of all we will
display a message saying
the contents are
now in order to print these contents
basically we have to
write a for loop
we'll write int a equals zero
will initialize it from zero
then
a less than
and dot size
this is the size function it basically
returns the number of elements
now
a plus plus
will increment
we have to now print this
we have to write like an array
in order to print all the elements
we'll write
n
and inside the bracket a
now we'll leave some space
we'll write endl
we wrote endl over here in order to
insert a new line
now after that
we'll see the functionality of one
another function that is
pushback
and we know that pushback functions adds
an element at the end of the vector
so we will write n dot
pushback
and then the element which we want to
add like let us say 2
now
we have to display this last element
also
so in order to display this we will
store the size of vector in some
variable
and then we will print the last element
so we will write
int
and no
this is the variable name
then we will write and dot size
here we are storing the size of the
vector in some variable and no
now
we'll display
last element
we'll display the message saying last
element
and then we will
print the last element and as we know in
order to print the last element we have
to print
the n minus one element
so we will write
n bracket
and no minus one
here we are writing n bracket
and no minus 1
this will print the last element
after that we'll write end l
now after that
we will see another function that is pop
back it basically removes the last
element so we'll write n
pop underscore back
so this function will remove the last
element that we have added that is 2.
so we need to print this also so we'll
write
first of all we'll display a message
now the contents are
now we again write the for loop
as we have done previously
we'll write int a equals 0
a less than
and dot size
a plus plus
now we will again print
in the form of array
sorry
and
and inside the bracket we will write a
then in order to give some space we'll
write this
after this we'll write handle
to add one new line
so firstly we displayed the contents
then we added one element at the end
and then displayed that element after
that we have removed that element with
the help of pop-back function
as you have noticed that we are just
doing the functions of modifiers yet so
in this example we will cover some
functions of modifiers only then in the
next examples we will do for iterator
functions and then for the capacity
function
so now let's do the functionality of
insert function
as we know that insert function is used
to add an element at a specified
position
so we will write
n dot
insert
and dot begin
it will point to the first element
then
7
as we know that the first parameter
specifies position and the second
specifies the value
so n dot begin will point to the first
position and 7 is the value
so now we will
print it also
we'll write
first element
is
then we will write
display the first element
then we'll write endl
now we will use the function
clear
to remove all the elements we'll write n
dot c l e a r clear
and then in order to check
we will write n dot size so first of all
we'll write
now
the size is
and in order to check
whether it is whether all the elements
are removed or not
we'll write n dot size
it will display the size
the program is pretty long but let's
just hope it runs
here it is
now the contents are last element
let's have a look whether it is right or
not
one is displaying nine times then last
element we have added two
then we have removed that element
it is also correct then the first
element we have added using insert
seven is there
and after using clear function
now the size is zero so this is the
correct output
now after doing this function let's try
another example
now here we will do the example of
iterator functions in which first of all
we will add some elements inside the
vector and then we will print them using
iterators
so let's start
first of all name this
vectors
2
dot cpp
now first of all we'll write the header
file
hash include iostream
then
the header file for vectors hash include
vector
then we'll use namespace standard
now we'll start with int main
so here we will write vector
and inside the angle brackets we'll
write the data type that is int
and then the name of the vector that is
num
now
we will write the for loop and with the
help of for loop we'll add
the elements inside the vector one by
one
so we will write
for
int
i equals zero
i
less than
let's say 5
i plus plus
let's make it 1 over here
okay
now
after that
we'll push
these elements one by one inside the
vector
so we will write the function
pushback we'll write num dot
push back
and here i will write i
okay now
because we want to add the elements from
one to five so that is why we have to
use less than equal to because we want
to include five also
okay now
[Music]
we have to print these elements right so
we'll write
first of all we'll display
that output
from
the begin
beginning
to the end
okay
now
now we will write for loop and with the
help of iterators we will print the
elements of vector
so we'll write
auto this is the iterator and
a is the iterator name
then we'll write
num dot begin
as we know that begin function points to
the
first element of the vector so that is
why we have written num dot begin
now we will write
a
less than
sorry not equal to
num dot
end
then a plus plus
now after that we have written a naught
equal to num dot n
and we know that end function returns
the iterator to the end of the vector
and after that we have used increment
operator
so this loop will run from beginning
till it reaches to the end
and inside for loop we will write the d
reference operator with a so that each
element which is getting pointed by a
will display one by one with the help of
loop
so let's write
we'll write
c out
d reference operator a
and then we'll give some space
now let's try to run this
[Music]
this is the output output from the
beginning to end
one two three four five this is our
right output
this is the message which we want to
display and this is the output one two
three four five which we want to display
which we have added in the vector and
then we have displayed
so
now let's do
another example which includes the
capacity function
so
we'll make another file
vector3 dot cpp
so in this example we will add some
elements in the vector and then we will
apply some functions on it
so let's start
first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include iostream
then
the header file for vectors hash include
vector
then we will write the name space
standard
using name
space std
okay now we will write intermin
so first of all we'll write vector
and then the data type
and then the name of the vector let's
say v
now one by one we'll put some uh
elements inside the vector so we'll
write for loop
we'll start with int x equals 0
x
less than equal to 10
x plus plus
because we want to add these elements
so we will write v dot
push
back
and then we will write x inside the
brackets
semicolon
now here one by one all the elements
from
0 to 10 will be added let's make it 1
1 to 10
okay now
we will apply some functions on this
vector
so
let's first of all try out the size
function so first of all we'll write
vector
size
is
and then we'll write the function v dot
size
and then we'll write
and
so this function will tell us the size
of the vector because we have already
added the elements from 1 to 10 so
it will display 10
after that we will use the
try out
the capacity function
we'll
write capacity of vector is
and then we will write v dot
capacity
after that
here also we'll write endl
now
we will use the maximum size
or the max size so we'll write
maximum
size
of
vector
is
so in order to calculate the maximum
size we write v dot
max
underscore
size
and l
as we know that v dot size will give us
the size of the vector
and capacity function this function
returns the size that is currently
allocated to the vector container
and
max size
this function returns the maximum size
of the vector
so
all of these functions
result will be displayed because we have
wrote them inside c out
now
let's try another function
that is resize
now in order to resize the vector we'll
write v dot
resize and then
we'll write
the number that we want to resize it
with
like let's write 5
now in order to check this also we will
display
so we'll write
vector size
after resizing
resizing is
i forgot to put the commas
okay now we'll write
v dot size because now we want to find
the size after resizing
so we have written v dot size
now
after that
we will write n l
okay
now we'll try
the empty function
we'll put empty function inside if
now inside if we'll write v dot empty
equals equals false
it means
if the vector is not empty because we
have written v dot empty equal equal to
false not true we have written v dot
empty equal to equal to false that means
if it is not empty
then
we'll display
vector is not empty
and in else condition we will write
vector is empty
so here we will write
c out
back
again i forgot to put over here
okay
vector
is not empty
and in else condition
will write
vector is empty
so in this question first of all we have
added some elements inside a vector
then we have used v dot size function
then v dot capacity function then max
size function after that we have resized
the vector
and then check it for the size of it
after that we use v dot empty function
so now let's try to run this code
okay i think we have done something
wrong
we haven't put the brackets over here
okay now let's try again
here it is
vector size is 10
because we have put 1 to 10
then capacity of vector is 16 okay then
max size of vector is this
then vector size after resizing
because we have done we have wrote the
number 5 as we can see so that is why a
vector size after resizing is five
and vector is not empty as we know
because inside the vector there are five
elements so it is not empty which is
true
so
these were some examples of vectors in c
plus plus
you can try some more examples on it you
can practice some more examples
and in today's session we will learn
about c plus plus stl
in this session we will learn about what
is stl then we will understand the
components of stl like containers
iterators algorithms and function
objects
so without further delay let's get
started
stl stands for standard template library
it is a set of template classes that
provide us data structures and
algorithms or containers
it allows the programmer to use
predefined functions which helps them to
write the code quickly and in an
efficient way
for example you are solving a problem
that needs sorting now instead of
writing the code to sort you can make
use of stl
now stl mainly consists of four
components that is containers iterators
algorithms and function objects
so first is containers
these are collection of objects that
store data of similar type in stl we
have different types of containers some
of them are array vector set map and
these containers are generic in nature
so further these containers are of three
types that is sequence container
associative container and container
adapters
sequence containers these are those
containers that can be accessed
sequentially for example vector
dq list or some of the containers that
store data in a linear form
next is associative container
these are those containers that
implement sorted data structures in this
elements are retrieved via keys and each
associative container maintain its keys
in sorted order
example set multiset map and multi-map
after that container adapters these
containers are like sequential
containers but they are implemented by
modifying their interface to provide the
desired behavior for example stack queue
and priority queue are some examples of
container adapters
now coming to iterators in stl iterator
plays an important role as it links
algorithms and containers iterators are
those entities that helps in traversing
through containers
they are used to point at the memory
address of the stl containers
iterators also helps in traversal from
one element to the next element in the
range using operators like increment
operator
iterator contains two functions that is
begin function and and function the
begin function returns the iterator to
the first element and the and function
returns the iterator to the last element
now coming to algorithms
algorithms in stl can be defined as
procedure that are applied to the
container and provides some operations
on the content of the container
and because stl algorithms are built in
so that is why they save considerable
amount of time
in algorithms we just have to make a
function call and we don't have to write
the lines of code to implement it
now let's have a look at types of
algorithms
first is modifying algorithm non
modifying algorithm sorting algorithm
searching algorithm and numeric
algorithm
modifying algorithms are those
algorithms that make changes to the
sequences
swap and reverse functions are some
examples of it
then non-modifying algorithm
non-modifying algorithm are basically
read-only function they do not modify
the data on which they work on
some examples are count equal and search
functions
then sorting algorithms
this algorithm is used to sort the
container elements its example is sort
function
next is searching algorithm
as the name suggests this algorithm
searches for the element binary search
algorithm is mostly used search
algorithm
last is numeric algorithm
this algorithm work on numeric values
or we can say it solves some numeric
problems examples are accumulate
function and partial sum functions
now coming to function objects
function objects are also known as
functors a function object is an object
of template class that implements call
operator
this call operator allows the object to
be used with same syntax as regular
function call
for example suppose you have declared an
object obj of a class in which operator
is defined
then you can use the object obj just
like a normal function
function objects also helps in
generating the data and it also helps in
testing purposes
now in order to do some examples let's
move to our code editor that is vs code
so here we will do an example of vector
container
so let's make a new file
and
let's name it stl.cpp
now we'll add the header files
now writing namespace standard
now
we will add before namespace standard we
have to add the header file for vectors
because we are doing the example of
vector so that is why we have to add the
header file of vector
okay now
we'll write int main
now first of all we'll declare the
vector so we'll write vector
int
within the angle brackets
now we will write
the name of the vector that is v
okay now we have to push
some elements inside the vector for that
we have to use for loop so we'll write
for keyword
and i equals
let's say 1
i
less than
equals 10
i plus plus that is increment operator
okay now we have to push the elements
one by one so we'll write v dot push
back
and inside the bracket
will put i
so the elements
will keep on adding one by one at the
end of the vector
so now we will check the size of the
vector
so we'll write
i'll write the message size
and then the function v dot size
it will tell us the size of the vector
that is the number of elements inside it
as you can see they that we have put ten
elements inside the vector one by one so
it must be ten
so in order to check it we have used
this function v dot size
okay now
we'll use another function
that is v dot resize
it will resize the size of the vector
so whatever we put inside this bracket
like let's say i've put 7 so its size
now would be seven
and we need to check this also
so
we'll again use the function
size so first of all we'll display the
message
after
resizing
it becomes
v dot size
it will print the size of the vector
after resizing okay
now
we use another function v dot empty for
that we have to use if condition
so we'll write
v dot
empty brackets
we know that if v dot empty equals true
then it means it is empty and if it
equals false then it means it is not
empty so we'll simply display the
message that
it is not empty
all right see out
and now we will
write
it slashing
not
empty
before go to
write the
commas over here okay
now
in else
we will write
it is empty
it is empty
we can also do this the other way around
like we can put v dot empty equals to
true and then inside that bracket we can
write it is empty but it's your choice
okay now
we'll display the elements of the vector
for that we have to first
write the
message so we'll write
elements of vector
then after this using for loop and
iterator we will print those elements
so let's do this
we'll write for
and inside for loop we'll write
auto
id
here the auto keyword specifies the type
of variable that is being declared will
be automatically deducted from the
initializer and i t is the iterator
now we'll write i t equals v dot begin
and we know that v dot begin function
will point to the first element of the
vector
so
after that we'll write
i t
not equal to
v dot end
and it will point to the last element of
the vector
now we'll write it plus plus
now
we'll print the iterator using the
reference operator
and in order to make some space we'll
write this
now return
zero
okay now
[Music]
let's try to run this
okay
here is the problem i think
now let's try one another time
here it is
size 10
after that after resizing it becomes
seven
firstly we add the elements by pushing
one by one using the pushback function
10 elements were added so size is 10
after that we have resized it so after
resizing it becomes 7
and then we have used the function
empty
so it was not empty so that is why
the message display is not empty
then the elements of vector
before go to pits space over here
and elements of vector one two three
four five six seven
and
that is correct
okay
now we'll do one example of iterator
in this example we'll simply
print the elements of a vector using
iterator
so first of all let's name this
stl2.cpp
now we'll write the header files
hash include iostream
in this we'll add three header files
now we'll write
hash include
iterator
because we have to use iterator so that
is why we are doing this
and we also have to use the vector so
we'll write hash include
vector
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll start with int main
so first of all we'll declare a vector
in which there are some elements
as in previous question we already
learned how to add elements in a vector
so in this question we'll simply declare
those elements inside a vector so we'll
write vector
inside the angle brackets
now let's say ar is the name of this
vector
now we will write the
elements
5 5 elements are there
now we have to declare iterator to a
vector
so
this is how
we'll do it we'll write vector
then
the data type inside the angle brackets
then after this we'll write the scope
resolution operator
like this
now
iterator
keyword
then the name of the iterator that is
ptr
now we'll display the vector elements
using for loop and using the functions
begin and end
so right
first of all we have to
display a message
okay
we'll write
the elements
of
vector r
okay
now semicolon
now using for loop
we'll write
the ptr that is the iterator
ar
dot begin
as we know that ar is the name of the
vector
ar dot begin begin function will point
to the first element of the vector
then
p t r
less than
a r dot
end
we know end function
and function will point to the last
element of the vector
okay now we'll write
ar plus plus
sorry ptr plus plus
now we have to display it
and
we'll display it using the reference
operator
and the name of iterator that is ptr
make some space
now at last we'll write return 0
now let's try to run this
the elements of vector r as you can see
the elements of vector are one two three
four five
so this is how you can print the
elements of a vector using the iterator
here is the vector
and with the help of iterator we have
printed these elements one two three
four five
now we'll do one simple example of
algorithm
first of all let's name this
stl3.cpp
now in this example we'll use swap
algorithm
to swap two
integers and we know that swap is an
template function so let's do this
first of all we'll write
hash include iostream
now using namespace standard
we'll start with int main
now first of all we declare a variable
let's say 7
and
second variable
let's say 10
first of all we'll display the value of
these variables that before swapping and
after swiping so that is where
we will write
value of i
now here we'll write
value of j
handle
okay now we'll use the swap
algorithm
and here we'll mention
the elements we want to swap i comma j
it will simply swap the contents of
these two elements
now we'll write
after swapping
and l
will do same for
j
this is a very basic example but we have
to see the functionality of it
we'll write
and
okay
now we'll write return 0
now we'll run this
yeah
value of i
7 value of j is 10 after swapping i
10 j7
it will look
better if we have
root like this
let's make it look good
yeah value of is 7 value of j is 10
after swapping i becomes 10 and j
becomes 7
so this is how we can swap the elements
using swap algorithm there are some more
algorithms you can try those as well
and now at last we'll do one example of
function object
let's name this as stl4.cpp
all right now
we'll add the header file
hash include iostream
now
we'll write namespace standard
now in this question first of all we'll
start with the function
first of all we'll make a class
class
function
object
now we'll write access specifier public
and
here we'll write the
call operator
as we know the syntax
operator
bracket
then
another bracket
for the arguments
and x
comma and
why
so this is the syntax of it and now
whatever we want to do with these two
variables
let's say we want to multiply
so i'll write return x
into
y
all right
as this is a class so we have to write
the semicolon
now we'll write int main
okay now i will write inpin after inpane
here we will write the name of the class
because
we have to define the object of it
now the object is
f4
so here class name is function obj
and its object is fo and as i have
explained earlier here i can use f4
object like a normal function because f4
is the object of class function obj in
which call operator is defined so it
will act like a normal function
so now
we'll make a variable let's say multiply
so we'll write mult
equals f4
and because it acts like a normal
function so we'll pass the parameters
four and seven
now in order to display we'll write c
out and
we'll write
multiplication
of x
and y
is
now we'll write the name of the variable
mult
because
the result is getting stored in mult
variable now
we'll write return 0
now let's try to run this
here we can see multiplication of x and
y is 28
and that is true 4 into 7
equals 28
so it is working and
this is the example of functor or
function object
so these were some basic examples of
components of stl you can practice some
more examples on them in order to learn
in this video we will learn about c plus
plus enumeration
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
first is why enumerations are used in c
plus plus then we'll understand what is
enumeration and its syntax and after
that we will learn how to use enums with
flags first is why enums are used in c
plus
enums are short for enumerations
these are basically used when we have
some set of possible values and we have
to select one out of it
for example suppose you are the shop
owner and you have four types of coffee
in your coffee machine
that is cold coffee hot coffee black
coffee and mocha
and you don't want the trouble of
customer putting any other coffee name
in the machine
which is not there
then in situations like these
enumerations are used
because in enumerations we have to
choose from predefined values
and it is also helpful for documentation
and readability purpose
now let's understand what is enumeration
enum or enumeration is a user-defined
data type in which a set of values are
specified for the variable and the
variable can take out any value from the
set of values and it is also a way to
use integers to represent values
we can assign values to enum but if we
do not assign any value
then the compiler assigns value to them
starting from 0.
coming to its syntax
which is enum that is the keyword for
enumerated type then enumerated type
name is written then under brackets
possible values of type enum are written
for example here enumeration name is
player and values are ronaldo's laha
messi neymar which are the names of
players
in this example by default ronaldo is
zero salah is one messi is two neymar is
three
because we know by default compiler
assigns them value which start from 0
and so on
but we can change these default values
by assigning values to them
like here ronaldo's value is now 4
salaha's value is 2
messi's value is 8 neymar's value is 1.
now let's have a look at an example in
which we will print the default value of
months
so in this example we have enum name as
months and enumerated values as january
february march and so on
and in order to access these values we
have written enumeration name and after
that the variable
as we can see inside main function m is
the variable and its type is months
now here we have assigned the month
march to the variable m
and then we are printing the variable m
plus one
here plus one will print the value next
to the month march that is 3 and
similarly if we write plus 2 then it
will print then 1 next to it that is 4.
these values are default integer values
after printing the output value is 3
because we have printed m plus 1 where m
is 2 and plus 1 makes it 3.
now
let's understand how to use enum with
flags
in this example we will choose a mobile
having any of the two features among
three
here the name of enumeration is mobile
and its enumerated values are battery
capacity camera quality large storage
and we have assigned values to them
one two and four respectively and
because we are doing this example of
enums with flags that is why we are
using integer values of power 2
because it avoids the overlapping
inside the main function we are using
bitwise or operator because we want to
choose the mobile having both camera
quality and large storage capacity and
we know that bitwise operator adds the
binary of two integers
so the value of camera quality is 2 and
value of large storage is 4.
when we use a bitwise or operator in
between these two features so it will
add up their binary giving the decimal
number as 6.
so the output 6 is showing both the
camera quality and large storage are
used
now let's do some examples of
enumeration in our code editor that is
vs code
okay now let's make a new file
and name the file as
enum dot cpv
in this example the enumeration name
will be captain and the enumerated
values will be the team members out of
which we will select one member as
captain
and with if condition we will verify if
he is the selected captain or not
it will be a basic example so first of
all let's write hash include iostream
now we'll add the namespace standard
okay now we'll write
enumeration enum
captain which is the name of the
enumeration type
and now we will write the enumerated
values
which is
let's say abi
sid
robbie
sammy
and jake
these are the team members
now we'll write int main
now here we will first of all write
captain which is the name of the
numerator type
then we'll make the
variable out of it cap
and let's say avi is the captain so
we'll write a v
now here we will write if condition
will write if
cap equal to a v
then we'll display
our captain is away and its value is
whatever the value this avi's value here
is zero so we'll display that
so we'll write
our captain
is a v
and its value
is then we'll write av
as we know that av is at first position
then
its value would be default value would
be zero
okay so
here we will write endl
now in else
here if we put said row b sammy jake as
captain or we if we declare them as
captain then this message would be
declared which will be writing in else
so the message would be
he is not our captain
then over here we will write return zero
okay now let's try to run this
our captain is away and its value is
zero
because here
captain we have declared avi so that is
why this is
printing if we write
let's say
sammy over here
then it will print the else part
he is not our captain
and if we write jake or said
then also it will print the same
is not a captain
only in case of avi it will print our
captain is away and its value
is avi's value
so this was the basic example of
enumeration now let's move on to one
another example
now
let's make a new file
and name it as enum2
dot cpp
okay
now we will add the header files hash
include iostream
and using namespace standard
so here we will do an example in which
enumeration name will be supercars and
to the values we will assign some
integers to them
which will be the speed of those cars
and then we will compare them using
comparison operator in terms of speed
so
we will write enum
the name of enumeration that is let's
say supercars
okay
now inside the bracket
we'll write the name of the cars which
are the values
and we will assign
some integers
these integers are actually speed of
these cars
268
then
valkyrie
speed is 240
now
roadster
250.
okay now
as you have created the enum now we will
start within main
so we will write the numerator type name
supercars
now the variable speed
one because we want to create two
variables in order to compare them so
first we will create speed one
now again
speed two
now we will assign the two cars that we
want to compare to these variables
so
speed one will be
valkyrie
and speed 2 would be
roadster
okay
now we will write the if condition
and inside the f condition we will
compare the speed of these two cars
so we will write speed one
if speed one is less than
speed 2
okay
then we will print
that it's a win for roadster
because speed 2 is roadster and speed 1
is valkyrie so we'll write it's a win
for roadster
with the speed we'll also write the
speed with the speed
off
this p2 will display the speed of
roadster that is 250
okay now
else condition
so here we will write
it's a win for
valkyrie
with the speed
of
here we will write speed
one okay
now we have to write into main but
before that we will write the bracket
which we forgot to mention
return zero
okay i think it's done
now let's try to run this
here we can see it's a win for roadster
with the speed of 250 as we know that
the speed of roadster here is 250 and
the valkyrie speed is 240.
so when we compare it
speed 2 that is roadster wins because
roadster is 250
so this was the second example now let's
do one last example
let's name this
okay
enum3.cpp
write hash include iostream
now namespace standard
now in this example we will see how to
use switch statement with the
enumeration
okay so
first of all
inside int main
we will write
enum
color is the name of the enumeration
type
then we'll write the values
red
blue
green
and yellow
these are the values
now
here we will use switch statement
but before doing that we have to assign
one color to a variable
so first of all we have to create that
variable and in order to create the
variable we will write the numeration
type name color
and then
the variable name select
now we will assign
one color from the above colors
let's say
yellow
now in switch statement we will write
first of all we'll write switch
statement
switch
and
we will pass here the variable that is
select
basically we are passing yellow
because yellow is assigned to the
variable select and that is why it is
getting passed
so now
case one that is case red
first of all we'll write the case red
with a colon in the end
now we will
print that it is red
now we will write the break statement
break statement basically
ends the case or terminates the case
so after that
the second case that is case blue
colon
now here we will print
it is blue
and similarly
break statement
we'll do same for all of these colors
green and yellow also
and switch statement will help us to
find which color is passed and will
display the message of that color
so here we will write
green
it is green
break statement
now case yellow
now we will write it is yellow
now he will write break
okay now at last we have to write return
zero
now as we know that we have we have
passed a particular color
to the variable select and select
is the expression and switch statement
will help us
in comparing the variable select value
to the value of different blocks and one
which matches that particular block will
execute
okay now let's try to run this one
here we can see
it is yellow is being printed
which is the right answer because we
have passed the color yellow to the
select and that is why only the case
yellow
output is being printed
so
this is how you can use switch statement
with the enumeration
so these are some basic examples of c
plus plus elimination you can try some
more examples on it in order to practice
it
in this session we are going to learn
about c plus gui that is graphical user
interface and how to configure visual
studio and make a gui application
so without further ado let's get started
to develop c
gui or c plus plus graphical user
interface apps we must have an ide
that supports c plus gui applications
and visual studio is one of the best ide
for that here ide stands for integrated
development environment
there are many versions of visual studio
for gui apps
but i suggest you to download visual
studio 2019
there are three editions of visual
studio 2019 that is community
professional and enterprise
we can download the community edition
once the visual studio is downloaded and
installed then you need to launch this
application after that you can select
the color theme
and change the development settings to
visual c plus
then the visual studio will look like
this
then here we will click on this create a
new project
and now we have to search for a project
template named clr empty project dot net
framework
so we'll type
clr
empty project.net framework
here it is
make sure that there is dotnet framework
over here
now all we have to do is to click on
this
and
select next
now here
we can name our project let's say i have
named it project 2 and we can select the
location
and now we can click on this create
button
now our project is being created
so here it is
so now let's create a form file by going
to the project
then add item
add new item
now here visual c plus plus
under visual c plus we'll click on ui
and then windows form
we'll click on this windows form and
click on this add button
so our file is loading
so it will show you this error but you
don't need to worry about this one you
can simply close it
now we will go to project
then into properties
then now we'll click on this linker
open this linker
now we'll go to the system
then inside this sub system
over here
we'll select
windows
here it is
now
after doing this then we go to advance
and in advance we can change this
entry point to main
we'll write main main
this main is the starting function
now we can
press ok over here
now you need to open this myform.cpp
here it is and you have to copy this
code
and just paste it over here
we will add this code in the description
you can take this code from there and
add it
now make sure to write your project name
over here
like my project name is project 2
so i'll write
project
2
yes
so after doing this we can save it by
pressing control ns
and now we can go to myform.h
here we can see there is no form so we
need to
save it and close this
visual studio once
now we need to open the visual studio
again
we'll go over here we'll write visual
studio 2019 here it is we'll click on
this
and this is launching
we can click on this project too
now
let's go to
my form dot h
will click on this
it is getting loaded
here we can see the form
earlier we are only able to see the code
but now we can see this form
now we can check this by running it by
clicking on this local windows debugger
button we'll click on that
and let's see if it is running or not
it will take some time
so here it is it is running properly as
you can see this is my my form
and this is ready to use
so it is the debugging is going on so if
we have to close the debugging or stop
the debugging we can click on this cross
button
so the debugging is closed now and we
have verified that the form is running
correctly
we can also add some buttons and labels
to this form like this we can click on
this tool box
then we can select this button
and we can click this over here
so this is our button and we can select
some more labels
all right we can click on this toolbox
again
and select another button like this over
here
and
now
we can select a label let's say
and click over here
and we can also adjust the size of these
buttons
like this
and like this we can adjust the size
and this is the label
we have to adjust his size by setting
its format we can do it by
clicking on this label
and going to properties
over here we can see as you have clicked
on the label
so we can see the text that is label one
here we can see text
label one
so it is this text which is written we
can change this one
by clicking on this we can select
hello there we can write like this and
it will be shown over this side
now
we must click
the label first then only we can access
the
button or label
so now let's say this is the font so we
can click on this font
and adjust this
here it is let's say
i have adjusted it to 18 size and
made it bold now we can click this okay
over this side so here we can see hello
there it is bold now
similarly we can do this for button as
well
as we have clicked on this button as you
can see
now i can go to this properties
now
inside this properties there is text
that is button one we can see we can
change this like we can write click here
and
we can also just it's font
here it is
let's say 12
and bold oblique
you click on this okay and here it is
click here
you can adjust it over there and suppose
if you want to delete some
button or label or something like that
so we can click on this
and
right click on this side and here we can
see delete we'll click on this late and
it will be deleted
there are more options in toolbox like
there is text box
list box list view
picture box
check box etc we can select as per our
choice
and
we can adjust its layout or editing by
going to the properties column
so now let's make a calculator program
so for that we have to create a
calculator layout so let's just delete
all these
delete this one
and we'll delete this one as well
now we'll go to the toolbox
and select a text box we can search it
over here
text box
here it is we can click on that
and put it over here
here it is
we have to adjust its formatting
so we'll go to properties and
we'll go to font
and click on this font
now let's say adjust it to
22
and
make it bold
bold oblique yes
i will click on this okay
and
we have to create another one so
instead of doing this all we can copy
this one and to copy this we can go to
this side and click right click over
here
and we can click on this copy
and then we can paste it
here it is because we have to enter two
numbers and for that we need to have two
text boxes for a calculator
all right now in between we can mention
the
operation or operator whatsoever for
that we can we have to select the label
and we'll go to tool box
and
here it is
text box
but we have to select
label
all right
label
we'll click on this label and
put it over here
now we have to adjust it
now here we will write
let's say its font would be
20. and
it would be bold oblique
it will look nice then click on ok
now we have to adjust what is written
inside it so we can go to text and click
on this
label one now
we can write operator
but it would be so long so we can write
op
that means operator
all right
it gives the idea
about the operator
we have to adjust it a bit
all right here it is
and
okay now we have to create a buttons for
addition subtraction multiplication so
we'll go to toolbox
and now we'll
search for buttons
we'll click on button and put it over
here
and now we'll adjust it by going to
properties
and go into fonts
let's adjust it to
22
and make it bold
now we'll click on ok
and now we have to change the label of
it
first of all let's select
its layout like this
it would be big
now we'll go to properties
and
we'll go to text
and
we'll make an addition sign over here
and now we'll click on this so here we
can see so now we'll copy this button to
create the
next three buttons so
click on this copy and paste it
we'll do this for the other two as well
and we'll change the text by going to
properties later onwards
here it is
so first will be addition then here
let's make it
we'll go into
properties we'll click on this
properties
now
let's make this text as
minus
all right now we can also change the
color of this text
let's say
we can make this
this here it is
blue in color now we'll change this one
we'll go to properties
and
make this as
sign of multiplication but we'll press
x
so that will look nice
all right now this one
we'll go to properties and change this
to
division sign
and we can change this one as well
it will look nice
let's make it this similar color to the
subtraction
all right here it is here are four
buttons addition subtraction
multiplication and division
now we have to display the result as
well so
we'll go to toolbox
and we'll search for label
we'll click on this label
and put it over here
all right
let's make it like this and
let's put it
over this side it will look nice over
here
properties now
we have to adjust it
let's make it 22
bold oblique
okay
here is our result and let's name it as
result as well we'll go to text here it
is labeled to written
we'll write
result
now whatsoever operation is done its
result or output is displayed over this
side
now all we need to do is to add the
functionality to these buttons
so let's do that we'll click on this
two times
on this button and the button name
actual name of that button is button one
so here it is
so this part is for button one and we
know that button one is addition so we
need to do addition over here
so let's start
first of all we'll
[Music]
we'll have to declare a variable
int result or output or
unser whatsoever we want let's write
output
now to add those we need the names of
those two text boxes
so we'll go to format design
and we need these names both of these
text box names so we'll click on this
first
and we'll go to properties
so here it is text box one we can see
and we click on this
and properties this is text box two
and this is similarly this is button one
button two button three button four
we can check this by going to properties
and by clicking them and going to
properties so this is text box one and
this is text box too
so now we know the names
now all we have to do
is to write
text box
text box where b is capital
we have to write the exact name we can
check it over here that this is text box
we can check the spelling
this is text box two this is label one
this is button one this is button two we
can
check the spellings from there now
now we have to use the
arrow operator
we'll write like this this is the air
operator this will give us the access to
the members of the object
all right so
we have to change the text so we'll
write
text
with t capital
all right
now we have to add
the text box too
and we'll do it same
we'll write
this ad operator
and text
now this addition which we have written
over here is wrong
because we are actually adding the
strings
as you can see
when we type any number over here it is
a string and same goes for this part
so we have to convert it
first we will convert both of these
text to integer and then we will
again convert the result into string
because we have to display it over here
and for that we need a string so then
again we have to convert it to the
string
and let's do it
so what we gonna do is we'll write
system
and then the scope resolution operator
convert
again scope resolution inverter
operator sorry 2
and
16
i must be capital keep in mind to int 16
all right now here we'll write
text
box with b capital
and then this operator
and we'll write
text
all right
after that sign of addition
again we'll do the same
system scope resolution operator
convert scope resolution operator
to
end
16
and
text box 2 here we have to write text
box 2
arrow operator
text
all right
here is the addition part now we have to
display the result
now to do that
first check the name of the result like
this is the result we'll click on this
and go to properties
its name is label 2
so we have to make the changes into
label 2. we'll go to this
format
now we'll
have to change the text that is we have
to change the result that is written
into the
output
so for that we will write
label
2 which is the name
then this arrow operator
after that we'll write text because we
have to change it
and then
we'll write
system
scope resolution operator
convert
scope resolution operator
to
string because we have to display the
output into string
as i have already told you
all right
now
over here we have to write
output
this output
okay
so let's check if it is working or not
we'll go to local windows debugger and
click on this
hope it works
here it is
my form
so let's try to add
let's say 5
plus
9
and we'll click on this add button
14
and we know that 5 plus 9 equal to 14 so
it is working fine we can see and now we
have to do this for all the buttons that
is subtraction multiplication and
division so let's go ahead and do that
let's first close this debugging
we have stopped the debugging and we'll
go to this
now we have to do that for
the next three buttons will
all right
now we'll click on this
subtraction button two times
here we can
see now
the code is same for all of these
and
so we can copy the code from here
and we have just
copied it and we'll paste it
and we'll make the
changes in the sign like i have used
here
minus sign for the subtraction
and the rest is good yeah
all right now we'll do it for the next
one that is
multiplication
and double click on that
and here it is
we'll copy the code from here
and paste it
we will change the sign
the subtraction not the multiplication
sign this is this multiplication sign
and now
the next one that is division
here we go
will again select
copy
and paste
let's change the sign of this as well
okay
as we have done the changes so let's
save it by pressing ctrl ns
and
it is saved now let's try to run this
hope it works we'll click on this local
windows debugger
it usually takes some time and here it
is
so let's try now
five
plus
6 let's do this first of all edition 11
now
we'll do
20 minus
6 so we'll click on this minus
and 20 minus 6 equals to 14 that's right
and now we'll do 20 into
3 that is 60
click on this multiply sign 20 into 3
that is 60 it is right
now let's
say
15 and
3 yeah
we click on divide and this is 5
so all of our
buttons is working fine so this is how
we can create a calculator in visual
studio 2019
you can also create this calculated
program in your pc all you need to do is
to download visual studio 2019 and
install it and you can follow the steps
and you can create this calculator
application in this session we'll make a
project in c plus plus
this project will be a hotel management
project in which we will have the
information of the items or rooms that
we have in the hotel and what are the
food items ordered by the customer
also we have the information that how
many rooms are allotted to them
also this project will tell us about the
sales and the remaining food stocks we
have and the total collection of the day
we will make this project in three parts
firstly we will discuss the first part
in which we will declare some variables
and then initialize them
after that we will enter the quantities
of items that we have in the hotel
then we'll make a list of items or menu
of items and rooms that we have in the
hotel
so let's start
now we will switch to our code editor
that is dev c plus so this is a code
editor so here first of all let's make a
new file
we'll click on file and
now we'll create a new file
so now let's start with the project so
first of all inside the main function we
have to declare some variables but
before that
we will
write the header files that is hash
include iostream
and then the namespace standard
all right so we have included the header
files now we'll start with the main
function
inside the main function
we will declare the variable so first
variable that will declare would be
quant which stands for quantity
and the second variable would be choice
now we will declare those variables
that store the quantity of food items or
rooms
so let's say
the variable which will store the
quantity of rooms would be q
rooms
and
we have to initialize it also
all right so similarly we have to do it
with the food items as well so let us
suppose one of our food item is pasta so
we'll write
q pasta that is quantity pasta
will initialize it with zero
similarly we'll do with the rest of the
food items
that is burger
noodles
and shake
and chicken
here chicken would be let's say chicken
roll
so these are
our food items so these variables will
hold the quantity of these food items
so now we will declare those variables
which will hold the value of the number
of food items that have been sold
so for example q pasta holds the value
of number of pastas we had in our hotel
and s pasta will hold the value of
number of pastas that have been sold
so let's start
similarly we'll write s
rooms that is sold rooms
we have to initialize it with zero as
well
and s pasta
similarly asmr
as noodles
as chicken
all right
now we'll create some more variables
that will store the price of the total
price of each of these food items or
rooms so let's do that let's say in
total
underscore rooms this is the variable
name
it will store the total price of the
rooms
we will initialize it with zero
similarly
total
pasta
equals zero
total
burger
all right
so these variables holds the quantity of
food we have
these variables holds the quantity of
food we sold and these variables will
hold the price the total price of each
of the food items or rooms
so
let's comment it these holds quantity
so that it's easy for you guys
all right so here we have declared these
variables
now
now we will make a list kind of a
structure in which we will ask
the user to enter the number or
quantities of food items or rooms that
we have in the hotel
so
all right now let's do this
first of all we have to display a
message
but before that we'll use slash n and
slash d
so slash n means the next line and slash
t will add a horizontal space in the
output
so we need
that horizontal space
so we'll write
quantity of food
let's say items only quantity of items
we have
we have in our hotel
all right
now
we'll write rooms available
so we'll add slash n and
rooms
available
all right so after this
we will write c in and take the input of
quantity of rooms we have because here
we are asking to enter the number of
rooms we have
so we'll write c in
q rooms because it holds the quantity of
rooms we have
we have initialized it with zero
similarly we'll do it for the rest like
quantity of pasta like this will do
inside the
slash n
now we'll write the quantity of pasta
see
in
q pasta
all right
now similarly
let's copy paste
and save some time
so this first was the pasta then
burger
and q burger
then there was noodles
few noodles
similarly we'll do it for shake
and then
here chicken is the chicken roll
so quantity of chicken roll
cue chicken
all right
so
one by one q room the quantity of rooms
we have to add q pasta the quantity of
pasta we have to add then quantum burger
we have
all right now we have to create a menu
to select the pasta burger room all the
items we have to create a menu like that
and for that let's do this
we'll write c out again we'll use
slash in
slash and then
again slash d slash
t
because you want some horizontal space
in that
we'll display a message saying that
please select from the given menu
options
all right
so it's a message for the users
or the customers i would say
now again we'll use slash n
because i want to add some new lines
so i'll use two selection
now
first is rooms
secondly we'll use only one selection
and
here we are creating the
menu to select the food items or rooms
so now we will write
pasta
and similarly we'll copy paste
so pasta then there was burger
then noodles
and there was shake
then there was chicken
chicken roll
you also have to change the numbering
that this is one this is two
then this is three
we are doing the numbering because the
customer will press the number
and then he can order
five
six
and now again we'll
in seventh position we'll add the
details or information regarding the
collection and sales
so
we'll write
press 7 if you want to see the
information
regarding
sales
and collection
this option would be used by the owner
of the hotel to check the total
collection for the day
all right now again
the eighth number
is for
if we want to exit
yeah
so this is done now
after that we'll display a message
saying that
please enter your choice
so we'll use slash and slashing and
right
please enter
your choice
now we'll write c in choice we have
already declared this variable
now based on this choice your order is
selected like if you press
2 then this pasta would be selected like
let's say if you want to order noodles
then you have to select four and if you
want to
order chicken roll then you have to
select six and if you want to check the
total sales and connect collection of
today
that is
for a particular day then you have to
click seven and eight for the exit
so a first part is done now in the
second part we have to add the
functionality to the choice part that is
if a user enters the first number that
is number one then rooms is selected and
then he or she have to add the numbers
of rooms they want
similarly for the other food items as
well
like if they want to take two burgers or
three burgers instead of one and we only
have one burger left
then also we have to display a message
saying that only so and so burgers are
left so now let's start with it
so now we will write switch case
statements so when
the user will select a particular number
so that particular case would be
executed
so now let's do that
we'll write switch
and
inside the switch statement
we'll write choice
now the choice can be one two three four
five six seven eight
all right so now we have to create eight
cases for that
so case one would be
start with it
there's a space between case and one
all right so case one would be
first of all inside the case one
that is the case when rooms have to be
selected so first of all we'll display a
message saying that enter the number of
rooms you want
so let's do that
use slash n
now
enter the
number of rooms you want
all right
now after that
the user will enter the number of rooms
that is the quantity of rooms
so now we will take the quantity
in the quantity variable that is quant
variable
so the user will enter the number of
rooms that is the quantity of rooms he
or she wants
now we'll use a if statement an if
statement inside this if statement now
inside this if statement will check do
we actually have that many rooms in our
hotel or do we actually have that many
pastas or burgers in our hotel
right now so for that we have to write
down a condition
that is
q rooms
minus s rooms
is greater than
equal to
quant
that is
q rooms is the quantity of rooms that we
have and s rooms the number of rooms
that we have sold
so if
we minus both of these that is if we
subtract the quantity of room we have
minus the rooms we have sold we will get
the remaining rooms now if the remaining
rooms it's greater than equal to the
quantity of rooms that have been ordered
by the customer then
we can give the room to them otherwise
we have to display a message saying that
we don't have that many rooms or
something like that
so let's do that so we'll write s rooms
that is the rooms that we have sold so
initially its value is zero so we have
to add the values of quantity that have
been
entered by the user so we'll add the
quant variable that is if the user have
entered two rooms he or she wants then
we'll add the add those two values to
this sold rooms
all right after adding the quantity to
the sold rooms
now
we will do the total price of the room
or rooms and for that we have the
variable
total
room
so we'll add this quant
into the price of a one room
to this total room
so
we are simply adding
total room plus
quant
into the price of a single room that is
let's say 1200 is the price of a single
room
if a person orders two rooms then it
would be like quant that is 2 2 into
1200 2400 will be added to this total
room this total room is the total price
of a room
all right
now we also have to display a message
saying that these many rooms have been
allotted to you so for that let's
display a message first of all we'll use
slash n
like two times now
we'll add some horizontal space as well
all right
now we'll display this quant
variable and
write a message
that these many rooms
have been
allotted
to you
let me let's make it room or rooms
room or rooms have been allotted to you
so this message will be displayed
all right
now
this is the if block
now we'll have to make the else block
that
if the
amount or quantity of room entered by
the user is more than the remaining
rooms then we'll display a message
saying that only so and so rooms are
left in the hotel
so we'll use slash n then again slash t
now
write
only
q rooms
minus s rooms that is here q room minus
s room is the remaining rooms are the
remaining rooms so
subtracting both of these
variables will give us the remaining
rooms
so
these were the remaining rooms
remaining
in
hotel
all right
and let's not add this as there's a
single statement
also we have to use break
so we'll use break statement now
similarly we have to create case 2. this
case was for the room
so whenever a user click on this one
then this case will be
executed so similarly we will create a
case 2
so let
we'll copy it now we'll paste it
so
i will case 2
so in this case
enters the number of rooms you want we
can't we can't write that
so we'll write past the quantity
so let's do that
we'll write
enter
past the
quantity
all right so in this case
the cn would be same that is quantity
variable we have
so
now in this case the different thing
would be the queue rooms instead of
queue rooms we'll use the
queue pasta that is the quantity of
pasta
minus sold pastas
it must be greater than quantity of
pasta we have
then only if block will execute
otherwise similarly as that of this
block
will display a message
so now the s rooms instead of s rooms
here we'll use s pasta
which is initially zero
so we'll add the quantity of pasta to
this variable that is will add the
quantity of pasta that is ordered by the
custard to this variable
now
total pasta that is the total price of
the pasta
so the number of pastas ordered by the
customer into the price of a single
pasta let's say the price of a single
pasta is around 250
so quantity into 250
now
rooms instead of rooms let's do here
pasta is the order
so quant
so quant will display the
quantity
so it will display like if you have
order to pass this will it will display
two
pasta
is the
order
and
q rooms here we have to display the
remaining so we'll do the q pasta minus
s pasta
and here we'll do is pasta remaining in
hotel or stock
pasta remaining in hotel
so it will display the remaining pasta
remained in the hotel now
so
else everything is fine now similarly
we'll do for the next
we'll copy it it will save some time
and paste it now this is case three the
case three is of burger
so
i will
write
burger
quantity of burger miners
sold burgers
similarly s burger
now the total price of burger
so let's say the price of a burgle is
around 120
and so
the remaining burgers
q burger minus s burger
the fourth case now
that is the noodles case
so enter noodles quantity
now case 5
now case 5 is of shakes
so we'll write enter shakes quantity
now
case 6 we have to create
in the case 6 there is chicken roll
so let's do that
chicken
minus s chicken
also we have to change the price of each
meal like chicken roll
would be off around 150
and this shake would be
120
noodles
140 let's say
burger is okay then
pasta is also okay
so we have created six cases as of now
so our second part of the program is
done now we'll start with the third part
of the program
so the third part will contain the case
seven case eight and the default case
that is if the user enters any other
number which is not in the list that
will come under default case
in case 7 we have to display the
information of sales and collection that
is how many
money we have collected for the day and
the remaining food items etc
so
now let's start with the case seven
so when the user will enter seven that
is case seven
then he want to see the details of the
information of sales and collection
so we'll display a message saying that
details
of sales
and
collection
all right
so after this message let's add slashing
slash t slash t
all right
so after this message
we have to display the number of rooms
we had the number of rooms we gave for
rent
and then the remaining rooms that is
minus the quantity of rooms minus the
soul rooms then the total rooms
collection for the day
so similarly we'll do for all the meals
like pasta burger noodles etc so let's
do it
so we'll start
display
first of all we'll add slash n
now
number of rooms
we had
display queue rooms that is the
quantitative rooms we had
now
similarly
number of rooms
we gave
for rent
all right
so we'll write
s
runes
now we have to display a message
similarly we'll write slash and slash n
remaining
rooms
so
for that we have to simply subtract
queue rooms with s rooms that will give
us the remaining rooms
after that
the total price
that the room has collected or number of
rooms have collected
so we'll write
total
rooms
collection
for the day
now
it is stored at total rooms
this variable is storing the total
drives of rooms
this is the complete information of
rooms similarly we have to do it for the
burger noodle pasta etc
so we can copy we'll copy this part
and we'll do
copy and paste
and paste
again will paste
now number of rooms we had instead of
this we'll simply write number of pastas
we had
number of pastas
we have to change that
number of pastas we
sold
yeah that would be right
now remaining pastas
there are few minor changes that we have
to do
total
pasta collection
also make sure to change the
variables total
pasta
then
q pasta
all right now
after pasta it was burger
burgers we have
number of burgers we sold
all right so
it would be q burger
and s burger
remaining burgers
total burger collection for the day
all right
now we'll do same for
noodles
all right now
shakes
number of shakes we had
number of shakes we gave
we sold
remaining shakes
now there is chicken roll
number of chicken rule we had
all right now the case 8 the case 8 we
have used for this was the case 7
and the case 8 we have used for exit as
you can see here
this is the exit case and for that
we'll simply use
the exit statement the exit statement is
used to terminate the program to shift
the control out of the program or exit
the program
so here we'll use that so k say it would
be
exit and inside that will use 0 0 will
mean that zero millisecond
and now after that we will have to use
the default case
that if the user enters any other number
that is not present in the menu list
then this default case will be executed
so in this default case we'll display a
message saying that please select from
the numbers that are mentioned above
so we'll use slash n
please
select
the numbers
mentioned above
so this message will be printed
and also one more thing is there
we have to use a go to statement
and we'll have to label
a part with m
now i'll explain to you that why have we
used this jump statement that is go to
statement
so after making a choice we again want
to choose another option that is if i
have ordered two pastas then i also want
to order two
burgers as well
so
we will mark or label
menu with m
so this is a menu please select from the
menu options so here we will label m
and
in the last we have used the go to
statements
so the go to statement here will
transfer the control to the menu after
making a choice
so again m is the label we have used for
the menu and we will use a go to
statement to transfer the control to the
menu after making the choice so that we
can make more choices
go to is a jump statement basically that
is used to jump from one part to another
part having a specified label
so we have labeled menu with m and this
go to jump statement will help us in
jumping to the menu after every choice
all right so our code is done we have
done all the things that we need
now we need to run it and for that
firstly we need to save it
all right so let's go to files and save
it
and now let's
select the destination folder
let's name it as
management
management dot cpp
all right
so the program is saved
now let's try to
compile and run this program
so there are some arrows i can see
okay so
we have used
the semicolon
now
this will take care of many errors now
let's try to again compile and run
let's check q noodles
all right i think uh
q noodles
so we have two backspaces now
let's try to
compile and run again
hope it works now
so quantity of items we have as we can
see
so rooms available let's say we have 10
rooms
and quantity of pasta
we have
25 pastas in our hotel and around 50
burgers
and 30 noodles
and
36
chicken roll we have 40.
so this is the menu please select from
the menu options as we can see
first rooms
then pasta burger noodles shake chicken
roll information regarding sales and
collection and then it to exit
so first of all
let's say
i want to order two rooms so i'll click
one
please enter your choice i have clicked
one and i'll press enter now enter the
number of rooms you want and let us
suppose i want two rooms
so as you can see
two room or rooms have been allotted to
you
now again the menu is displayed on the
screen now let's say i want
burgers so i'll click on three
and i want two burgers
and two burger is the order it is
displayed
now again i want a
pasta let's say
i want
six pastas
and six pasta the order
i want
to order now shakes
let's have something to drink i want to
order
nine shakes
nine shakes is the order
and let's say
so as we know that we have only ten
rooms
now let's try to enter eleven
so first of all we'll enter one that is
rooms
now let's try to order
11 rooms
as you can see only eight
eight rooms available or remaining in
hotel so we forgot to add some space
over this part
but we can easily read it now as of now
so
it is displaying the message that only
eight rooms are available because
already we have ordered
two
early it was ten then now only eight
rooms are available so this is showing
that if we
order
more than the quantity then it will
display this message
now let's say i want to
check the information regarding sales
and collection of today's
rooms and as well as meals so i'll
simply click on seven
now as we can see it will simply display
all the
sales and collection
rooms and meals as you can see number of
rooms we had 10 number of rooms we gave
for rent two remaining rooms are eight
so total rooms collection for the race
2400 as one room is of 1200
so similarly number of pastas we had 25
number of pastas we sold six remaining
pastas we had 19 so the total pasta
collection is 1500 so and so the burger
and then noodles and then shakes and
chicken roll
so this is the total chicken roll
collection for the day
that's that is we haven't ordered a
single chicken roll also we can do one
more thing we can simply
display the total result of all the
collections of rooms and meals
so let's do that
now so to display the total collection
of the day all we need to do is to add
all the totals of pastas burgers and
rooms
so for that we have to go to k7
now we'll write slash and slash and
slashing three times
so here we'll write total collection for
the day
and after that
total rooms
plus
total total burgers
total pasta
this total
burger
total
chicken
all right after this we will use the
break statement
now let's run the program
so here it is rooms available
let's write 10
quantity of pasta 30
quantity burger 50
quantity of noodles 30
shakes 30
chicken roll
40
so first of all i'll book two rooms i'll
click on one and now two rooms
and again
if i'll click on rooms
and then if i try to click
10 rooms because already we have two
sold we sold two rooms then it will
display that only eight rooms remaining
in hotel
now i'll click on two to order pasta
let's say i have ordered five pastas
and
five pasta is the order
now let's say if we click on nine
although we know that only one to eight
numbers are available but if we click on
nine
so it will display a message please
select the numbers mentioned above
all right now let's say i have i want
ordered chicken roll
10 chicken rolls i want
so 10 chicken roll is the order now i
want to check information regarding
sales and connection for the day
so click on 7
and then here i can see
number of rooms we had number of rooms
we gave for rent remaining rooms and
total collection for the day similarly
for the pasta
similarly for the burger similarly for
noodles
shakes and chicken roll as well
and this is the total collection for the
day 5150 exit
and if we click on it we can exit
so as we can see
this is our hotel management project
and this is how it's done
the code is bit long but it's worth it
you can also try this project on your
own in this tutorial we will make a
project in c plus plus
this project will be a login and
registration system in c plus
in which a user can register
log in and also if he or she forgets the
password then also it can be recovered
we will make this project using the
fundamentals of c plus like switch case
statements and file handling operations
etc
but before that if you are new to our
channel then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel as we have daily
updates on multiple technologies
so let's go ahead and understand this c
plus plus project of login and
registration system
in this project first of all we will
make a menu page
in which there are options like login
registration
forgot password and exit
then we'll ask the user to select anyone
among those options
once the user has selected a particular
option
then we have to continue with the
functionality of that
so now let's switch to our code editor
and do its practical implementation
so this is our dev c plus code editor
and now let's create a new file
now first of all we will include the
header files
the hash include iostream
then there is
f stream class for file handling
operation
hash include f stream
then there is string.h
for string
then we will include the namespace
standard
now we will do the forward declaration
for three functions that is login
function registration function and
forward function
and after that inside the main function
we will make the menu for the login page
so let's start
first of all we are doing the forward
declaration
this is the login function
this is the registration function
and this is the forward function
now inside the int main
first of all we will make a variable
c which stands for choice c for choice
so now
we will make the menu page
so let's create
use
slash t for adding the horizontal space
now in the end we will use slashing
all right similarly we'll do here
welcome to
the login page
now again we'll do the same
slash d
and now
underscores
menu
slash installation
all right now we will make the options
so we'll do the slash t
now after slash t will add
vertical bar
then
we'll write press
one
to login
let's make it capital
press one to login
and after making some space then
vertical
bracket again
then end l
similarly
we'll copy it and do for option 2.
press 2
to register
all right
let's maintain the symmetry
press 3
if you forgot your password all right
press 4 to exit
all right
so this is done now after that we will
ask the user to enter your choice
and for that we'll display a message
saying that
please enter your choice
but before that we'll use slash n and
some slash teas
all right now we'll ask the user please
enter your
choice
all right
now we'll take the input of the choice
that is c that we have already declared
next line
now
we'll use switch case statements
for example if the user selects 2 to
register first of all
then
inside the switch case statement in case
2 we will call the
registration function
and if the user enters 1 then we will
call the login function
so let's do that let's create a switch
statement
and see that is choice
now inside the switch statement first of
all we'll create a case one
inside this case there would be
login
we are calling this logging function
and then there is break statement
all right similarly now we will
create case 2
so case 2 would be registration
here we are calling the registration
function
and then there is break statement
in case three there is forgot function
that is if the user forgets the password
then this function will be implemented
now
there is a default case
no now there is a case for
in case 4 there would be
a message saying that
thank you
because case 4 would be exit
so we'll display a message saying that
now we will also have to make the
default case
that is if the user selects 5 6 or any
other number that is not in the menu
then we will display a message saying
that
please select from the options given
above so before that we'll add the slash
t
please select
from the options
given
above
after that we'll use slash n
and end
after that we'll call the main function
so that the control goes back to the
main function and
we'll also use
system
cls that is clear screen
it means every time the code is
processed it will clear up the screen
now all we need to do is to create the
login function
so
i'll write void
login
and inside this function first of all
we'll create some variables
and so let's do that and count
user
id
no this user id would be of string
write
string
user id
then there would be
password
then id
then pass
all right so these are the variables
that we have created
now again we'll use this
system cls
that is clear screen
we have to
write cls inside the double quotes
all right now we will display a message
that please enter the username and
password
so we'll do that
and we'll write slash g slash d slash d
and
please enter
the username
and
password
all right now
we'll again display a message saying
that
username
now we'll take the input
so here user id
is the username that the user will enter
now again we will display a message
saying that password
let's make it capital
again we'll take the input
now as the user has entered the username
and password
now we will check that if that username
and password already exist in our
records
and for that we will use the file
handling operation
of if stream class because if stream is
used
to read the data
so
we will use if stream
and if stream class
this will read the data from the file
input is the object name
and the file name would be
records
dot txt
all right
we'll have to
[Music]
make it inside the double quotes
all right
so now this if stream will check inside
the file that if that login password
exist or not
and to check that we will have to use
the while loop
inside the while loop will write
input that is the object name
then there would be id
and then
pass
so this is the id and password
and this is how we read in file handling
operations
here what we are doing is we are reading
that if
that id and password is there and then
we will match those id and password
with
the id and password that is entered by
the user
so for that we will have to use the if
condition inside the while loop
so let's do that we will write if
id
equals user id
and
pass equals password
then
count would be
one
and then we will use system cls to clear
the screen here we have assigned one to
count because in the next part we will
use an if condition that if the count is
one then we will display a message
saying that
your login is successful that is the
password or username entered by the user
matches with the record that is
the user has already registered
so now before that we have to close this
file
so
let's do that
we'll to close this file we will use the
object name that is input dot
close this is how we can close the file
all right now we'll use the if condition
and inside this if condition
as i've said if count equals one
all right if count equals one
then we will first of all display the
user id that is the username
and then we will display a message that
your login is successful
so let's do that
your login
is successful
now thanks for logging in
now again we will
shift the control to the main
because there is the main menu
and now
inside the else block
we will display a
message that is if the user and password
is not found inside the file
then
it means that the
user is not registered so he can't login
he has to register first
so we'll
display a message
saying that
login error
please check your username
now again
main function
now we have to create another function
that is the registration function
that is if the user press 2 then this
registration function
would be called
so let's create this function
void registration
now inside this function we will first
of all create some variables then after
that we'll ask the user to enter the
username and password pretty much the
same as that of the previous function so
first of all string
r for registration
user
id
our user id
then our
password
then rid and rpas
system cls again clear screen
all right
now we will
display a message saying that enter the
username
again
enter the password
our password
all right
so in the previous function we have used
if stream class but in this function we
will use off stream class because we
want to write inside the file and off
stream helps us with that
so
for that we will use off stream
and object name would be f1
and
records is a file
and we will use the
app mode
this ios mean the input output stream
and app will open the file and append
the output in the end
so this is our app mode
there are different modes
so here we are using this app mode
so after this we'll put the semicolon in
the end
now we have to write inside the file so
we'll do the
f1
and this is how we write inside the file
f1 here is the object name
and our user id
is the username and after that we'll add
some space
and then
our
password
that is the password
we want some space between the username
and password that is why we have
used the single quotes and
this is how we write inside the file and
after that we'll again use the system
cls that is the clear screen
all right
now we'll display a message that
registration is successful
as we have already written inside the
file so now we can display this message
saying that registration is successful
now again
control back to the main function
so now we will create the forgot
function
this is the last function
void
forgot
so
this function
would be called when the user
forgots the password or username
so first of all we will create a
variable
option
now we will ask the user that you forgot
your password no worries then we'll ask
the user to press one to search your id
by you by your username and press 2 to
go back to the main menu
so let's start
before that we will use system cls
all right now we'll display the message
saying that
you forget the password
no worries
and then
new slashing
now press one
to search
your
id
by username
all right
now
press 2 to go back to the main menu
all right now after that
we'll use slash d
all right now enter your choice
now we'll take the input
c in
option
after that using the switch case
statement
option
now inside the switch case
we will create cases
so case one
that is when the user selects option one
then
end
will use bracket over here because there
will be
multiple lines
all right
now int count
we'll initialize it with zero
now
some more variables we will declare the
string
s user id
and
s i d
then s pass
so these are some string variables and
count is the integer variable after that
we'll display a message that enter the
username which you remembered
so let's do it
enter the username
you remembered
all right
now
we will take the input from the user
as user id
so once the user entered the username
then we will check
that if that username exists in the file
using the if stream object
as we know stream is used when you want
to read from the file or check from the
file
so we'll
create the if stream class
and the object name would be f2
and
records.txt is the file
all right now using the while loop
we will check
that if
the username
is there inside the file or not
so s id
and s pass
so now
if
s i d equals
s
user id
then
count equals one
so we will assign one to count and
after that we will close the file that
is f2
dot close
so here what we are doing is we are
checking inside the file using the
stream object that if that id or
password is there and if that id is
there then we'll assign one to the count
as initially it was zero and then again
we'll do the same as that we have in the
pre as we have done in the previous
function that if count equals to 1 then
we will
print a message that your account is
found
so let's do that
so as we have closed the file now after
that
will use an if statement
with a condition that if
count equals 1
then we will print a message saying that
your account is found
your password is
s pass
so it will display the password
again the control will be shifted to the
main
where there is the main menu and inside
the else block now
inside the else block will
display a message
saying that
sorry your account is not found
sorry
your account
is not
found
so as the case one ends we will use the
break statement
now we will create case 2.
in case 2 as we have
said that it will simply call the
go back to the main menu so
all we'll do is
call the main function
so that the control will go back to the
main menu
and also we have to create the default
case
in the default case we'll simply print a
message saying that wrong choice please
try again
so we'll use slash d slash slash t
wrong choice
please try again
after that
we'll call the forgot function
so that the user can try again with the
correct option
all right so
we forgot to save this
so let's name it as
register
dot cpp
and save it
now let's try to run this
go to execute and compile and run
there is some error
all right so it must i must be capital
as we have declared
let's try again
so as you can see welcome to login page
this is the menu and this is press one
to login press 2 to register
press 3 if you forgot your password
press 4 to exit
so now we will enter our choice first of
all we need to register so we'll write 2
and our username as sam
addrete
email
this is our username
and now our password
sam
123 is our password
so as we can see the message
registration is successful
after that we will login
as we have registered now we'll try to
log in
sam address email is our username
and sam
one two three other
password
so as you can see your login is
successful
thanks for logging in
now let's say i forgot my password
so i'll press 3 as
if you forgot your password you have to
press 3
so
there's the message you forgot the
password no worries please
press 1 to search your id by your
username so i'll press one
now i'll write my username the last
username i remembered
sam at the rate
email
so your account is found
your password is this as you can see
so let's say
again if i forgot the password and by
chance
i write
semi
at the rate email
then sorry your account is not found is
displayed as sam address email is the
registered customer and not sammy at the
right email so it will display this
message that sorry your account is not
found
and let's say
again if we try to
press let's say 5
then we can see that please select from
the options given above actually we have
to make it below
options given below
but we can do that
else everything is working fine so now
we will click on exit that is 4
and this is the message thank you
so as you can see this is our
registration and login
system in c plus plus and this is how we
can do it
we have created these three functions
that is login function
then there is registration function
after that there is a forgot function if
you forgot the password and the code is
pretty easy and not that much long so
you can try this code on your own
hey guys welcome to another tutorial by
simply learn i hope you all are doing
well
so in this session we will learn how to
create a supermarket billing project in
c plus plus we will create this project
in small parts as there are various
functions that we will be creating for
this project like the add function to
add the goods and products in the market
and delete function to delete some
products etc
also we will create a buyer site where
the buyer can buy the products or food
items of his choice
so now let's go ahead but before that
make sure to subscribe to our channel
and press the bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
now we will move to our code editor that
is dev c plus
so now let's create a new file
and we'll start with
adding the header files first of all
we'll add hash include iostream
then we'll include the f stream file
right hash include f stream because here
we have to do the file handling
operations as well so we'll add the
stream file
now we'll write the namespace standard
now let's save this one and name it
billing one dot cpp
all right so we have named this file
now first of all we'll create a class
and we will declare some variables and
functions
so let's create a class and name the
class as
shopping
inside the class shopping first of all
inside the private scope
we will create or declare some variables
p code
then
float type
price
then another variable discount of load
type
then
name which would be string
all right let's name it p name
p stands for product
all right
now inside the public scope we will
declare the functions
so
let's name this function as menu
because we have to create the menu then
administrator function
all right now let's create a buyer
function a buyer customer whatsoever
all right
now let's create add function
then the edit function
these definitions of these functions we
will create later first of all here we
are declaring these functions after that
we have to remove some products for that
we will create remove function
and then the list function to display
the list
and at last
recept function
all right
so here we have declared the
functions and the variables
so now we'll put semicolon in the end of
the class
and we'll start with the first function
that is the menu function
so we'll write void
class name
then the scope resolution operator
and
menu function
so now inside this function
first of all we will create a
variable
that is choice
and
some more variables like let's say
email
and password
because here we will need email as well
as password for the login purpose so now
we have to create this menu and for that
we have to first of all display
supermarket main menu and after that we
will display that administrator buyer
etc and
all that so now let's start with that
for that we have to display
and
you can display in your own style
like i usually do like this
slash t to add some horizontal space
it's just for formatting
and
after that same will do
to save some time let's just copy and
just paste it
and but now we'll here we'll write
supermarket
main menu
reduce some space
all right now similarly we'll do here
now let's just copy and paste this part
all right now again some space
all right now we'll create a menu in
which
the user have to select the customer
have to select
whether he is an administrator or a
buyer
so let's do that and for that
write c out
slash d slash d slash d to add some
horizontal space
and
all right now
administrator
now similarly here we'll do for
we'll add some space over here
just remove this one
in number two will write buyer
the person who wants to buy stuff
from the market
all right
now
let's format it
we'll add some space over here
now in number three we'll write exit
all right it's pretty much done
after that again if we want to add some
space we can
add some
it's just for formatting purposes you
can do it in your own way
and after that
we have to display a message saying that
please select
so we'll display message
forgot to use semicolon
now we'll take an input from the user
that whatsoever he wants to click on
like if he's an administrator he'll
click on one if he's a buyer then he'll
click on two and if he wants to exit he
can click on three
so we will take an input of choice now
we have to use switch case
and let's create that
switch inside this will write choice we
all know how switch case works
all right now for case one that is
administrator case
we will ask the user to enter the login
credentials if he or she is an
administrator
so let's just do that
so first of all we'll display a message
saying that please login
so
slash t slash d
enter email and then
we'll take the input of email we already
declared this variable
email and
now we'll take the password from the
user
now we'll take the input of the password
so as we have taken the email and
password from the user now we will set
an email and password that only admin
knows and no other person can enter that
and let's say
for that we have to use if else
statements
so
if
email
equals
now let's set the email first of all
robbie at the rate email.com
you can write the email and password as
of your choice
and i'll set the password now as
robbie add the rate one two three
now inside the if block
if the user enters this
that means it is the administrator
and we will call this administrator
function
all right
now in the else block
we'll simply display a message saying
that invalid username password
invalid username
invalid email password
all right after that we'll use the break
to end the case
now we will create case 2
case 2 is for the buyer so we'll write
case
2
and in this case we'll simply call the
buyer function
so this is the case 2 and now we have to
create the case 3
inside the case 3
case 3 is for exit so we'll do exit 0.
it means successful termination of the
program
now
default case
so inside the default case will simply
display a message saying that
please select from the given options
default case will execute if a person
selects any other option
rather than one two three
so
we'll have to instruct him
that please select from the given option
select from the
given options
now
after this we'll use a go to statement
after the switch statement
so go to is a jump statement
so it will help us in jumping to the
main menu again
after the completion of this switch case
and
this m is a label we have to put this
label at the starting of this
menu
so let's do that
right m
now coming back to the next function
so this function is done
so we'll close this function
all right so now we will create an
administrator function in which there
will be different
options inside the administrator menu so
now let's start with that
so we will write
void
shopping that is the class name
scroll resolution operator
administrator
so our function name is administrator
so inside this function
first of all we will declare variable
choice
now after that
we will
create a menu in which there will be
different options
so
let's do that
first of all we'll write slash in
then slash d
some horizontal spaces
so that
administrator
menu
all right
after that
it will be our first option
so first of all we'll write slash and
then slash these
just to make it bit fancy we can do this
add the product
so the user can select this option if he
wants to
add the product not user the
administrator
now we will add some space in this one
now again same
we'll copy it from here then paste it
so here we will change it to the
modified product
modify the product and
we have to adjust it as well
all right now again we'll add some space
so we can copy this one
now
here we write delete the product
now here again
three and make this four
four will be off back to main menu
all right
now after that we will ask the user to
please enter your choice
so we'll display a message saying that
please enter your
choice
all right
now the user
will enter the choice
now again we have to use the switch
case statements
inside this
first case first of all we'll
make and inside this first case
we will call the add function
after that we'll use break statement
now we will create case 2.
in case 2 we will call the modify
function or the edit function
so we'll write
edit
and again the break
now
we'll create case three
in case three
there will be delete function
so we'll name this function as remove
rem stands for remove
now case 4 would be back to main menu
so for that
we'll simply call the menu function
now after case 4 there would be default
case
so we'll write default
and we'll print a message saying that
invalid choice
all right so
after the switch case statement again as
we have done in the previous function
we will mark
m with the go to statement which is a
jump statement
and label it over here
all right so administrator function is
done
after this function now we will create
another function
let's say buyer function
so for that
word shopping
scope resolution operator
buyer
all right
so inside this buyer function first of
all
we'll declare the variables
and choice
now inside this function will ask the
user that he or she wants to buy the
product or go back so let's create that
first of all here we'll write
by the product no first of all we'll
write buyer
yeah
after that
let's get some space
no
first would be
my product
now there will be some space let's copy
it and paste it over here
and
all right selection
okay again
in the second right go back
so the second option is
go back
and we're gonna add some
space
[Music]
all right so these are some options
after that we will ask the user to enter
your choice
then the user will enter his choice
so we are taking the input
after that
we'll use the switch statement
and
choice
so inside the switch statement first of
all we'll create case one
inside this case
we will call
the recept function
inside the recept function all the
operations of the buyer will take place
so this is the receipt function and
after that we'll use break
now we'll create case 2
in case 2 will write
or call the menu function as
2 would be go back as we can see
now default case
write invalid choice
now after this again we'll use the go to
jump statement
and mark here m
all right so after this function
now we will create the add function
so as we know if the user over here
the administrator over here will click
on this add the product that is the
first
case then this add function will be
called so now we will create this add
function
so we'll write void
shopping
add
so inside this function we will use some
file handling operations
so
create an object of fstream class
so data is the name of the object
now we will create some variables like
nc
and
token equals 0
and
float
p
float
d
and
string n
so these are the variables that we have
declared now we have to create a menu
kind of a structure in which we will ask
the user to enter the product code of
product the name of the product price
discount etc
so let's do that
so let's write
add new
product
all right after that we will write the
product code of product will ask the
user to enter the product code of the
product so we'll write slash and
slashing and on slash d
we'll
take the input in p code we have already
declared these variables at the top of
our code
now
we will write
another
message saying that name of the product
for that
i'll write
name
of the product
now we will take the input
in pname
now we'll display
price of the product
we'll take the input in price
now we'll ask to enter the discount
so we'll write
discount of the
discount on the product
all right so
here we are asking the user to enter the
product code of the product then the
user will enter the product code then
the name of the product then he will
enter the name then the price and then
the discount
so after that
now we will have to open a file
because as this add option is being used
by the administrator so we have to store
these product details inside a
particular file so that we can display
to the user that we have these products
in our supermarket
all right so for that
we'll have to use the file handling
operations
data is the name of the object as you
can see
and with the help of data.open
we can open the file
and
the name of the file we can write here
database
dot txt
all right
after that
we want
to open this file in reading mode
ios in will open the file in reading
mode and ios out will open the file in
writing mode
so now
we will use if statement and we'll write
if not
data that is if this file
doesn't exist
then
inside this function will
write data dot open
database dot txt
we will open this basically we will open
this file in writing mode if this file
doesn't exist
and if this file exists then in else
block will do that
ios out
ios app stands for append mode and io
sound out stands for write mode
now
in order to write inside the file
we will give some space and
now we'll write
p code
this is how we can write inside a file
after that p name
then again some space
after that there is price
then again some space
after that
this for discount
then we'll
use slash n
all right so after that we have to close
the file as well
close
data.close after that
in else block
that is if the file exists
then
we will read from the file so this is
how we can read from file
and
p
these are the variables here we are
initializing the file because after that
we have to use the while loop to iterate
through the file
so let's do that
first of all i will write this part and
then i'll explain
inside this we'll use if statement and
if c equals to p code
then
token will be incremented
and
for
initialization
or for iteration
we'll again do that
so here what we are doing is first of
all we are initializing the index of
file here we are initializing the index
because after that we will use the while
loop inside this while loop
we have written
not data dot eof this eof is the end of
file function
this while loop will make sure to check
every content of the file
by iterating it so one by one each
content of the file is checked
if the code matches with the p code that
is if there is a duplicacy then
the token variable which we have
we can see initialize with 0 will be
incremented
it will become one basically after that
for the iteration purpose we are reading
from the file
and after that now
we will close the file
data dot close
all right
now
we'll use if statement that if token
is 1
as we know
if token gets incremented that is if
there's a duplicacy
then again
it will go back to the menu
that is if the product code entered
by the administrator already exist then
he have to enter another product code
because if
the administrator enters the duplicate
code then it will again go back to this
menu
so this go to m
we have to label it over here
all right now in the else block
that is
if
the token value is not incremented
that is the product code entered by the
administrator is unique and not
duplicate then we can enter the
the product that is its product code its
product name its price
so for that we can just copy paste this
part
it's the same
and
we can paste it over here
so here we are writing inside the file
so this is how we can write inside the
file and here we are opening the file in
append and writing mode to write inside
the file we have to open the file in
writing mode
so after that
we will display a message saying that
record inserted
this bracket error the else block will
close over here
all right
now
this add function is done
we have done this part
now we have to create another function
named the edit function
as the add function is used for adding
the products in the market
based on their price
names discounts etc now edit function
will edit the products like if you want
to edit some product like
choose instead of milk or something like
that you can do it with the help of edit
function so we'll do that functionality
in edit function
so let's do that
we'll write void
shopping
edit the name of the function
so inside this function we will create
two
objects
of f stream class
that is data one and data two
that is data and data one
all right
so these two are the objects of a stream
class
now we will
declare some variables
or string n
all right
now we'll write
a message displaying modify the record
so write slash in
now we will ask to enter the product
code
so we'll write
now we will open the file and check if
that file exists or not
now
if
that file doesn't exist
then
we'll simply display a message
saying that file doesn't exist
and in else block
we will open the file
but not the same file the other file
this
file would be database 1 and we will
open this file with the help of this
object that is datavan
so we'll write
data1 dot open
the name of the file would be
database
one dot txt
and we will open this file
in
band mode
and
writing mode
so here what we are doing is we will
save our edited data in this file and we
will rename it to the original name that
is
database.txt
the name of this file is database1.txt
we will save the edited data in this
file and then
we will rename this file as database dot
txt that is the original name of the
file
so now we will write
data
p
code then p name
price
and then
this
so we are initializing this file
basically we want to iterate this file
so
not data dot end of file
it will check each and every content of
the file
all right now
using if statement
we will check if p key equals to p code
p key is the code that is entered by the
administrator
which he wants to edit
so if that matches
then inside the file
write slash n
slash t slash g
then product
of
new code
product new code
here we are asking the administrator to
enter the new code for the
product
so
[Music]
cnc
he or she will enter the code then we
will ask
to enter the name
so write slash installation
name of the
product
p name
and
now the
price
so we'll write
now the discount
now all the updated details of the
product will be entered with the help of
data one object
again some space
then
n
again some space
and here p
then here
d
all right
now
we'll write
a message saying that record edited
record edited all right
after that we'll increment the token
that is token plus plus
now
this was the if block now in else block
gain data one
that is if
the product key for the product code
entered by the administrator doesn't
matches with
any of the product code within the file
then
the old variables that is
p code
p name
price
and after that discount
that is this
all right after that
yeah
we'll do that selection
now outside this else block we'll write
that
e code p name
just for increment purpose
we want the while loop to iterate so
that is why we will use this one
so that this while loop can iterate
all right after this
we will close both the objects that is
data dot close we are closing both the
files
and data one
dot close
now as i already discussed that we have
to rename that database 1 back to the
original name that is database so we
will use two
functions in c plus that is
remove function and rename function with
the help of remove function we will
remove the list that is the database.txt
file we will remove the database.txt
file and then with the help of rename
function we will rename database 1.ext
to database dot txt
so let's do that
remove inside remove we will write the
name of the file
it will basically remove all the list
inside the file
all right now rename function
inside the rename function first of all
we have to write the old name
that is database
one dot txt
then the new name
that is
database dot txt
so now
using this function
this name will be changed to database
dot txt
all right
now
if
token value is not incremented
or we can say is zero
then
it will display a message saying that
record
not
found
sorry
and with that we are done with the
edit function and now we will create
remove function
so we'll write
void
shopping
rem remove
this remove function will be bit similar
to that of the edit function
so now let's start with that
f stream
will create two
objects
data and data one
now
hint p key
and
into token
we'll initialize it with zero
now
we'll display
slash d
delete
product
now we will display
to enter the product code so we'll write
similar to previous function
now data dot open
database
dot txt
we are opening this file
in reading mode
and then we will check
if this file exists or not
so write
so here we will write
if
not
data
then inside will display
file doesn't exist
all right
now in else block
inside the else block we will open the
data one file
and the file name would be database 1
dot txt
and we will open this file
in append and writing mode
all right now after that
the sp code to initialize or iterate
the while loop
we will write this
this is how we read from the file
and here we will use data because we
will
iterate through data.eof
that is data file
now inside the while loop
again we'll do the same as that we have
previously done
data dot eof end of file
now
use if
p code
equals to
p key
then
we'll simply display the message saying
that
product
deleted
successfully
all right and now we will increment the
token
now in the else block we will write
data one
space
then p code
then p name then price then discount
now
rename
then
price
then discount
here the p key entered by the
administrator will check for the first
product code if it matches the if block
executes
in the second iteration it will not
match and else block will execute and
database 1 file will be displayed
in other words in else block all the
products will be displayed except the
one which you want to remove or delete
so we will show this file database 1 and
then rename it with the previous one
that is database
all right so now let's go ahead
we'll do the same in order to white rate
this while loop
now as we've done previously
data don't close as we have to close the
files
data one
dot close
and after that again the remove function
to remove the database file
and rename function
firstly we will write the database 1
that is the old name
make sure to put semicolons then
database
then database
dot txt the new name
all right after that if
tokens is not incremented
that is if token is zero
then it will simply
display a message
saying that record
cannot found
or record not found
so as we have created three major
functions
now we will create another function
named list
it will help us in showing the list to
the customer or the buyer
right shopping
now i will write
list
inside this function
write
the data the object of the stream class
then data.open
will open the database file
dot txt
in the
reading mode
all right after that
we will format it a bit
so after that again
we have to write the product number name
price etc so we'll write
product number
and then
we can use slash d
again name
then
price
and then we'll use lesson
please put them inside the double quotes
and now again we'll copy this part
you can design it in your own way
and
now we can do
the reading part
data
p code
then rename
as you have done previously
price
this
while loop inside the while loop again
we'll use
not data
dot eof
now inside this file
we'll write the product code
product name and the price we'll start
with product code
then
product name
that is b name
after that
price
for the iteration purpose we'll write
again p
code p name
price
discount
all right now after that we will close
the file by writing data dot
close
all right so we are done with this
function as well after this now we will
create the receipt function in which all
the customer operations will take place
so now let's create this
recept function
so we'll write void shopping
rec ipt recept
and now inside this function first of
all we'll create
the object of f stream class
then we'll declare some arrays because
we have to store multiple product keys
and multiple quantities of those
products
so that is why here we have to use
arrays
and then we will declare some variables
so let's start
first of all f stream class the object
of this class is
data
now
after this we'll create
array
array c means array of codes
so i'll declare it in that way
now after that
now we'll decline another array
array of q that is quantity
now
choice variable
then there would be
a counter variable let's say
then discount variable
we'll initialize it with 0
and we'll initialize amount with 0 as
well
all right now
total variable
now we will display a message
saying that recept
so that the user will know that this is
the receipt
now after that we will open a file
that is data dot open will open the
database.txt file and then we'll check
if that file or database exist or not
so
we have done this previously data.open
database
dot txt
will open this file in
reading mode
now we'll use if block and inside this
if block will write not data we are
checking that if this file or database
exist or not
all right
if it doesn't exist if not data that is
if this file doesn't exist or this
database doesn't exist then we will
print the message saying that
empty database
empty with a p
now as this
now in else block we'll write if that
file exists
then first of all we will close the file
that we already opened
now in else block we will call this
list function that we have created
because if the file is created then we
have to call the list function and
will show the user or the customer that
these are the products available in the
supermarket
and for that we are calling this list
function
now we will
design the structure and ask the user to
place the order
so let's do that
please place the order
now again we'll copy this part
all right so now
we'll use
do while loop
the purpose of using this do while loop
is that we have to run a specific part
of the code every time and
the other part of the code we have to
run based on the choice
so now let's start with that
inside the do
block
first of all we will
ask the user
to enter the product code and enter the
product quantity
so first of all
we'll write
product code
enter product code
we'll take the input in the array
now we'll ask the user
to enter
the quantity
all right now
we'll take the product quantity let us
see in
a r r
q
c
now
we will check that
if the product code entered by the user
matches with the product code
that is being already entered
then we will display a message saying
that duplicate product code please try
again
so for that we have to use the for loop
first of all and inside the for loop
will initialize i with 0
i less than
c we have already initialized c with 0
now
i plus plus
so inside this
for loop use if condition and check if
the
product key or product code entered by
the user matches with
the product code that already exist in
the file then we will display a message
saying that duplicate product code so
we'll write
if
rac of
c that is entered by the user
equals array of c
i
so i will keep on iterating as we have
used for loop
so inside this if we will display a
message saying that
duplicate product code
please
please try again
all right
now
we'll write go to m
again jump statement as we have already
discussed
now after this
we will increment c plus plus that is if
the product
key is not duplicate then c will
increment that is the counter will
increment
all right now
we will display a message saying that do
you want to buy another product or not
all right
all right so as we have displayed this
now we will take the input of the user
see in choice that whether he wants to
buy the product or not
so this is our do loop
now we'll have to use after this do
block we'll have to use while loop as
we're using the do while loop
now here is the condition that if the
user will press yes that is y
then
this loop will execute
all right
now
we'll make a design structure so we'll
write c out
and
slash n
slash and slash t slash t slash t
and now we'll write receipt
all right now after that
now we'll write product number
sorry by mistake we write
capital n now we'll write product number
then i will write
product quantity
product name sorry
now
product quantity
then the price
now we'll use the for loop to iterate
through the file so we'll write
4 and i equal 0 i less than c i plus
plus
so now inside this for loop first of all
because we have to do the iteration we
will open the file data.open
database
double quotes database dot txt
and we'll open this file in reading mode
so ios
in
all right so after that
we will kind of initialize this file
we'll write p code
p name
then price
after that there was discount
all right
now
as we have done previously while
not
data dot eof that is end of file
and inside this while loop we will check
we are actually matching if the code
entered by the user that is a r r c i is
equal to the code present in the file
and if so
then we will do the calculations and add
those file in the customer basket
so let's do that p code
equals area of c of i
here we are checking
if so
then
we'll do the amount amount equals to
price of the product into the quantity
of the product
all right after that we'll have to do
the discount part
so in this part we know that the
discount is calculated by multiplying
amount with discount divided by 100
and then we have to subtract it from the
amount
so let's do that amount minus
amount
into
discount
divided by 100
all right
now after that as we are done now we'll
have to add discount to the total
variable
because
in this part
the total amount
after getting discount is stored in this
disk variable now we'll add this
variable to the total variable all right
so as this is done now we will
print this part
so in this part we are just printing so
we'll
do the slash n and now
then p code
then p name
then
array of q of i
array of q
i
all right now after that price
then amount
and amount after discount or will write
discount only
because we have to write the variable
all right now we'll have to add the
slashed is in between them
so let's do that part
all right so we have added the slash
these in between them for the formatting
purpose
now to iterate the file for the
iterating purpose we'll do the same
that p code
rename
price
discount
all right now
after this while loop
now we will have to close the data file
we'll write
data dot close
[Music]
so after this data dot close we have to
print the total amount so let's do that
first of all we'll do some
design part like let's say selection
slash in
now
just for design purpose
now we'll simply print the total
variable
we'll write first of all total amount
now the variable
total
all right so everything is done except
the main function now in the main
function
we'll write
so int main
now inside this main function as we know
we have created the class shopping class
so we will create the object of that
shopping class and we will call
the menu function with the help of that
object as we know that is the first
function that must be called so we'll
write shopping
and let's say the object of this is
s
and s dot
menu function
so as we know the menu function is the
topmost function
so this
menu will display when we run the file
so now everything is done
and now let's run this file
let's press compile and run
i hope it works
there are some errors
alright so 335 okay
so this is the error and now
57 line
line number 57
yeah we have to use double equal to
and one more error is there i think
now let's try to run this
there might be some more errors
as you can
all right after this 386
okay so we haven't labeled this one
we have to label m
now let's try to run this
so here we can see supermarket main menu
first is
administrator then second if you're a
buyer three to exit
so first we'll login as an administrator
so as you can see please login
so now we'll enter the admins
email
so i'll write
robbie
at the rate
email
dot com
now the password
robbie address one two three
now this is the administrator menu as
you can see first is the add product if
you want to add the product second to
modify the product three to delete the
product and four to back to main menu
so now i'll click on
like i want to add the product so i'll
write one i'll press one and enter add
new product so now i have to add product
code of the product
like let's say the product of code of
product is one
name of group product let's say juice
and price is
70
and discount on product is
two percent record
inserted now again
i want to add
so i'll click on one
product code of product would be two
now name of product would be let's say
bread
price
30
discount again 2
record inserted now again
product now would be
let's say butter
3
butter
price of product would be 60
discount would be four
now fourth product
sorry add product now product could be
fourth
and this would be
let's say x
price would be 170
discount
three percent
record inserted so now we will check
that these records are inserted or not
so we can cross check it by
going here and open this database file
so as we can see one juice
product code one is juice
price is 70 2 is the discount
then second is bread third is butter
four is egg so first this is the product
code this is the price and this is the
discount on that product
now let's come back and modify the
product
let's say first product was juice
and we want to modify that product
so what we'll do is we'll add the
product code 1 and the new product code
would be
1 only let's say we don't want to change
that
and name of the product would be
chips
we'll replace it with chips
price would be
20
and discount would be two percent
so record edited as we can see
here record edited and now we can check
so now we'll open this database file
so as you can see
as you can see one chips
two bread three butter four eggs so the
first product that was used is replaced
by chips
so this function is done now let's try
the delete function
we'll click on 3 for delete
and now
we have to enter the product code of the
product which we want to delete so let's
say we want to delete the fourth product
and we can see product deleted
successfully we can check that
as you can see
there are three products left the fourth
one got deleted
so now let's go back and let's check if
the customer wants to buy the product
how can he or she buy so let's first of
all we click on form to go back to them
so now let's click on two as a buyer to
buy some products
now we'll click on one to buy the
product
so as you can see our products are chips
bread and butter
so product numbers are 1 2 3 and their
price are 20 30 60 respectively
and now we will enter the product code
of the product which we want to buy so
i'll click on one
and the quantity i say 2
want to buy another product or not
they're asking if you want to buy
another product if yes then press y and
if no then press n
so we'll click on why because you want
to buy another product
so now i'll click on two that is bread
product quantity i'll add product
quantity as four breads
and now butter so for that first of all
why
for butter i will click on three
product code of butter is three now
quantity would be two
now
i don't want to buy any other product so
i'll click on n
so as you can see
product numbers product name their
quantity price amount and amount with
discount
and the total is there that is 272.
and if we wish to buy another product so
we can click on one else we can click on
two to go back
so this is our recept our total amount
is there
so this is our complete project on
supermarket billing in c plus you can
try it although the code is bit long
approx 400 to 450 lines of code
but it is worth trying
all right guys with that we have come to
the end of this session
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up i hope it really helped you
all
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you